Ich könnte auch mit Musik meine Seite nur machen, so Hintergrund, so plätschern.
Das habe ich schon mal probiert, das ist keine gute Idee.
Das klingt total scheiße.
Für uns nicht oder für die Hörer nicht?
Für keinen.
Sowohl als auch.
Also die macht die Musik aggressiv.
Ich will ein Cocktail-Gefühl haben. Die Musik macht dich aggressiv. Das heißt, wenn wir uns dann nachher wieder streiten über irgendein Thema, dann muss ich die Musik einspielen und dann geht's richtig los.
Dann wäre ich jetzt zum Stier.
Anyway, hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Ihr seid so wie Hund und Katze. Die Katze zieht den Schwanz ein, wenn sie Angst hat und der Hund wedelt mit dem Schwanz, wenn er Angst hat. Also die Signale bei beiden sind genau andersrum. Du wirst entspannt bei der Musik und er riecht auch bei der Musik.
Ein aufgestelltes Schwanz bei einer Katze heißt also aggressiv ist, bei einem Hund heißt es Freundschaft.
Genau, wie so.
Okay, für den Moment wusste ich jetzt nicht, ob die Sendung noch jugendfrei ist. Auf jeden Fall wollen wir jetzt mal anfangen. Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Mobile Max. Ausgabe Nummer 45. Es hat keine drei Wochen gedauert, bis wir uns mal wieder zusammengefunden haben.
Ein alter Frösche.
Und wir haben keine Themen.
Fortgesetzte Problematik hier mit Zeit und Verpeilung und sonstigen Dingen. Vor allem haben wir Menge los.
Quatsch, wir wollten einfach noch die Eindrücke auf uns einschwingen lassen.
Genau, ich finde das Timing ist jetzt aber auch perfekt. Also das Timing könnte jetzt so schlechter nicht sein, besser nicht sein. Denn alles Mögliche ist jetzt an den Start gekommen. Es gibt iPads, es gibt MacBooks, es gibt Ankündigungen, Zukunftsvisionen.
Opera Mini.
Und Opera Mini. So sieht's aus, so sieht's aus, so sieht's aus. Ja, wollen wir denn dann gleich mal einsteigen hier mit dem kleinen Gerät?
Mit dem ganz kleinen oder nur mit dem mittelkleinen Gerät?
Mit dem mittelkleinen Gerät.
Wir hatten alle Gelegenheit, einen zu betatschen, oder?
Ja, ich hatte letzte Woche das Vergnügen, das erste Mal. Wir reden vom iPad, dem Gerät, was den Voraussagen der Auguren glauben darf, alles irgendwie revolutioniert. Seitgeschnitten Brot. Ob das dann bedeutet, dass man das iPad dann auch in den Toast steckt?
Das kann man durchaus tun.
Das wird auch mal was.
Das probiere ich dann mit deinem aus.
Habt ihr schon Willet Blend gesehen, wie es heißt?
Ich hab's mir nicht angeguckt.
Ich hab Probleme mit Gewaltvideos im Internet.
Da fällt mir ein, dass wir uns das noch nicht vorgestellt haben. Wollen wir das noch mal machen?
Ja, wo bin ich?
Was ist denn die beste Methode? Ist die beste Methode, einer stellt alle anderen vor, jeder stellt irgendjemand anders vor oder jeder stellt sich selber vor?
Also ich bin Dennis und meine Stimme weiß ich nicht, wo die ist. Ich glaube aber, die war mal links.
Ach so, die Balance. Jetzt weiß ich auch gerade gar nicht, wo du bist. Mal gucken, wo bist du denn? Da muss ich hier nochmal kurz...
Schon wieder? Na ich bin immer noch Dennis und vielleicht bin ich ja jetzt links.
Du bist ein bisschen links. Aber das hören wir jetzt glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, hören wir das jetzt gerade im Kopfhörer?
Wo haben wir hier noch den Max und wo ist der? Wo höre ich dich?
Also ich glaube, ich müsste ja so tendenziell rechts sein, wenn alles seine Richtigkeit hat, wenn alles mit rechtem Ding zu geht.
Hier geht immer alles mit rechtem Ding.
Meine Ohren sagen, du kommst mitten aus meinem Gehirn.
Jetzt bist du rechts, wo du hingehörst. So, das Detail hatte ich hier noch nicht so. Gut, werden wir überhaupt gehört?
Ja, die freuen sich alle im Chat schon.
Achso, ja hier tatsächlich, da ist schon ein Echo auf den Inhalt. Das ist gut, denn wir werden uns bestimmt wieder komplett verhaspeln. So, das iPad, wie war es denn? Also, wer hat es denn zuerst angefasst von uns?
Ich glaube du.
Dennis, wann hast du es gehabt?
Vor, was, heute Samstag vor acht Tagen, glaube ich.
Vor acht Tagen, dann warst du glaube ich sogar noch vor mir. Oder? Ist ja auch schon wieder so spät. Und wie war es?
Also es sieht erst mal so ganz schick aus.
Achso, warte mal, du hast dich jetzt schon vorgestellt, ne? Max?
Ich bin Max.
Du bist Max.
Und den hast du wohl gepackt rechts?
Ich bin rechts.
Achso, ich muss mich ja auch noch vorstellen.
Genau, und du musst dann auf, wer bist du eigentlich? Wer sind Sie eigentlich?
Das frage ich mich auch häufiger.
Und was tun Sie hier?
Und ich bin Tim und damit ist die Truppe mal wieder komplett. Abgesehen von unserer möglichen Erweiterung Hucke.
Unserem Backup.
Unserem Backup, der hat sich nicht gemeldet, der ist noch im Silo. Ja, im Raketensilo. Das ist unsere Geheimwaffe. Da drücken wir hier auf diesen roten Knopf, der hier auf dem Tisch steht.
Und dann ist BitTorrent so weg.
Wenn man mal wieder auf dem Tisch steht. Die sind ja nachher alle auf der Autobahn. Auf der Flucht vor dem Vulkan. Ich hatte schon die Befürchtung, dass die beiden Sendungen jetzt hier gleichzeitig live laufen.
Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass wir vielleicht eine zusammen machen können.
Ja, dazu ist es jetzt nicht gekommen. Aber genau, warum überhaupt? Weil jetzt bis gestern Abend Republika war hier in Berlin. Und da hat es Spaß gemacht. Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir jetzt noch so leicht geschallert sind. Also der Grund, warum ich so leicht geschallert bin. Wie lange warst du auf dieser Party?
Gar nicht so lange.
Ja, schon.
Aber ich bin trotzdem ein bisschen durch.
Aber du warst die ganze Zeit davor da. Ja, es war erstaunlich, wie voll das da war. Also insgesamt auf der Veranstaltung, aber eben auch.
Und ich fand auch gut, also aus meiner Perspektive hat es erstaunlich gut geklappt, diese wir machen mal eine ernsthafte Web 2.0-Konferenz, aber auf der anderen Seite auch wieder dieses Klassentreffen der deutschen Blogosphäre so ein bisschen hinzukriegen. Das war echt... Haben sie gut gemacht?
Ja, und gesellschaftliche Themen und politische Fragestellungen.
Definitiv, das war echt wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Von allem, was man so braucht für eine YouTube-Konferenz.
Mir geht es ja ähnlich. Ich finde, das ist eine gute Sache. Also man kann von so etwas Gemütlichem eigentlich nicht genug haben, aber das ist jetzt schon mal cool, dass wir sowohl jetzt im Frühjahr als auch im Winter hier so eine Veranstaltung haben. Fehlt noch was für einen frühen Herbst.
Ja, gibt es die zweimal oder wie?
Es gibt ja noch den Kongress, der ist ja auch mal ganz gemütlich, wobei er natürlich ein bisschen aus den Nähten platzt. Aber mal schauen, wie lange das bei der Republik noch dauert. Zurück zum iPad. Also Dennis, wie war es? Dennis, du hast das zuerst angefasst. Mein allererster Reihleicht, mein erstes Mal.
Ganz kurz in der Hand, kam mir ein bisschen schwer vor. Also ich glaube, so zum entspannt lesen, weiß ich noch nicht, ob das so das Wahre ist. Also man dauerhaft sozusagen nichts mit dem Ding macht und das nur festhält. Dann wär's mir glaub ich ein bisschen zu schwer, weil man aktiv irgendwie so klicken muss. Dann ist es vielleicht ein bisschen anders. Ich hab's im Freien gesehen, also mit wirklich drumrum in alle Richtungen freier Himmel. Und da war es nicht so gut zu sehen. Dafür habe ich es auch mal in geschlossenen Räumen gesehen. Und da sieht es wirklich sehr schick aus mit dem glossy Display. Das Scrolling ist wirklich sauschnell. Also da ruckelt nichts, es ist flutschig. Und so wie das iPhone im Vergleich zum Android, könnte man sagen. Weil da finde ich nämlich, dass es nicht flutschig ist. Und ich habe ein bisschen zugeguckt, wie jemand den Bookstore da vorgestellt hat. Es war auch alles sehr schick, auch mit dem Umblättern und so. Es ist alles schick gemacht auf jeden Fall. Aber so richtig länger konnte ich es mir noch nicht angucken.
Ich habe relativ viel Zeit gehabt mit diversen iPads. Ich meine, auf der Republika sind ja nun wirklich einige rumgeführt.
Das war das Posertool Nummer eins. Ach, du hast noch kein iPad, so.
Als der Unbekannte, der nicht genannt werden möchte. Als er seinen iPad für uns rausgeholt hat, bildet sich innerhalb von Minuten eine Menschentraube um ihm herum. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er meinte, er hofft, dass es endlich in Deutschland auf den Markt kommt, damit er es irgendwo rausnehmen kann, ohne ständig angestarrt zu werden. Das ist eine Hoffnung, die sich nicht so weiterfüllen wird.
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Ich bin sehr angetan gewesen. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt schon vom Simulator angetan gewesen, als ich da mit diesem iPad-Simulator rumgespielt habe und das Scrollen in Safari einfach reinklicken und ziehen ist. Wenn man es dann wirklich in den Fingern hat, ist es natürlich noch mal zacken besser. Die Karten-Applikation ist ziemlich grandios.
Was ist an dir eigentlich anders als an der iPhone-Version?
Dass sie größer ist.
Also es gibt keine neuen Features, sondern andere, die größer sind? Welche?
Diese ganze Direction-Geschichte, also roten Ladern, die ist etwas anders gelöst. Also da nutzen sie auch den Space ganz anders. Wenn du halt so ein Ziel angibst, dann wird natürlich erstmal da so eine Linie gezogen, aber dann erscheint unten noch so ein blauer Balken, wo du dann eben vor und zurück gehen kannst. Das gibt es ja auch auf dem iPhone, aber das iPhone dann halt...
Entweder oder. Beim iPhone ist es entweder oder. Entweder du hast die einzelnen Abbiegestationen oder du hast die Karte und beim iPad ist beides gleichzeitig im Bildschirm oder wie?
Nein, beim iPhone ist es vor allem so, du gehst dann zu dem nächsten Punkt, wo du halt, was weiß ich, abbiegen, Weg ändern, Straße ändern musst. Und dann springt er da halt hin und das ist so ein schneller Zoom. Aber du kriegst halt diesen Weg dahin nicht so mit. Und beim iPad, wobei ich mir gut vorstellen kann, dass ich das generell um etwas handelt, was dann auch beim nächsten iPhone, also mit iPhone 4 kommen wir ja nachher noch drauf, dann auch so funktionieren wird. Also ich sehe das eher als so ein iPhone-Ding, also iPhone OS-Feature, als jetzt vielmehr so ein iPad-Feature, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall blinken dann so die Teilstrecken dann noch mal so blau auf, während der Rest der Strecke grau ist. Also sie haben mehr daran gearbeitet, dieses eigentliche Routenfinding ein bisschen besser zu visualisieren. Aber, und die Maps-Applikation auf dem iPad macht halt auch Terrain-View, so wie Google Maps. Das ist ja beim iPhone auch nicht drin.
Naja, aber das kriegst du dann alles hinterher. Also ich fand erstmal die schiere...
Du hast noch einen Unterschied gefragt, das sind die Unterschiede. Ansonsten ist es vor allem größer.
Ich fand die schiere Größe extrem beeindruckend.
Da merkt man wirklich, dass das etwas anderes ist mit dem iPad zu arbeiten.
Dann, was fand ich noch? Dann habe ich mir gestern mal ein bisschen Keynote und Numbers ein bisschen ausführlicher angeguckt. Das ist, davon bin ich erstmal noch nicht so ganz begeistert. Also ich habe wirklich ewig gebraucht. Und ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht rausgekriegt, wie es geht, wie man in Keynote zum Beispiel ein Bild löscht. Also das ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdig. Du kannst also Bilder verschieben, ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ein Bildrahmen nehmen und den Inhalt auswechseln, das ist auch total easy. Also es gibt Echtpunkte, die sind so extrem einfach. Aber dieses Menü zu sehen, also was man so auf dem iPhone als Text kennt, um dann den Delete-Button zu haben. Ich habe es bis zum Ende nicht vernünftig reproduzieren können. Ich glaube, irgendwie längere Zeit auf den Seitenrand oder auf den oberen Rand gedrückt halten mit dem Finger und dann im richtigen Moment loslassen oder sowas. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Da ist auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge Optimierung notwendig, glaube ich, damit das wirklich frustfrei geht. Aber das ist, ja, was war noch so? Das Akkordeon war lustig. So dieses Akkordeon, kennst du das?
Ich habe davon gelesen, dass es das gibt, aber ich habe das nicht.
Das ist so total albern. Du hast so ein Akkordeon und kannst dann das iPad so vor dir halten, ein bisschen Akkordeon spielen. Geht auf dem iPhone auch nur schlecht.
Aber ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass man das iPad auseinanderziehen und wieder zusammenstauchen sollte.
Ja, das nicht, aber du kannst halt die Tassen drücken.
Jetzt gibt es dann ein iPad Flashlight 2.0.
Juhu, endlich.
Ernsthaft?
Jetzt wird der Raum heller.
Aber wenn es auch das Akkordeon gibt, gibt es ja auch neue Flashlights.
Das Akkordeon ist ja das wirklich, das ist richtig aufwendig gemacht und macht schön Krach und so. Das ist schon ganz cool. Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich so, man ahnt das.
Bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal beim Gerät und nicht so sehr bei diesen Applikationen. Sonst noch Eindrücke? So vom Handling her jetzt nur so die Hardware erstmal.
Es war tatsächlich, ich bin einer von denen, also der erste, ich sag's hier so einfach gerne, meinte, die Leute nehmen es in der Hand und sagen, entweder immer, es ist leichter als ich dachte oder schwerer als ich dachte. Ich gehöre zur ein bisschen schwerer als ich dachte Fraktion.
Das hat er mir auch erzählt und deswegen meinte, es ist anscheinend genau richtig, wenn die eine Hälfte meinte, es ist schwer und die andere meinte, es sei ganz schön leicht, dann muss es ja stimmen.
Die Logik verstehe ich nicht so hundertprozentig, aber okay.
Was gibt es da nicht zu verstehen?
Das ist halt der Mittelwert.
Genau. Einfach machen, aber du hast dir zumindest die Mitte von beiden getroffen, wenn alle sagen würden, es ist zu schwer, hast du was falsch gemacht.
Nicht, dass es zu schwer ist, sondern es ist schwerer als ich gedacht habe. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es zu schwer ist. Ich kam mit der Tastatur am Anfang, also mit halten und dabei tippen, mit dem Daumen. Dafür ist zumindest die breite Tastatur definitiv zu breit. Da geht es mit der Hochkantastatur besser. Aber so auf dem Schoß liegen, kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass man damit echt gut tippen kann. Umlaut tasten würde ich mir noch wünschen und so ein Späßchen, aber das ist echt, ich glaube, da kann man wirklich ein bisschen längere Texte auch drauf tippen, ohne dass man Probleme kriegt.
Das kannte ich aber genau, was mir aufgefallen ist. Ich habe ja gesurft mit dem Ding und dann kam mir auch, wollte ich eine Adresse eingeben und dann kam halt auch die Tastatur und dann willst du so tippen und dann denkst du auch, ok, dann drücke ich halt auch Return, wie man das oben in der URL-Leiste halt auch machen würde, aber es war keine Return-Taste beim Safari, sondern es war eine...
Öffnen-Taste.
Öffnen-Taste, aber das ist erstmal irritierend, weil du suchst halt irgendwie die Return-Taste, weil er simuliert ja schon irgendwie eine richtige Tastatur und dann kommst du voll durcheinander.
Ich fand das sehr lustig, die haben ja diese kleinen Nippel hier, die man beim MacBook so unter F und J hat, diese kleinen, die gibt es da auch in der Optik. Das finde ich so... Ach, das bin ja nicht aufgefallen.
Aber es sind doch genau die kleinen Feinheiten, die das irgendwie...
Aber man spürt sie erstaunlicherweise gar nicht. Haben sie so gemacht, dass man, die sind ein bisschen flach, sollten sie mal bei der nächsten Version ein bisschen höher machen, damit man die Optik spürt.
Was hab ich gehört, das iPad hat keinen Vibrator drin?
Richtig. Kann nicht vibrieren.
Das ist ja schon ein bisschen lame für manche Spiele, oder?
Man kann das überhaupt für Spiele schon so richtig nutzen. Gibt es irgendein Spiel, wo man das gut nutzen kann?
Es gibt ja auch eine App, dass wenn du die Kasten drückst, das ist immer mit einer kurzen Vibration irgendwie konfirm.
Warte mal, was meinst du jetzt? Die Vibration, ob man die Vibration für Spiele nutzen kann?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte ja auch sagen können, dass das nur rein als Sound-Ausgabe, wenn ein Alert kommt, dass nur dann die Vibration möglich ist.
Jede Frage.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch eigentlich nicht, wenn...
Ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass Spiele das nutzen können, aber ich kann dir jetzt auch gerade kein Beispiel nennen.
Also ich kann mich an so ein paar Sydia-Sachen erinnern, die das konnten, aber die können ja immer auf mehr zugreifen und bei Spielen. Insofern würde ich da ehrlich gesagt auch nicht viel vermissen.
Mir geht es einfach um die Signalisierung, die halt weg ist, wenn das Ding halt gemutet ist, aber eine Mute-Taste hat es ja auch nicht. Also das haben sie ja weggekürzt für den...
Jetzt lange, leise Taste drücken.
Für das Scroll-Log. Fertig, das war's.
Zur Hardware?
Willst du immer noch eins kaufen?
Ja.
Unbedingt?
Und willst du mit oder ohne?
Mit. Also bei mir sieht es jetzt so aus, dass ich hoffentlich, also ein Freund fliegt Ende des Monats nach USA und ich hoffe mal, dass das dazu führt, dass er jetzt den Europastaat verschoben hat, dass er in Amerika genug Geräte verfügbar hat, dass er mir dann eins mitbringen kann.
Na toll, du bist also schuld, dass es hier keine gibt.
Ich bin dann schuld, dass es hier keine gibt, und dann stelle ich mich mit dahin und sage, guck mal, ich habe ein iPad.
Ja, es ist auch kein Spaß, weil dann auch alle zu dir kommen und um dich herum stehen und du nie in Ruhe dein Ding benutzen kannst.
Wann will der in die USA fliegen?
Der kommt am 3. Mai zurück.
Mal hoffen, dass der Vulkan bis dahin schon wieder Ruhe gegeben hat.
Hoffen wir mal, dass es das ist.
Also im letzten Jahr waren da zwei Jahre Asche gespuckt, angeblich. Vor 100 Jahren oder so circa.
18, 20 war das.
Oder 200 Jahre fast.
Die ganzen internationalen Gäste der Republik sind hier gegroundet. Das ist gerade ganz lustig.
Das ist echt die erste Republik, die während eines...
Dann bin ich dran jetzt mit iPad, oder?
Vulkan aus doppelter Zeit.
Also ich hab das Ding in Wien das erste Mal in der Hand gehabt. Und ja, mein erster Eindruck war wie erwartet. Also ich hatte keine... Wobei ich irgendwie dann...
Dann musst du mal erzählen, was du erwartet hast und erzählen, was du getwittert hast.
50% der Reaktionen, die ich... Also 45% der Reaktionen, die ich bekommen habe, war so gut und die anderen 45% waren so schlecht. Und der Rest fragte nur, was ich denn erwartet hätte. Na, wie erwartet? Also die Größe, das Gewicht, die Haptik, der Speed, wobei ich sagen muss, dass für meinen Geschmack diese Beschreibung von wie unglaublich schnell das Teil sei eher dazu geführt hat, dass ich es geführt hätte. Es wäre nicht so schnell, wie sie alle meinen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie schnell die Apps an sich sind. Ich fand aber, das Scrolling war sehr butterweich.
Ja gut, Scrolling ist ja auch eine Frage der Grafik-Performance vor allem, nicht so sehr des Overall-Speeds. Also auf gar keinen Fall ist das Ding langsam. Also beim Foto-App ist das geil. Du gehst da irgendwie auf Safari drauf und tralala. Und kritische Sachen haben sie einfach super beschleunigt. Also gerade hier so, was du sagst, hier so Photoscaling, Video und der ganze Kram, da merkt man einfach, dass sie da jetzt lang genug an dieser ganzen Grafikkarten- und OpenGL-Treibergeschichte rumgedokt dort haben, um dann einfach das Maximum rauszuholen. Ja, also ich war jetzt nicht, ich war ja nun geprägt von vielen Vorurteilen und Berichten und so weiter. Und ich würde sagen, insofern entsprach das Gerät einfach meinen Erwartungen. Bloß die Erwartungen waren natürlich hoch. Weil das ist natürlich schon so ein Teil, wo wenn da was falsch läuft, dann wäre das halt nicht so gut. Und ich bin gespannt, wie das mit diesen berichteten WLAN-Problemen ausgeht, ob das jetzt wirklich ein Problem darstellt oder nicht.
Erzähl doch mal über die WLAN-Probleme, da weiß ich ja wieder gar nichts von. Ich weiß nur, dass es im Sonnenlicht wohl zu warm werden könnte oder irgendwie so.
Ich habe da keine Erfahrung. Ich habe nur gelesen, dass Leute meinen, aber das habe ich schon fast bei jedem Apple-Produkt irgendwann mal gelesen. Von daher ist mir die Dimension dessen noch überhaupt nicht bewusst. Aber ich wollte noch mal kurz von meinen Eindrücken berichten. Es gibt eine Sache, die mir nicht gefällt und es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen. Erstmal, was zwar an sich ganz gut gelöst ist, aber was ich immer noch als Nerf-Faktor finde, ist halt einfach dieses Autorotate, bzw. dieses Programm ändert seine Ansicht, wenn man es dreht. Das heißt, nicht ganz so haarsträumt wie beim aktuellen iPhone, mit Podcast-Liste in Porträt-Modus, und dann drehst du das Ding ein paar Grad und dann hast du dieses bekloppte Coverflow. Ja, ja, wir wissen, ein iPod. Coverflow ist das komplette Prinzip, was dir angeboten wird. Dass es dasselbe anders dargestellt wird, damit kann ich leben. Nur, dass irgendwas, was dir gerade angezeigt wird, danach irgendwie so überhaupt nicht mehr in der Form gehen kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nur beim iPhone iPod.
Ja gut, aber du hast aber auch beim iPad eben solche Sachen, was weiß ich, zum Beispiel Pages. Dann drehst du das Ding halt quer, da kannst du halt zwar schreiben, aber du kannst halt nicht mehr diese Menü-Dinger aufrufen, sondern nur im Porträt-Modus hat das Ding oben die Möglichkeiten, Dokumente zu schließen oder zu laden.
Das ist eine gewöhnliche Sache. Ich fand die Drehung wesentlich flotter als beim iPhone.
Ist auch ein bisschen hektisch. Knifflig war für mich ja von Anfang an, als wir über das Tablett philosophiert haben, dieses, wie hält man das Teil eigentlich? Was mich wirklich ein bisschen pissig macht, ist, dass wenn du das einfach auf den Tisch legst, dass du damit eigentlich gar nicht arbeiten kannst, weil es unten halt rund ist. Und es liegt zwar schon im wesentlichen gerade auf, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es einfach wackeln würde, wenn du es einfach so auf den Tisch legst, es liegt schon, aber wenn du halt im Randbereich touchen möchtest und das mit so ein bisschen Energie machst, dann wackelt das Teil halt einfach. Und das muss ich sagen, finde ich...
Du willst mit runterkleben.
Ja gut, aber dann ist es halt ein Hardware-Fail, wenn ich als erstes da erstmal wieder so einen Gummi-Mutscher da hinten dran machen muss, damit das irgendwie wieder gerade ist. Also da hätten sie schon ein bisschen weniger Kurven da reinhauen können, damit das Teil einfach mal stabil steht.
Aber ich bin ehrlich gesagt, ich hab's nicht mal versucht auf den Tisch zu legen. Also ich hatte das auch...
Aber sonst musst du das doch die ganze Zeit in der Hand halten. Ich seh halt einen großen Wert da drin, das Teil einfach neben meinem Rechner zu haben, während ich irgendwie was hacke. Und dann hab ich da halt einfach meine Doku drauf. So, wie so ein Buch eben. Und blätter da halt drin und mach irgendwas, damit ich nicht immer mit Fenstern hin- und herschalten muss. Wenn ich da aber so einen Wackelteil habe, dann ist das irgendwie blöd. Ich seh sogar die Hauptanwendung für das iPad im Wesentlichen als Buchersatz.
Ja, schon. Aber wenn du Doku lesen willst, weil du an einem Rechner hacken willst, dann willst du ja auch ab und zu mal schnell ein Keyword aus dem Buffer mit Copy und Paste oder so.
Ja, das mag sein, dass ich das auch mal tue. Du beziehst dich jetzt wahrscheinlich so auf Programmieren und so. Ich könnte mir auch viele andere Handbuch-Situationen vorstellen, wo das irgendwie nicht so ist. Und es muss ja auch nicht unbedingt immer neben dem Rechner sein, sondern es kann auch neben der Telefonanlage, der ich gerade schraube, neben dem Gerät X, mit dem ich mich gerade auseinandersetze. Und ich hab halt einfach meine Manual-Datenbank auf meinem iPad und dann hab ich das halt immer dabei. Wo man halt so ein Laptop dann eben nicht mitschleppt. So eine Anwendung. Und ich seh halt das iPad im Wesentlichen so als Couch-Potato-Device. Da kannst du dein Fernsehprogramm drauf haben, da kannst du natürlich deine Webseiten, deine News lesen, gehst in die Küche, hast du deine Rezepte da drauf. So ne Sachen. Naja, also das ist jetzt aber auch nur ein erster Eindruck. Ich hab das Ding ja auch nach 20 Minuten wieder aus der Hand gegeben. Von daher kann das durchaus sein, dass sich dieser Eindruck dann nochmal relativiert.
Was ich so richtig geil fand, war mal Twitter-Klient. Auf dem Ding. So Tweetdeck und so.
Hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
War nicht ganz hübsch. Also ich hab ne Menge Software ausprobiert. Und so ein Car-Racing-Spiel, was so weit ganz lustig war und was von der Grafik her einen ziemlich guten Eindruck machte.
Ja, das Spiel mit dem Auto.
Dann eben Pages und Keynote und Numbers mal kurz. Fand ich alles drei nicht sonderlich intuitiv zu bedienen. Also da muss echt noch ne Menge passieren. Brushes, also das ist so dieses viel beworbene Zeichentrogramm, ist einfach großartig, macht echt Spaß. Das war so richtig so, ja. Und dann mit dem Finger drumballen. Wobei, da kriegt man auch mit so richtig, haben sie es noch nicht im Griff, weil Brushes funktioniert halt sehr stark. Wenn du zwei Finger hast, hast du Pinch und Zoom. Und wenn man das Ding, wenn man damit einfach rumspielt und dann so Fingerfarben quasi vor sich hat, dann möchte man, dann ist es einfach fast absolut intuitiv, dass man irgendwann auch mal einen zweiten und dritten Finger mit drauflegt und mitziehen will. Und plötzlich geht es einfach nicht mehr. Plötzlich fängt er an, rum zu zoomen. Hast du eine gute Geste.
Und man soll es auch mit drei Fingern malen, oder mit der ganzen Hand.
Genau, so.
So wie im Kindergarten.
Genau, das will ich haben. Also ich glaube, das ist, dass das iPad ist. Das ist noch nicht fertig. Das fängt gerade erst an. Wir können jetzt angucken, wie da so eine Evolution beginnt, wie sie es nach und nach lernen. Und ich glaube, unter dem Aspekt muss man es auch kaufen. Also ich habe viele Leute erlebt, die gesagt haben, ja ich finde es schick und so, aber ich weiß nicht wofür ich das brauche. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt auch nicht, wofür ich das wirklich dringend brauche. Ich finde aber diesen Entwicklungsprozess der nächsten Computer-Generation oder wie auch immer, also das nächste Hauptbildschirm ins Internet, finde ich eine spannende Sache. Und da möchte ich gerne früh dabei sein. Das ist so der Grund, warum ich das gerne haben möchte.
Na klar, Early Adopter Punishment Fee schlägt dann hier zur Buche, wie das immer so ist.
Ab 500 Euro, ja, schon ein ordentlicher Preis, oder?
Vor allen Dingen, für 500 Euro wäre schon...
Ich finde das jetzt nicht so teuer, muss ich sagen.
Oh ja, ist ja schon ein Zusatz-Luxus-Gerät. Brauchen tut man es nicht wirklich. Schon klar, schon klar.
Warum geht es ja nicht? Was man braucht? Ach, bist ja ganz schön deutsch, Dennis.
Ihr seid mal ein bisschen amerikanischer, ein bisschen mehr Konsum.
Ja, Opportunities sehen, irgendwie. Das ist doch das Ding hier. Hier gibt es einfach Gelegenheiten. Also ich sehe schon, dass das Teil an sich super positioniert ist, um einfach so das universelle Medienkonsumgerät zu sein. Und so positionieren sie sich natürlich auch. Und wenn dann erstmal die Webseitenanbieter, die derzeit noch der Meinung sind, dass Flash irgendeine Zukunft hätte, das dann auch mal eingesehen haben und sich auf die Standards einschwenken, dann wird das auch relativ universell nutzbar sein im Web. Und ansonsten muss man sehen...
Das ist schon jetzt gut einsetzbar im Web.
Ja, kommt auch an welchem Web. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt auf Spiegel online gehst, dann gibt es halt blaue Lego-Käschen. Ist doch gut. Was ist gut?
Blaue Lego-Käschen.
Und dann?
Ok, die Videos kannst du nicht gucken.
Na ja, davon rede ich. Du kannst auch nicht die Bundesliga-Tabelle gucken.
Wir werden dir schon was empfeilen lassen. Aber ist doch gut, man braucht keinen click to flash auf dem iPad.
Das ist noch mal ein Feature. Ja, obwohl ich sagen muss, also in gewisser Hinsicht traue ich, ich hätte schon derzeit mit Flash hinterher, weil jetzt wo ich so die ersten Webseiten sehe, die mir den ganzen Video klimp im HTML5 vor die Nase hauen, kann ich diesen ganzen Content nicht mehr so leicht abschalten. Also mit click to flash sehe ich einfach sofort so wie so eine große Warnhinweise, hier Multimedia-Überforderung, irgendwie, du musst klicken. Und wenn die halt dann auf einmal wieder Standards benutzen, dann kommt diese ganze Multimedia-Überforderung einfach auf und zu.
Aber dann gibt's click to QT oder so. Oder to QuickTime, wat rumma. Also vielleicht gibt's ja dann...
Auf iPad würde das jetzt mal nicht gehen. Auf spiegel.de würde schon ein HTML5-Video auf dem iPad liefern? Das überrascht mich ja echt wirklich.
Jetzt können wir jetzt so einen kleinen...
Warum machen wir das dann nur auf dem iPad?
Ich hab eine Variante der Bild.de-Seite gesehen, die mit HTML5 läuft.
Ja, das wird sich jetzt in zwei, drei Monaten auch in Deutschland keiner mehr wirklich leisten können. Und ich glaube, dann beginnt eben auch ganz offensichtlich und für alle nackts sichtbar dieser Verfall von Flash. Also dann findet das einfach mal auch so in aller Öffentlichkeit statt.
CS5 Flash kann ja auch nach Canvas exportieren. Also nach HTML5. So ein bisschen.
Willst du jetzt schon ein komplett neues Thema aufmachen? CS5 wollten wir ja nachher irgendwie reden. Hat denn jemand das iPad mit deiner Tastatur verwendet? Eigentlich mit einer externen? Keine Gelegenheit, ne? Kein Proof, dass du das Tastatur zur Hand gehabt hast. So geht es mir auch. Also kurz gesagt, iPad sieht erstmal interessant aus. Ich werde mir wohl auch erstmal eins vorab shoppen. Jetzt, wo bekannt geworden ist, dass das Ding Ende Mai erst kommen soll, hier denke ich mal, werde ich besser nochmal... Ja, ich denke der Trend geht auch zum 2. Und man braucht halt so einen Teil für die Sofarit, so wisse. Dass man einfach im Sofa hat man irgendwie eins. Und wo ich mich natürlich total darauf freue, ist das iPad einfach als Spielzeug für Kids. Weil mit diesen ganzen Musik- und Mal-Spielen, die da jetzt so kommen, und wo du dann wirklich auch mit mehreren dran machen kannst, Brettspiele und so.
Brettspiele, wenn er nochmal so richtig reinschlagen. Das bin ich auch sehr gespannt drauf.
Das kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass er es greift. Das ist schon irgendwie ein guter, spottables Schachbrett. Das ist schon ein gutes, allgemeine, also alle diese ganzen Brettspiele, die man so spielen kann, lassen sich da vergleichsweise gut umsetzen. Und vor allem kannst du halt auch, was weiß ich, Senso, all diese Geräte.
Ein Freund von mir hat Pong 4 vorgeschrieben. Da kann man zu 4 Pong spielen, in allen 4 Ecken.
Ah, fürs iPad. Ah, ist das schon im Stor? Na siehst du mal, sowas. Und das ist natürlich, für Kids ist das natürlich sagenhaft. Weil das Teil halt einfach prima ist, das legst du dann irgendwie auf den Teppich. Und dann kann man da einfach...
Na lasst es da drüber und dann sind die 500 Euro weg.
Na ja gut, so ein kleiner Baby Fuß, der, glaube ich, hält das iPad schon noch aus.
Sagst du dann mal Scheid?
Na ja, deswegen sag ich ja, Trend geht zum 2. iPad. Das ist halt noch irgendwie so eine Notfallbox in Avantas, für das eine iPad schreut, dass du das gleich als Nächstes rausnehmen kannst. Ich finde, jetzt sollten sie iPads gleich so wie Klopapier, so an so einem Spender irgendwie verkaufen, so 5 Euro oder Stück.
Ja und auch so wie Bilderrahmen für Omi, dass man gleich so hinstellen kann.
Stimmt. Wobei ich ihnen ja das total übel nehme, dass sie dann noch Last Minute diesen 2. Dock-Connector weggehauen haben. Der ja nun, wenn man den Gerüchten glauben darf... Na, es ist wohl tatsächlich so gewesen, dass sie mit dem zweiten Dock-Connector an der Längsseite geliebäugelt haben. Ach so, okay. Also das war bis zuletzt noch vorgesehen oder zumindest eine Option. Keine Ahnung, wie da die Entscheidungsprozesse bei Apple laufen. Und das finde ich halt schon so ein bisschen schade, dass das nicht geht. Weil ich eben... Dass gerade, wenn man das Ding so als Photoframe-Anwendung benutzt, das natürlich auch geil wäre, wenn man es halt quer hat. Weil gerade, meistens fotografiert man halt im Landscape-Modus. Die meisten Fotos, die man macht, sind Landscape. Wenn das Ding immer im Porträt-Modus steht, heißt das, dass die Landscape-Bilder eben nie die maximale Größe erreichen.
Das heißt, wenn das Ding auch in diesem Tastatur-Sock steht, ist es auch immer im Porträt-Modus.
Oder es lädt nicht.
Da kannst du es ja auch nicht draufstellen.
Man muss halt auch erst mal wieder was bauen. Das finde ich auch so ein bisschen blöd.
Wir reden von einem Bilderrahmen.
Leute gehen in die Läden und kaufen sich für 200 Euro solche digitalen Bilderrahmen.
Die kosten keine 200 Euro.
Oder für 100 Euro.
Die kosten eher so 30 Euro. Ich weiß nicht vielleicht.
Die sind richtig schlecht. Da ist er ja am zocken während der Sendung.
Während ihr über Bilderrahmen redet, kann ich ja mal was ausprobieren.
Ein digitaler Bilderrahmen, du willst mir nicht erzählen, dass die 30 Euro kosten mit so einem Display.
Ich weiß nicht, was die können mit so einem Display vielleicht nicht.
Das sind aber relativ klein. Das Display flackert so komisch, weil es eine ganz geringe Wiederholrate ist. Das ist auch total billig.
Dann musst du da mit deinem USB-Stick ran.
Kannst du voll klicken. Voll der Schrott.
Hab ich meiner Oma geschenkt vor ein paar Jahren. Das iPad ist halt, wenn du es nicht benutzt, ist es halt irgendwie immer noch ein geiler Deluxe-Bilderrahmen. Und das mag für viele Leute.
Ist ja auch LED-beleuchtet von hinten, oder?
Ja, aber warum dann nicht quer? Cool wäre eigentlich so ein Ladedoc, so dann auch so direkt an die Wand. Quer halt.
Dann wäre nur quer die Konsequenz gewesen. Und dann noch den Button da hinsetzen.
Ich finde das nicht gut und ich prangere das an. Haben wir noch Hinweise zum Thema?
Wir haben jetzt auch alle keine so richtigen Aufreger-Themen gefunden, außer jetzt vielleicht quer liegende.
Wir haben ja auch alle noch keins. Wir reden ja wie Mutter ohne Kind irgendwie.
Na ja, wir haben uns jetzt aber alle mal mit rumgespielt und wir haben jetzt alle nicht so den richtigen Megafil. Also zum Beispiel Bildrahmenbreite, finde ich zum Beispiel.
Ich könnte jetzt mein Lieblingsthema wieder aufbringen und da so rumseiern und bejammern, dass es auch noch nicht gelöst ist.
Dass man mit dem Ding keine Podcasts machen kann?
Ne, das Syncing und Backup. Also ich hab die Podcast-Funktion nur so ansatzweise getestet. Podcast-Funktion? Na ja, das kann ja auch Podcasts abspielen.
Ach abspielen, achso.
Also nicht aufnehmen.
iTunes sah sehr geil aus auf dem Ding.
Fandest du, nur weil da jetzt wieder dieser graue Balken da oben ist?
Ne, ich fand den Album-View ganz cool. So dieses, dass du, also man sieht ein bisschen aus wie iTunes, dann hat man so ein Album-Ansicht, wo man so die ganzen Album-Cover sieht, und wenn man dann drauf tippt, dann flippt das so einmal kurz und man hat so ein kleines quadratisches Ding, wo man dann auswählen kann, welchen Song, und dann tippt man den an und flippt das wieder zu und das war's dann. Das finde ich sehr, sehr cool gelöst.
Kleines quadratisches Ding, du meinst diesen Overlay?
So ein Overlay, wo man dann auswählt, welchen Song man spielen will, fand ich sehr gut gemacht.
Genau, und dann gibt es nämlich auch noch so Related Tralala. Irgendwie in dieser Sache, irgendwie so ähnliche Musik oder so, wie das war. Ich glaube, das war in diesem iTunes oder war das im iTunes Store? Redest du jetzt vom Store oder redest du von einer Player?
Du meinst...
Du redest vom iPod oder von iTunes. Weil iTunes ist der Store und iPod ist der...
Von dem Ding, was hast du die iTunes auf dem Mac? Also wo man Musik mit abspielt.
Ja, iPod sieht aus wie iTunes auf dem Mac. Das ist alles total verwirrend.
Das ist etwas dusch tatsächlich.
Das heißt auch auf jedem Device anders.
Nee, wenn es jetzt konsequent... Vielleicht geht es ja darum, auf dem Mac, dass es einfach... Vielleicht ist das ja die Hoffnung, sie haben es überall getrennt, dass es auch da trennen. Dass dann eine neue Mac-Version rauskommt, wo du einen iPod-App hast und einen iTunes-App und...
Na, auf dem iPod Touch ist es ja auch so, dass es iPod heißt und dass auch die Video-Applikation nochmal getrennt ist.
Na, auf dem iPod Touch heißt es... Nee, da heißt es Musik einfach nur, glaube ich. Ich glaube, da gibt es keinen expliziten... Jaja, es hat auch ein anderes Eigen da, glaube ich.
Stimmt, auf dem iPhone heißt es iPod. Es ist alles auf jeden Fall total durcheinander, was da irgendwie iTunes ist und was nicht. Und ich finde halt dieses ganze Syncing-Thema, das hat sich halt irgendwie nicht nennenswert verbessert. Ich habe jetzt die Gelegenheit mit diesem Dokumentenaustausch mit Pages und dem Mac und so weiter und das Synken nicht ausprobiert. Ich habe nur die Berichte darüber gelesen, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. Das sind irgendwie so 7 Steps, die du da machen musst, um zwischen dem Mac und dem iPhone zuverlässig Dokumentversionen zu tauschen. Und das ist natürlich irgendwie alles ungeil.
Ja, ich will auch Wireless Syncing. Ich will mein Telefon nicht mal ranstecken, damit er da irgendwie... Ich will nach Hause kommen und meine Jacke mit dem Phon irgendwie an die Wand hängen und der soll synchronisieren automatisch. Nicht die dicken Movies oder so, aber zum Beispiel SMS und irgendwelche Kontaktdaten, die sich geändert haben.
Na ja, wenn schon alles.
Alles. Ja, Kontakte kriegt man ja hin.
Ja, es gibt halt für jeden einzelnen Teil gibt es halt irgendwie irgendwas so. Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass es da wirklich die Lösung dafür gibt. Lass das alles durch. So, haben wir's mit dem iPhone?
Ja, aber das werden sie machen. Also ich finde es für den ersten Wurf auf den allerersten Blick sehr gut gelungen.
Ich habe noch eine Theorie, eine kleine. Ich weiß, warum das iBooks ein extra Programm ist. Darauf ich zu wissen zumindest. Und zwar, weil die erste iPhone-Generation wird ja von... Die kriegt ja kein Update mehr. Also das OS 4.0 gibt es ja nicht für das erste iPhone. Sie wollen aber natürlich auch dort Bücher verkaufen können. Weil Verkaufen von Zeug hat ja immer Priorität. Und deswegen ist es ein extra App, damit nämlich auch die das noch für das erste iPhone rausbringen können, damit alle runterladen können.
Wie für das erste iPhone?
Das erste iPhone. Das kriegt kein OS 4.0-Update mehr. Das heißt, wenn das iBooks Teil vom OS 4.0 wäre, dann würde es ja nicht aufs erste iPhone kommen.
Also da finde ich aber Tims Theorie, dass das einfach das iBook-Apps je nach Markt mit ausrollen. Wesentlich plausibler.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Haben sie denn gesagt, dass das iBooks auf dem ersten iPhone auch rauskommt? Nein, noch nicht. Nein, das kommt nicht, weil das ist ein Feature von iPhone OS 4.
Das wurde zumindest damit angekündigt.
Und damit ist es definitiv nicht auf dem ersten iPhone. Womit wir bei dem...
Das ist ein Feature von iPhone 3.2, weil dort sind die ganzen neuen Wording- und Textfeatures und so. iPad hat ja 3.2.
Leute, ich muss hier zuverlässige Kapitelmarken machen. Also müssen wir auch zuverlässig unsere Kapitel ankündigen.
Ich muss superlässig die Klappe halten.
Nein, ich versuche schon die ganze Zeit einen eleganten Schwang zu machen, der irgendwie von der iPad-Thematik auf die iPhone-Thematik...
Das hat man jetzt gerade gekriegt.
Ja, ich muss aber mal so einen Ton einspielen, damit das mal alle merken.
Bing ist schon belegt.
Womit denn?
Neue Mail.
Das ist super gemacht, einfach mal den neuen Mail zu halten, dass die Leute, die uns auf den iPhone hören, immer so...
Das könnte auf jeden Fall verwirrend sein, das stimmt, ne? iPhone OS 4.0 wurde dann relativ schnell nach dem iPad angekündigt und naja, auch wenn da nicht alles drin ist, was ich da ganz gerne gesehen hätte, sind auf jeden Fall ein paar interessante Sachen drin. Also iPad ist mit Version 3.2, die im Wesentlichen so eine Interims-Version ist. So würde ich das mal nennen. Da haben sie schon mal alles eingebaut, was sie jetzt unbedingt schon umsetzen wollten oder was noch fertig war.
Die 3.2 kommt aber noch für alle iPhones noch mal vor.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Fürs erste schon.
Fürs erste machen die nichts mehr. Die machen nichts mehr fürs erste.
Das sind Updaten. Die kriegen Buch-Fish auch.
Achso, du meinst, dass es eine 3.2-Version gibt noch für das erste iPhone?
Und vielleicht für die anderen auch noch. Ich weiß ja nicht, wann es 4.0 kommen wird, wenn es im Juli ist. Naja, im Juli. Bis dahin ist es ja echt noch ein bisschen. Obwohl, jetzt ist auch schon Mittapri. Also in dem iPhone OS 3.2 sind die ganzen Features drin, die man braucht, um die ganzen Bücher ordentlich anzeigen zu können.
Ja, das ist, also ich glaube...
Das sind die ganzen Text-Features und sie haben da richtig viel mit Paragrafen und Zeug und Links, also so richtig viele Features für Textanzeigen.
Ich glaube, für das alte iPhone, für das erste iPhone ist der Zug einfach abgefahren.
Ist das genauso schnell wie das 3G?
Ja, es gibt keine technischen Gründe dafür, sondern einfach das Marketing-Gründen.
Die wollen Bücher verkaufen.
Das Ding ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr im Handel. Mit anderen Worten, die Verträge laufen jetzt langsam aus, die Provider-Verträge und Apple wird sagen, wenn du neue Features haben willst, kauf dir ein neues iPhone.
Der Kunde sagt, wenn ich Bücher kaufen soll, gib mir diese Applikationen.
Also ich würde sagen, 50-50 kann sein, kann nicht sein. Tatsache ist, iPhone OS 4.0 ist das erste iPhone OS, das den alten Scheiß ein bisschen abschüttet und dann eben nur noch ab dem 3G verfügbar ist und auch bestimmte Features nur für die derzeit aktuelle Version macht.
Da kommen wir ja einsteigen. Und zwar hat das iPhone OS 4.0 ja Multitasking. Und das gibt es dann auf dem iPhone 3G nicht, weil es nämlich zu wenig Speicher hat wahrscheinlich. Das ist so die Theorie und das macht auch total Sinn. Was natürlich am Ende die Entscheidung bei Apple ist, wenn die da am Tisch setzen, weiß man nicht. Aber das 3G hat nur 128 MB. Die Programme müssen ja im Speicher gehalten werden. Und deswegen gibt es Multitasking nur ab dem 3GS, weil die halt 256 MB Speicher haben.
Ich habe mir also, ich habe dir schon eine klare Vorstellung davon, wie dieses Multitasking funktioniert. Also was tatsächlich jetzt die neuen Funktionalitäten sind.
Also ich glaube, das wichtigste Feature, also die haben ja kein echtes Multitasking.
Ich habe eine Frage gefragt. Habt ihr eine Vorstellung davon?
Wir haben die gleiche Keynote gesehen wie du auch wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die Keynote fand ich war da jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig. Es gab halt so die eine oder andere Information drumherum, die hoch kam.
Kein Multitasking, so wie es halt vom Desktop-Rechner kennen, dass das Programm parallel weiterläuft. Also, dass sie Multitasking sind, sondern es ist nur...
Doch, klar, laufen die Programme parallel weiter. Selbstverständlich. Wie sollen sie sonst Musik im Hintergrund abspielen?
Das kann man auch so lösen, dass es nicht das Programm ist. Also, dass es ein Programm, die Musikdaten an das OS gibt und sagt, hier, spiel mal. Wenn du es irgendwie fertig hast, dann melde ich zu mir zurück. Also, die laufen wirklich nicht gleichzeitig. Die schalten immer aus. Also, wenn du die auch stoppst, die gehen nur in den Hintergrund und parken dann solange. Oder solange zum Beispiel bei Voice over IP, wenn da kein Call reinkommt, dann läuft das Programm nicht, sondern das wartet, bis es geweckt wird. Deswegen machen die ja diesen Aufwand. Die wollen halt nicht, dass irgendwas gleichzeitig läuft. Die wollen die immer möglichst aushaben und haben sie alle möglichen Tricks einfallen lassen, damit die trotzdem dann geweckt werden, wenn sie gebraucht werden. Das ist doch das, was sie meinen, dass sie geguckt haben, was Programme eigentlich machen wollen im Hintergrund. Eigentlich wollen die ja nicht so viel machen.
Ja gut, aber auch bei Background Audio, das heißt ja nur, das Programm sorgt im Hintergrund dafür, dass Musik kommt. Also muss es ja auch diese Musik irgendwo herholen. Und wenn du so eine Streaming-Applikation hast, dann muss ja auch diese Daten von irgendwo empfangen werden. Und das OS kann ja nicht vorher determinieren, wann diese Daten überhaupt kommen. Wenn da irgendwie ein wackeliger Stream ist, oder ein komplexes Protokoll ist, oder was auch immer. Das ist schon so, dass die Programme dann laufen. Weil sie müssen ja eigenständig irgendwelche Dinge tun.
Da wäre ich mir noch gar nicht so sicher.
Was ist, wenn das Programm diese Musik nur generiert?
Dann geht es vielleicht nicht. Weiß ich nicht. So genau hat das nicht gesagt. Du hast so ein Musikabspielprogramm, das irgendwie das MP3 ans OS geben und dann sagen, wenn du die 5 Minuten abgespielt hast, dann komm zu mir zurück, ich gebe dir den nächsten Song.
Ich sage nicht, dass es da nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, dafür das Programm einfach die CPU wieder abzugeben. Aber es ist halt schon so, dass das Programm als solches läuft. Und auch bei Task Completion, ich meine, das Ding macht ein, das Beispiel war im Hintergrund ein Upload, dazu muss es halt, naja gut, aber es muss ja dafür laufen, sonst kann es ja nichts tun. Es ist halt im Speicher, es ist aktiv, es ist nicht komplett ausgeschaltet. Und auch bei diesem VoIP, da habe ich echt gerätselt, als ich zuerst davon gehört habe, so die ersten Berichte, als ich die Kino noch nicht gesehen habe, so naja, und jetzt auch VoIP und Skype könnte dann halt auch laufen, da habe ich mich echt gefragt, haben sie explizit eigentlich Skype genannt oder reden sie von VoIP?
Skype haben sie ja vorgeführt.
Genau, das habe ich danach halt auch festgestellt. Und das spricht meiner Meinung nach auch sehr viel mehr dafür, dass es halt so richtig läuft, weil es sich nicht um einen VoIP-Dienst des Betriebssystems handelt, sondern es handelt sich nur um, wenn du sagst, ich bin VoIP, dann darfst du.
Also spätestens bei Turn-by-Turn-Navigation muss das Programm ja laufen, um dir sagen zu können, wo du abbiegen musst. Das reicht ja nicht, wenn im Hintergrund irgendeine API läuft, die die Location regelmäßig einsammelt, sondern man muss ja irgendwas mit anstellen. Also und auch bei dem Beispiel, das wir in der Keynote hatten, nämlich dass sie da nicht einfach nur Musik aus dem Flash-Speicher spielen, sondern offensichtlich mit diesem Pandora-Zeug da, das irgendwie gestreamt wird, muss da im Hintergrund ein Client laufen, der das Ganze aus dem Netz holt. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass das weniger, also es wird bestimmt auch eine API existieren, eine wirklich vernünftige, aber das ist im Ersten Linie sozusagen, was die machen dürfen und was nicht diese App-Store-Bestimmungen sind.
Denke ich auch.
Das ist mein Gefühl.
Ich bin ein hm hm hm und falle in die Kategorie lalala und ich möchte das jetzt tun und wenn dann halt dieses Programm submitted wird, dann gucken die da drauf und sagen ok, alles klar, was du da tust, ist Background-Audio, das darfst du und du musst es über die und die API realisieren und so wie du es gemacht hast, ist ok, jetzt nehmen wir dich an.
Also ich hab es so verstanden, dass die sieben Services, die sie da bieten, dass die halt genau dafür da sind, dass das Programm sich mehr oder weniger abschaltet und den Background-Dienst, den es machen will, ans OS abgibt. Und das wäre auch mehr oder weniger bei allen gegangen, bei Background-Audio weiß ich es nicht ganz genau, aber da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es klappt, indem das Programm halt die Musik ans OS abgibt und sich so lange wieder wirklich mehr oder weniger dann nicht ausschaltet, weil es läuft noch, aber dass es auf totaler Pause ist.
Es kann ja jederzeit die CPU komplett abgeben. Es gibt ja genug Bedingungen, unter denen ein Programm nicht laufen muss und so ist das ja in der Regel auch. Aber es muss halt selber auf Sockets lauern und wenn da Daten kommen, wird es halt automatisch aufgeweckt vom OS, wie das sonst eben auch ist.
Sonst würdest du ja auch mit den 7 Services keinen Grund machen, wenn du noch alles Mögliche da im Laufen haben könntest. Ich meine, das ist das... Ich meine, ob dein Programm gerade viel verbraucht oder nicht?
Nene, ich meine, diese Services definieren sozusagen nur den Grund, warum du laufen darfst. Also lass es mich mal anders aufziehen. Das letzte, also diese... Okay, also unter Multitasking gibt es diese 7 Sachen. Background Audio, Voice-over IP, Task Completion, Background Location, Push Notification in irgendeiner neuen Variante, Local Notification und dann das letzte, was er genannt hat, war Fast Up-Switching. Und da steckt es nämlich eigentlich auch drin. Wenn du die Kino nochmal genau anschaut, ist ja sehr interessant, er spielt ja dieses Spiel, was war das, Tab Tab Revenge oder so was Ähnliches. So, und dann sagt er irgendwie Homebutton, Doppelklick und kommt ja in diesen Task Manager, den sie nicht so nennen wollen, also in diese, eigentlich in dieses Dog, was dann halt laufende Programme anzeigt, die aber ja eigentlich nicht laufen. Eigentlich ist es ja mehr so ein Recent Items, es ist irgendwie Recent Applications. Weil, wenn ein Programm verlassen wird, wird es ja auch gestoppt. Dann wählst du was anderes. Das läuft dann halt. Es ist nur so, dass die Programme halt nicht aus dem RAM komplett, also der Prozess wird nicht komplett weggeworfen, wie das derzeit ist, sondern er wird halt nur in so einen Suspend-Modus. Also der Name ist jetzt von mir. Also Hibernate oder was auch immer. Also er wird halt irgendwie schlafen gelegt und weiß auch, dass er schlafen gelegt wurde. Und das merkt man in dieser Demo da dran, dass wenn er wieder in das Programm reingeht, dass das Programm ja erstmal selber so einen Pause-Modus auch anzeigt und eben diese Wiederaufnahme dann mit so einem Countdown begleitet. Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, funktioniert das im Kern so. Du sagst, ich verlasse dich, wie bisher auch wird das Programm aufgefordert, sich zu beenden, seine Daten zu sichern bzw. unter iPhone OS 4.0 kannst du halt auch sagen, ich will mich gar nicht beenden, sondern ich will weiterlaufen und ich benutze hier ein definiertes Event.
Du kriegst so ein Call, das gedrückt wurde, so wie früher auch, also wenn du das Programm ausmachst. Und da kannst du dann halt noch deine Sachen speichern, irgendwas beenden oder was auch immer.
Genau, du musst halt so ein State sichern.
Du wirst nicht terminiert, sondern du kannst halt wieder geweckt werden, im Gegensatz zu früher. Du musst dafür aber eine weitere Methode in deinem Programm anbieten, für 4.0, dass du es halt kannst.
Genau, da frage ich mich aber jetzt, was eben passiert, wenn tatsächlich ich das Programm beende und es eigentlich so in einem Ich-will-weiterlaufen-Modus ist, so wie mitten im Spiel, und ich dann aber 30.000 andere Applikationen speicher starte, sodass definitiv der Speicher für mich nicht da ist. Dann müsste das Programm irgendwann auch wirklich aus dem RAM rausgenommen werden. Wenn ich da wieder reingehe...
Wenn du einen Anruf reinkriegst, musst du ja auch dafür sorgen, dass du dann...
Ja klar, aber das gelingt ja nicht allen Programmen, da wieder weiter zu machen, wo sie aufhören.
Die haben Pech gehabt, die müssen ja mal langsam ein bisschen mehr koden.
Ja, aber es gab... Ich hab aber jetzt das in der Beschreibung der Keynote so verstanden, dass das OS es einem einfach sehr viel leichter macht, diesen State auch als solchen zu sichern.
Ich nehme an, dass die das irgendwie, wenn du eine Serialisierungs-API anbieten, mit der du automatisch sagen kannst, das möchte ich gerne beim nächsten Start so wieder haben, wie es jetzt gerade ist, und dann wird es irgendwie wegschoben.
Ja, es kann aber natürlich auch sehr viel...
Serialisieren, das gab es alles irgendwie schon immer.
Ja gut, aber das kann halt sehr viel Speicher sein, was sich in der kurzen Zeit gar nicht wegschreiben lässt.
In 5 Minuten?
Ich glaube, es ist weniger so ein Serialisieren als vielmehr so ein... Dass du deinen Data-Bereich, also dass der variable Datenbereich deines Programms, dass sich der erhalten lässt, während aber so der Platz für den Code usw. weggeworfen wird. So was könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Na das wird bestimmt passieren, was wahrscheinlich auch passieren wird, dass es so das ganze User-Interface, dass dir das eine gewisse Unterstützung liefern wird, also dass der View, der geladen wird, automatisch der Richtige ist in irgendeiner Form, also dass er so einen Breadcrumb oder sowas anbietet und das für dich wieder herstellt.
Ich bin gespannt. Und tatsächlich ist das das, was mir eigentlich am meisten fehlt. Wenn ich zum Beispiel, was weiß ich hier, Tweety 2, was ich benutze, vor allem zum Twittern, das ist ja schon in der Version, da war ja schon eins der Hauptfeatures, dass das Ding weitgehend immer wieder dort aufsetzt, wo man es verlassen hat.
Aber nicht hundertprozentig.
Genau, weil wenn ich zum Beispiel in einem Webview bin, also mir gerade eine Webseite anschaue und ich rausgehe, wieder reingehe, dann lande ich halt in dem Tweety-Panel davor, aber eben nicht in diesem Webview, wo ich war. Und nicht gerade an der Stelle, wo ich mir diese Webseite durchgelesen habe. Das heißt, wenn ich so einen Tweet, einen Link verfolge, dann mir die Webseite dazu durchlese, die halb durch bin. Und dann werde ich unterbrochen und dann gehe ich da wieder rein. Dann kann ich halt wieder anfangen, muss die Seite komplett laden und mir auch noch raussuchen, wo ich jetzt gerade war.
Mit Multitasking würdest du jetzt wieder genau dahin kommen, wo du warst. Und wenn der Speicher gereicht hat, wenn der aber nicht reicht, dann würde das Programm beendet werden für dich, ohne dass du es mitkriegst. Und wenn du es dann neu startest, dann wärst du wieder das Fenster davor, weil Tweet, die sich halt selber darum kümmern muss, wo du gewesen bist.
Da bin ich wirklich gespannt, wie da die User Experience sein wird. Ob man eigentlich wirklich davon ausgehen kann, dass man immer wieder da landet, wo man war, oder ob das dann auch wieder von der Qualität der Programme abhängt.
Das Multitasking wird jetzt dafür sorgen, dass sich auch rumsprechen wird, welche Programme zu viel Speicher verhauen, dass alle anderen Programme deswegen rausgeschmissen werden. Das heißt, die Leute werden sich jetzt, oder die Programmierer haben jetzt viel mehr Grund, auch ein bisschen speichersparsamer zu programmieren. Und weil es halt klar ist, dass wenn du draufdrückst, du den letzten Stand nochmal kriegst, werden sie auch mehr dafür sorgen, dass es halt dementsprechend programmiert ist. Dass wenn es halt doch mal beendet wird, dass da ein paar Sachen gespeichert werden und so weiter und so fort. Also ich denke auf jeden Fall, dass es eine gute Sache ist.
Diese Nuke-Notification, die sie vorgestellt haben?
Ja, kann ich kurz erklären. Und zwar ist es ja so, hat er aber eigentlich auch gut erklärt, dass wenn du hier so ein TV-Programm hast, ich nehme einfach mal das Beispiel, was die in der Kino auch schon hatten, und da war es so, dass du hast eine Sendung, die ist morgen um 19 Uhr und du willst sie gerne gucken und du willst, dass die TV-Applikation dich daran erinnert. Das ging bisher halt nur, indem die TV-Applikation einen eigenen Server, die mit dem Apple-Notification-Server spricht, der dir dann von außen wieder eine Notification reinschickt. Obwohl eigentlich das eine fest definierte Zeit ist, die gar keinen externen Service irgendwie braucht. Deswegen gibt es jetzt Local-Notification, du kannst einfach lokal sagen, weg mich morgen um 19 Uhr, ohne dass es das übers Netz geht.
Das heißt jetzt kann auch jeder seine eigene Wecker abmachen.
Ich weiß ein Programm, was das wirklich gebrauchen kann, und zwar hier dieses Fahrinfo. Nutzt ihr vielleicht, ab wo ihr fahrt, nie mit der Bahn?
Ich fahre nie mit der Bahn.
Achso, stimmt, du fährst ja nie mit der Bahn. Ne, dieses Fahrinfo Berlin.
Ich weiß, wovon du redest.
Und der hat ja so einen kleinen Wecker-Button, wo man sich dran erinnern lassen kann, weil man aussteigen muss. Und der funktioniert überhaupt nie, weil der sich, glaube ich, mit Notifications arbeitet.
Der kann jetzt mit Local-Notifications arbeiten, wenn er über die Uhrzeit läuft, kann er das halt prima machen.
Ich glaube, der läuft über die Uhrzeit.
Genau das gleiche bei eBay, wenn die Auktion zu Ende ist, das ist ein fest definierter Zeitpunkt, da können die auch jetzt Local-Notifications benutzen. Das ist zwar egal, weil eBay-Programm muss natürlich trotzdem externe Notifications machen, wegen Überbieten und so, aber der Effekt ist auch, dass die Apple-Server durch diesen ganzen Scheiß irgendwie total entlastet werden, weil die ganzen lokalen Sachen müssen jetzt nicht mehr über den Apple-Server drüber. Hätten sie mal ein bisschen früher darüber nachdenken, sonst hätten sie nicht so einen Aufwand da.
Und wenn du ein eigenes, ein kleines Programm, was damit total auskommt, dann brauchst du keine eigene Infrastruktur für irgendwelche Push-Notifications auf die Beine zu stellen, was ja auch eine Menge wert ist.
Also die ganzen TV-Jungs, die wirklich nur auf die Uhrzeit ankommt, die können jetzt da viel entspannter arbeiten.
Also es macht so den Eindruck, was haben wir noch nicht besprochen, also Task Completion ist, dass ein Programm sagen kann, ja ich beende mich, aber ich muss hier noch was zu Ende machen.
Das heißt, man kann es beenden, weil ein Call reinkommt, aber das Programm, wenn es länger braucht, kann es im Hintergrund beenden, du kannst schneller woanders hin switchen.
Genau, Beispiel war so Flickr-Upload, und dann was weiß ich, glaube bei 300 Sekunden ist Schluss oder so, es gibt so einen harten Timeout. Und Background Location funktioniert halt in zweierlei Feinheiten, wie du schon gesagt hast, Max. Das heißt, entweder wirklich genau GPS, wobei mich so ein bisschen wundert, dass Sie da nur von Navigationssoftware geredet haben, was ja einer der großen Fails ist, eigentlich derzeit auf dem iPhone, ist die Unmöglichkeit, einen GPS-Logger zu implementieren. Und das müsste ja dann damit eigentlich gehen.
Kann ich endlich Motorrad fahren? Lass das Telefon meiner Jacke, es ist auch ausgeschaltet. Also der Bildschirm ist dunkel, weil bei den Trekking-Dinger muss man die auch immer anlassen, sonst schaltet sich sie ab. Die waren dann glaube ich nach 5 Stunden leer, oder so diese Trekking-Teile wegen Bildschirm noch an. Und jetzt ist es halt der Bildschirm aus.
Das ist natürlich super, das heißt, dann kann man mit dem iPhone auch mal ordentlich Open-Street-Map-Kram machen und so weiter.
Das ist übrigens auch meine Theorie, dass das Programm eigentlich komplett aus ist, aber dem OS-Pros sagt, du, ich will hier tracken, du trackst jetzt für mich weiter, ich mach mich aus. Und wenn es dann wieder gestartet wird, kriegt es vom OS die komplette Liste mit allen Tracking-Punkten und dem passenden Timestamp dazu, dass es das dann danach auslöst.
Das ist definitiv nicht der Fall, weil sie ja Tracking nicht mal erwähnt haben, sondern nur Navigation.
Und das ist schon Realtime.
Und Navigation kann ja nicht sagen, bei nächsten Start ist alles komplett falsch.
Wir reden jetzt wirklich von laufendem Programm. Das ist so. Und es gibt, es ist halt nur so, wenn ein Programm, also die wesentliche Änderung kurz zusammengefasst ist eigentlich, die, wenn gesagt wird, ein Programm wird beendet, wird es gar nicht mehr beendet. Sondern die Programme werden nur offiziell schlafen gelegt, bleiben im Rahmen. Manche dürfen unter bestimmten Bedingungen noch bestimmte Dinge tun.
Über diese sieben Services.
Über diese sieben Services, aber eben darüber hinaus erstmal so nichts, wobei das sicherlich schon eine ganze Menge abdeckt. Und wenn sie dann, und sie können eben auf bestimmte Events reagieren. Bei dem Background Location kann das permanent sein. Das heißt, da wird das Programm eben auch häufig aktiviert werden, aber es muss ja auch nicht sehr viel tun. Sondern so ein GPS-Logger, der nimmt halt diesen Event irgendwie, hier, neue Messungen, tralla, wir sind jetzt da, Uhrzeit, da schreibt er sich in seinen RAM, und dann ist er auch schon wieder beim OS.
Ja, aber eigentlich, wenn er sie sich immer merken soll, dann kann er sie auch gar nicht kriegen, und kriegt sie dann, wenn das Programm wieder gestartet ist, die Locations der letzten zwei Stunden.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass dein Location-Tracker das halt übers Internet rausschickt.
Und es geht auch nicht um Location-Tracker. Das war das Beispiel, was sie überhaupt nicht erwähnt haben.
Nein, Apple hat es nicht erwähnt, aber ich hab's erwähnt. Ich find's wichtig. Guck mal, ich hab zum Beispiel vor 5 Jahren...
Die haben Navigation, dafür muss das Programm einfach laufen. Es führt keinen Weg dran vorbei. Das App muss laufen, ansonsten geht's nicht. Ansonsten geht Navigation nicht. Das ist ein... Was ich mir noch vorstellen könnte, ist, dass einzelne Threads von Programmen weiterlaufen dürfen oder ähnliches. Also, dass das User-Interface geblockt wird, um nicht mehr so viel Rechenzeit zu brauchen, weil das braucht ja auch mal das Hintergrund theoretisch noch auf Events wartet und Bildschirmausgaben sind verboten und so was. Und dann darf man halt nur noch irgendwie ein Thread oder startet einen separaten Prozess, der sich um sowas kümmert und der darf dann weiterlaufen.
Hier, September 2003. Da, wie lange ist das jetzt her? Sieben, sechseinhalb Jahre. Da bin ich mal auf Inlineskates hier beim Berlin-Marathon mitgelaufen und da wollte ich das erste Mal dieses Live-Tracking machen. Und da war ich noch irgendwie mit so einem Ben-Phone irgendwie Teil unterwegs. Das ist so ein Spezial-GSM-Telefon, was halt GPS hat. Und das schickt halt per SMS immer die Position raus. Das heißt, ich bin diesen Marathon gelaufen, hatte halt dieses Teil in der Tasche und das hat die ganze Zeit irgendwie alle, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, paar Sekunden eine SMS rausgeschickt und dann hatten wir halt irgendwie einen Server, der die SMS, der mit dem Telefon angeschlossen war, der die SMS wieder eingelesen hat und der das dann halt irgendwie auf einer Karte angezeigt hat. Damals noch mit ohne Google Maps, sondern mit so einem lokalen Berliner Karten-Provider, hab vergessen, wie die hießen.
Und das kriegt dann demnächst jeder für seine Westentasche.
Genau, und das, was ich damals gemacht hab, ging halt sozusagen, geht bis heute nicht mit dem iPhone. Das ist das, worauf ich jetzt hinaus will. Und jetzt mit iPhone OS 4.0 kann man das dann endlich auch mal tun. Und dann eben auch nicht über SMS, sondern eben mit so einer kleinen Applikation, die im Hintergrund einfach nur aus so einem GPS-Event ein UDP-Paket macht und das irgendwo hinschickt und dann kannst du halt deine Karte aktualisieren. Das finde ich eigentlich mal relativ geil, weil stell mal vor, du bist jetzt mit einer größeren Gruppe irgendwo in einer anderen Stadt. Demo oder so. Und alle sind irgendwie irgendwo. Dann könntest du quasi so eine einfache private Anwendung machen, so eine geschützte Webseite, wo einfach nur eine Google-Map drauf ist, wo alle anderen sind. Und du hast aber auch wirklich live das Tracking und kannst dann halt sofort alle anderen auch finden.
Naja, also ich meine, da brauchen wir das Location jetzt mal langsam eine richtig, richtig schön wichtige Sache wird. Da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle einig. Also schon allein so für die bestehenden Dienste wie Govala, Google Attitude, Forcequare und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Dafür ist das sicherlich extrem interessant. da wird noch eine Menge dazu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist noch gar nicht absehbar für uns, was da jetzt noch alles gehen wird demnächst.
Gut, dann können wir jetzt glaube ich diesen Multitasking-Teil mal abschließen. Und dann gibt es ja noch ein paar andere Sachen, die auch gar nicht jetzt so der Rede wert sind, muss ich sagen, bei iPhone OS 4.0. Das mit diesen Folders, also die Möglichkeit, den Homescreen so zu organisieren, dass man jetzt quasi da, wo normalerweise nur eine Applikation oder eine Website Platz hatte, einen Icon, dass man dann bis zu 16 in so einem Teil Ich dachte 12, aber egal. 12, ja genau. 12, dreimal 4. Bis zu 12 Icons quasi in einem gruppieren kann.
Finde ich eine hübsche Sache.
Ja, könnte ich mir auch ganz brauchbar vorstellen.
Ich fand allerdings, ich fand bei sowohl bei diesem Fast-Up-Switching, als auch bei diesem Fold, dass das irgendwie nimmt die Einfachheit aus dem iPhone raus.
Wird sich zeigen.
Also rein vom Gefühl her war das bisher nämlich immer so, dass eigentlich alles immer im Fullscreen-Modus und du hast keine Fenster gehabt. Und plötzlich hast du da dieses Up-Switching-Fenster, was unten reinfährt und du hast halt dieses Folder, das aufgeht.
Ich meine, mit diesen Seiten seine Applikationen ordentlich zu administrieren, das geht ja auch gar nicht.
Es ist eine gute Sache, ohne Frage. Also ich möchte es haben, das ist toll und so weiter und so fort. Es ist aber, es war nicht mehr so dieses, ich hab das Video gesehen, hab gedacht, bisher sah das immer einfacher aus. Bisher sah es einfacher zu benutzen aus. Jetzt fängt es an, erklärungsbedürftig zu werden.
Der Nachteil ist natürlich, das bedeutet, dass sie irgendwie auch immer noch kein Konzept für ein Dashboard haben oder Lockscreen. Es gibt immer noch nicht die Möglichkeit, dass Programme zu so einem Dashboard irgendwas beitragen könnten. Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen bekloppt. Also ich hätte mir schon gewünscht, dass das jetzt mal kommt. Ich meine, Programme haben halt so diese Zahl und so weiter, aber sehr viel hübscher wär es eigentlich, wenn man so ein Widget für so ein Dashboard bauen könnte, was quasi auch noch mal so ein kleiner...
Fürs Log-Screen oder für...
Für den Log-Screen zum Beispiel. Also Klassiker ist ja sowas wie deine To-Do's, deine Termine heute. Also das ist das einzige Feature, was ich von meinem Nokia vermisse, was ich damals hatte. Ich meine, ein scheiß Telefon, aber zumindest konnte ich das Teil irgendwie eine Taste drücken und ich sah sofort meine nächsten Termine heute. Und das war einfach echt eine Menge wert. Und das geht einfach nicht mit dem iPhone, sondern muss ich draufdrücken, unlocken, auf Seite 5 scrollen, da irgendwie meinen Kalender anklicken, warten, in den richtigen View gehen, rumscrollen und dann weiß ich, ah, um 15 Uhr in 2 Stunden habe ich einen Termin. Anstatt dass das scheiß Teil einfach mal...
Also das zum richtigen View gehen und warten ist ja alles weggefallen mit dem Multitasking.
Wieso?
Na, weil es zum Multitasking kommt sofort nach vorne mit dem View, wenn du den noch hast.
Ja gut, ich warte vielleicht etwas weniger, aber ich verbringe immer noch Tage damit. Ich meine, im Effekt macht man es dann halt gar nicht erst. Sondern man verpasst den Termin einfach. Und das ist...
Aber dafür gibt es auch Local Notifications.
Ja, aber so eine Local Notification sagt gar nichts aus. Also diese 15 Minuten vorher, wenn er mir sagt, 15 Minuten vorher, dass ich irgendwie vor einer halben Stunde hätte losgehen müssen, das bringt mir irgendwie wenigstens.
Also diese ganzen Notifications, das ist noch nicht der Weisheit, das stimm ich dir absolut zu.
Also ich finde die Notifications als solche sind völlig in Ordnung und das gehört da auch rein und das braucht man auch. Das ist bloß nicht das, wovon ich rede. Ich rede davon, dass das Ding eine Art Dashboard braucht. Dass man einfach die Möglichkeit hat, so wie ich auf diesen Searchscreen gehen kann... Also ich hätte gerne unter diesem Searchscreen. Also wenn ich auf diesen Home-Tasse und dann irgendwie einen nach links...
Aber dafür wäre das wirklich das Log-Screen gut geeignet.
Oder auch der Log-Screen. Beides meinetwegen, dass da halt einfach die Möglichkeit besteht, dass Programme sich da einklingen und dass ich konfigurieren kann, was bestimmte Programme da machen. Jetzt ist ja mit diesem Multitasking im Prinzip die Basis dafür gelegt, dass sie das halt auch live aktualisieren. Wir werden sehen. Vielleicht ist das ja auch das, was sie erstmal abwarten und sie denken danach nach.
Davon gehe ich auch mal aus.
Mail, da müssen wir viel darüber reden. Mail wird jetzt irgendwie eine Unified Inbox haben.
Ist für viele Leute bestimmt ganz cool.
Was ich ganz gut fand in Mail, was du hier woanders eingebaut hast, und da Enterprise Features, Multiple Exchange Accounts. Ja, also dass man mehr als einen Exchange Account haben kann, macht einen anderen Zustand etwas erträglicher, nämlich dass sie nach wie vor keine Google-Synchronisierung mit drin haben, was ich echt mal schade finde.
Aber Google kann man überall als Exchange Account konfigurieren.
Google kann man als Exchange-Verkauf-Account konfigurieren, mit anderen Worten, ich kann jetzt im Büro den Exchange-Account dann in Zukunft noch irgendwann mal mit dazu packen, wenn ich will. Weil da haben wir Exchange, und ich hab schon meinen Google-Exchange-Account, der mir natürlich wesentlich wichtiger ist als irgendwelche Arbeitsmails. Find ich ganz schön, dass das geht.
Also du hast einfach den Bedarf für mehr als ein?
Da hab ich, genau.
Okay, das ist ja auch verständlich. Ja, was ich sehr viel interessanter finde, also ich meine, für große Firmen haben sie wieder hier so, was weiß ich, Applikationen, Wireless, Distribution und bessere Tools, um einfach deine ganze iPhone-Flotte zu managen. Das haben sie halt irgendwie gemacht, keine Ahnung, wie gut oder schlecht das bisher war. Aber das wollen sie wohl verbessern. Aber was ich viel interessanter finde, ist, dass sie diese Möglichkeit bieten, dass Programme jetzt auch die Verschlüsselung benutzen. Auf dem Telefon. Also ihre Daten verschlüsseln. Habt ihr verstanden, wie das laufen soll genau? Also mein Verständnis ist ja das, dass...
Weil der Keychain gibt es ja schon.
Ja, aber es geht sozusagen um die Daten des Programms selbst. Und also das, wo das Programm, was ist halt lokal in seinem eigenen Store, seinem eigenen Fallstore und vielleicht auch in RAM gespeichert.
Also dass man nicht den Flash rausnehmen kann und irgendwo anders einbauen und die Daten auslesen.
Genau, also wenn so ein Telefon klaust und der Typ ist irgendwie klug genug, da zu verhindern, dass das Ding von außen gelöscht wird, dann hat er ja potentiell Daten. Und im Enterprise-Bereich heißt das, du hast da irgendwie so eine Customized-Kunden-Lagerbestands-Faktura-Anwendung, die halt lokal irgendwelche, was weiß ich, Daten vorhält, damit du eben als mobiler Verkäufer die immer zur Hand hast. Und das können ja auch schützenswerte Zahlen sein. Verkaufspreise, Margen, you name it.
Was hat Firmen für Geheimheiten?
Was Firmen halt auch immer so für Geheimheiten. Und das 3GS ist ja das erste iPhone, was quasi Krypto schon im Telefon hat.
Das hat da so ein Chipment drin dafür.
Genau, deswegen können sie ja dieses Remote-Löschen des Telefons so schnell machen, weil sie eigentlich nichts anderes machen als den Key wegschmeißen. Das heißt, alles ist sowieso verschlüsselt und es ist halt ein Key-Aktiv.
Es ist eben nicht alles sowieso verschlüsselt, oder? Ist pauschal? Alles, was ich auf meinem iPhone abspeichere, ist verschlüsselt?
Ja, aber es gibt halt nur ein Key für alles. Und deswegen ist das sozusagen, solange dieser Key nicht weggeschmissen ist, ist halt alles sichtbar. Und jetzt steigt sozusagen die Granularität, dass Programme quasi für ihren Kram auch nochmal einen anderen Key on top benutzen können. Und dann eine PIN oder ein Passwort erfragen. Also sie haben ja jetzt auch die Möglichkeit, längere Passwörter zu nehmen. Sodass, wenn du das Programm startest, wie das ja heute, was weiß ich, wenn du so One Password startest oder sowas, hast du es ja auch, dass die dann auch nochmal eine eigene PIN haben wollen. Oder dieses, meine Banking-Software, iOutBank macht das auch. Nur, das sind halt reine Zugangshindernisse. Und es ist nicht so, dass du damit tatsächlich ein Entschlüsseln der Daten machst.
Hoffentlich schon. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass One Password die Daten nochmal verschlüsselt.
One Password verschlüsselt ja noch nicht mal die Login-Daten auf Mac richtig, sondern nur die Passwörter. Das ist mir neulich nochmal klar geworden. Da hat hier Mac Macken drauf hingewiesen in seinem Blog. Und das ist auch bei uns kurz kommentiert.
Ja, das habe ich lange nicht gesehen.
Ja, und jetzt habe ich mir das angeschaut und dachte, ich falle vom Stuhl. Also wenn du da halt ein Login bei Facebook hast, dann ist zwar dein Password verschlüsselt, aber die Information, dass du da ein Facebook-Password überhaupt hast, die ist unverschlüsselt. Das heißt auch die Information, dass du bei YouPorn dein Account hast oder bei MyLocalSM-Group, ja, weißt du?
Hat mich tatsächlich jetzt nicht vom Hocker gehauen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Was hat dich nicht vom Hocker gehauen? Ich finde das eine Frechheit und ich wollte schon längere Zeit mal da einen Shitstorm irgendwie auf Twitter los treten, weil das geht einfach mal gar nicht. Weil sie weisen auch nicht darauf hin, dass es so ist. Anyway, bleiben wir kurz beim iPhone. Also, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Programme haben die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich will meinen Scheiß verschlüsseln und der User vergibt dem ein Passwort und das Passwort, was du eingibst, unlockt deinen Datastore. Das heißt, wenn das Telefon geklaut wird, sind tatsächlich die Daten des Programms noch mal mit diesem nur dem Benutzer bekannten Key verschlüsselt. On top der ganzen sonstigen Verschlüsselung. So habe ich das verstanden. Klar, wenn du Remote-Wipe machst, dann ist eh alles weg, aber wenn das eben nicht erfolgt, müsstest du auch, wenn du da jetzt forensisch rangehst, auch noch diesen Key auch nochmal knacken.
Weil sich ein Remote-Wipe übrigens auch relativ leicht aushebeln lässt, indem man einfach eine Büroklammer dabei hat und mal rasch die SIM-Karte rausnimmt. Was ich, wenn ich ein schlauer Dieb bin, sowieso als allererstes machen würde, um jede Nachverfolgbarkeit zu verändern.
Ja, na klar, aber es kann ja auch sein, dass ein Telefon geklaut wurde, ohne dass der Dieb schon weiß, dass er eins hat. Was weiß ich, Koffer weg und so weiter. Dann wissen schon. Naja, aber das finde ich auf jeden Fall eine gute Entwicklung. Und das ist sicherlich sehr sinnvoll, das auch unter Enterprise-Features aufzuführen. Und was dann auch noch mit dabei war, was ich auch sehr gut finde, ist, dass sie jetzt diese recht populären SSL-basierten VPN-Geschichten Out of the Box unterstützen wollen.
Da war auch was.
Das findet im Web zunehmend Verbreitung. Dass du da aber irgendwelche SSL-Sachen... Cisco hat das und ja, ist ja andere Bude.
Also noch ein bisschen mehr VPN.
Das macht einfach das Telefon noch ein bisschen seriöser.
Wie nutzt man das SSL? Ist das irgendwie auch auf HTTPS basierend? Oder ist das einfach nur...
Ja, also heutzutage läuft das meistens so, dass irgendwie so ein Java-Fu runterlädt und das Problem ist, dass das alles gebrochen ist. Dieser ganze Juniper-SSL-Scheiß, ich hab das zum Beispiel verwendet bei einer Webseite, wo ich halt nur Zugang für einen bestimmten Bereich bekomme, wenn ich eben darüber reingehe. Und da hab ich halt unter 10.5 irgendwie Java-Code geladen bekommen und mit dem 64-Bit-Java-Neue-Version und das Snow Leopard war das alles wieder nicht kompatibel und bis dabei schon ein paar Mal ein Update kommt und dieser ganze Scheiß. Naja, und beim iPhone bauen sie es ein und ich hoffe, dass sie es halt auch auf Mac bald einbauen.
Was wir noch haben an Sicherheits-Teacher Indirect ist, dass für die, jetzt kann man für jedes Einzelprogramm erlauben, ob die die Location abfragen dürfen oder nicht. Also wie es früher bei Push-Notification war, wo du pro Programm das einstellen konntest, kannst du es jetzt auch bei den Locations machen.
Also erlauben konntest du es bisher schon immer, aber wenn du es einmal erlaubt hast, kannst du es nicht mehr entlauben.
Nicht überblicken, genau.
Nur durchlöschen, oder?
So und jetzt kannst du es halt einzeln einstellen und auch noch kommt oben neben dem, was ist das da oben? Die Uhrzeit, das ist da oben rechts. Batteriestand. Neben dem Batteriestand kommt jetzt so ein kleiner Kompass-Nadel, so eine lila, die anzeigt, ob das Programm gerade die Location abfragt oder nicht.
Von allen Dingen, für die man diesen Platz da oben nutzen kann, finde ich das tatsächlich mit Anführung der Schlechteste. Ich würde da gerne sehen, ob ich eine neue Mail habe oder ob eine neue Notification da ist oder eine neue SMS, aber ob dich ein Programm gerade Location abfragt, bei dem ich es erlaubt habe, interessiert mich so nicht die Bohne.
Mich schon. Das will ich schon wissen. Das kann echt Sicherheitskontrollen sein.
Programme alle nach vorne machen, dass du die Badges siehst. Oder meinst du, dass du eine neue Mail hast, während gerade ein anderes Programm läuft?
Also da ein bisschen mehr drinne, wäre schon schick.
Vielleicht bist du ja nicht paranoid genug. Nee, ich bin ja nicht paranoid genug. Wenn du Wikileaks bist, dann machst du über sowas vielleicht schon Gedanken.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich sowieso kein Programm...
Kurz ein Hinweis hier aus dem Twitter und auch aus dem Chat. One Password verschlüsselt auch auf dem iPhone nur die Passwörter. Und iOutBank tatsächlich die Datenbank. Also, die haben das drin.
Ja, habe ich gesehen, bei iOutBank habe ich letztens geupdatet. Da kam gleich irgendwie, ist hier am Datenbankend oder Verschlüsseln oder irgendwie so. Das heißt, die haben das jetzt schon oder was?
Nee, die verschlüsseln selber.
Aber es ist natürlich ganz was anderes, ob du dann noch Verschlüsselungen von deiner Datenbank einbauen musst oder ob du einfach nur sagst, liebes Apple OS, ich möchte gerne hier einen Passwortcode abfragen vom User. Und dann musst du wahrscheinlich, jetzt mutmaße ich mal, dass wenn du das Programm das erste Mal startest, dass du eben dann ein Kennwort eingeben musst für dieses Programm. Und dass in dem Moment quasi der Key dann gesetzt wird. Und das Programm einfach ganz normal speichert, ohne irgendein Verschlüsselungscode drin haben zu müssen. Und es ist dann alles verschlüsselt und du halt auch OS-gestützt dein Passwort vielleicht auch ändern kannst. Weiß ich nicht, ist ja ein bisschen schwierig, die Bestände dann zu überführen. Aber wie auch immer. Du musst dich halt nicht mehr drum kümmern. Und du hast eben dann auch gleich Hardware-Level Security mit, keine Ahnung was sie da machen, 256 Bit AES wahrscheinlich.
Irgendein Standard Ding, was dir Armheit am besten kann. Genau.
Wir haben eine schicke neue API drinne.
Gut, iBooks, keine Ahnung. Hat glaube ich jeder mal so ein bisschen in Winnie the Pooh rum geblättert. Ist ein bisschen langsam, aber...
Ach, du hast das mal ausprobiert? iBooks?
Also ich habe... Naja, aber iBooks ist ja sozusagen als Feature angekündigt worden von dem iPhone.
Ja, aber da haben sie auch genau nichts gezeigt, oder?
Doch, sie haben gezeigt, dass es geht und dass es ein bisschen wie es aussehen wird.
Na gut, also es wird halt irgendwie dabei sein. Spannender, denke ich mal, ist dieses Game Center. Und das bekräfte ich mich ja auch nochmal in dem Glauben, dass Spiele eigentlich fast die wichtigste treibende Kraft sind in dem ganzen iPhone OS-Markt.
Haben sie gemerkt jetzt, ein bisschen schwierig. Ich glaube, die haben es nicht so geahnt am Anfang.
Doch, die haben schon ganz früh angefangen, mit Games zu werfen.
Also der iPod-Touch wurde ja quasi nur mit Games beworben.
Ja, und ich meine, ich bitte dich, die haben dies statt von ihrem Upstore. Sie wissen genau, was gekauft wird, was Umsatz macht. Also ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand Apple erklären muss, was auf ihrer Plattform gut geht. Das ist ja einer der Vorteile, der mit diesem restriktiven Modell verbunden ist. Und das zeigt halt, dass sie jetzt auch dieses Feature nachrüsten, wie das eben sonst nur bei Xbox im Wesentlichen hast. Ich glaube, bei Nintendo ist das nicht ganz so ausgeprägt. Aus guten Gründen, weil sie ja immer die Kinder beschützen müssen.
Also ich hab's nie auf einer Xbox gesehen, ich hab mir noch nie bei, ich hab auch hier keinen Open Find und wie es heißt, Plus-Plus und sowas, hab ich auch keinen Bock drauf gehabt. Ich bin kein Spieler, stelle ich mal wieder fest.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt mal gemacht habe, aus Interesse ist, bei Doodle Jump diese Facebook-Highscore-Geschichte zu aktivieren. Was dann quasi bedeutet, dass in dem Moment, wo du das tust, alle Leute auf Facebook, die auch Doodle Jump spielen, dass du deren Highscores... Wie viele Hunderttausend Leute oder Hunderttausend Score?
Leute, also du hast gesagt, dass alle Leute, die auch spielen, du jetzt deren Score siehst. Wie viele Hunderttausend Leute sind das?
30 oder so.
Also nur die, die du kennst?
Ja, also von den Leuten, denen ich bei Facebook befreundet bin. Ja, ich will jetzt, das interessiert mich, was irgendwelche Leute...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie Facebook funktioniert.
Na, Facebook, gibst du alle deine Daten und dann haltest du's maul. So funktioniert das.
Nee, ich hab die immer getwittert, wenn ich einen neuen Rekord hatte.
Hab ich gesehen. Aber da musst du halt gar nichts twittern, sondern wärst du halt bei Facebook mit deinem Doodle Jump, dann würde ich halt jederzeit... Ich kann dir das mal zeigen hier. Ich kann hier einfach die High-Score-Liste mir anzeigen lassen. Und dann geht er halt hier ins Gesichtbuch und guckt nach, wie es so bei den anderen so aussieht.
Verstehe. Und wie viel hast du denn?
Loaning-Scores.
Der macht sozusagen automatisch eine Gruppe für dich.
Was, was, was, wie viel ich was habe?
Punkte.
Ach so, was mein High-Score ist. 35.608.
Hast du noch ein bisschen zu tun.
Ja, hab nicht so viel Zeit. Und du?
81.000.
81.000. Das ist immer der Beste. Wärst du zum Beispiel in meiner Liste ganz oben? Ganz oben.
Wie viel ist denn der Oberste in deinem Facebook-Account?
40.000.
Oh ja, nee, da hast du ja noch.
Ja, New Fame for you. Du willst keinen Facebook-Account haben, oder?
Bin nicht so der Account-Fan. Ist mir zu viel einfach.
Kann ich gut verstehen.
Also es könnte mal irgendwann besser werden, wenn es immer das hier mit diesem OpenID und Zeug und so, wenn das alles mal irgendwann irgendwie ein Stück besser wird. Aber solange ich irgendwie in drei Wochen nicht mehr weiß, was ich dafür einen Account angelegt habe, so wie ich jetzt schon bei Google Wave mir das nicht merken kann.
Ja, dafür gibt es ja One Password und so.
Genau. Dafür gibt es das. Na wie auch immer, also dieses Game Center scheint noch eine relativ junge Entwicklung zu sein. Trotzdem haben sie sich schon mal entschlossen, das in iPhone OS 4.0 reinzubauen.
Also eigentlich war das ja sowieso mehr so eine Sammlung. Wir nennen das jetzt mal iPhone OS 4.0, aber zum Beispiel diese Enterprise Mobile Device Management Feature, ob sie da wirklich ernsthaft wahnsinnig viel am Software ändern müssen oder ob sie das nicht einfach ein Feature ist, was jetzt irgendwie, haben sie halt neue Roll-Out-Tools? Roll-Out-Tools. Also irgendwie Tools für kann die Management-Konsole dann eben ein paar mehr Einstellungen oder was?
Ich denke das OS 4.0 ist schon ganz schön doll viele Änderungen insgesamt.
Also es sind viele Änderungen, aber was sie jetzt vorgestellt haben, also iBooks ist jetzt, wie du sagst, ist im Wesentlichen eine App. Das hat mit iPhone OS 4.0 erstmal so nicht so unglaublich viel zu tun.
Naja, doch. Also was ich bei dem 3.2 iPhone OS gesehen habe, ist, dass die ganz, ganz viel Api-Zeug für Texthandling haben. Das ist nicht nur einfach mal so eine App, sondern...
Sie müssen auch das DRM reinpacken. Insofern passt das da schon rein.
Das DRM haben sie ja auch für den Shop. Für den iTunes Store. Das haben sie ja eh das Fairplay. Die Grundlagen dafür.
Jaja, aber sie müssen das iTunes erweitern und das ist definitiv Teil vom iPhone OS. Insofern... Nee, passt schon. Ihr habt recht. Ihr habt recht.
Ist es auch Syncing? Sie Synken ja auch deine Bookmarks, deine Lesebookmarks.
Ach, das wäre natürlich mal eine spannende Frage. Wird das transparent, ohne dass ich irgendwas anstecken muss, mit meinem iPad gesynkt?
Das war die Aussage, dass ich das tue. Also du kannst halt quasi, so wie das mit deiner Musik auch funktioniert, dann eben auf dem Device, auf your choice, weiterlesen.
Na ja, aber mit Musik klappt das ja im Augenblick überhaupt noch nicht, oder? Also da muss ich ja wirklich...
Doch, klar.
Mit Musik.
Na, wenn du es einschaltest für die Musik, dann funktioniert das.
Wie was funktioniert? Dann kann ich hier direkt auf dem Mac weiterhören, ohne dass ich...
Ja, dann musst du da mal das Flag setzen. Dann hast du das. Kennst du das nicht?
Nee, was ist denn für ein Flag?
Na, dann gehst du mal in deinen Apfel iTunes, spielst das Musikstück deiner Wahl aus und gehst auf Options. Und da gibt es ein Remember Playback Position.
Nee, das kenne ich, klar. Und das wird dann gesynkt?
Nee, OVZ iTunes.
Also da muss ich Kabel reinstecken und...
Ja, Sync halt.
Ja, das ist doch total doof.
Das ist aber eine andere Debatte.
Aber das war gerade die Frage.
Aber ich habe doch gerade die Frage gestellt, habe ich dann mit meinem iPad und.
Meinem iPhone ein Over-the-Air-Syncing meiner Podcasts?
Ach so, das mit dem Over-the-Air habe ich nicht gesehen. Nein, das geht nur davon aus, du liest ein Buch auf deinem iPad bis auf Seite 50, du synkst das Teil mit deinem iTunes, dann synkst du danach deinen... Es ist total brain dead. Wir brauchen überhaupt nicht darüber diskutieren. Es ist total brain dead und ich werde jetzt auch in jeder Sendung sagen, was für ein Syncing-Fail Apple ist, damit sich das einfach mal ändert.
Gut, Steve?
Die hören ja offensichtlich ja auch zu, ne? So mit hier irgendwie Autorotät-Log und so weiter. Das kommt ja hier auch langsam an, ne? Steve, also hast du gemerkt, ne? Syncing. Ja, wir waren noch bei diesem Game Center. Ist das jetzt noch irgendwie ein spannendes Thema? Also es macht halt so das, was man so erwarten würde. Es macht irgendwie Highscores. Es macht irgendwie, suchen wir jemanden zu mitspielen und wahrscheinlich auch diesen ganzen Freundes-Klimbim, ne?
Und wahrscheinlich wird man jedes Wort auch als Sex drin haben dürfen.
Jaja, das ist auf jeden Fall spermerfrei. Ja.
Stimmt, apropos spermerfrei, war das nicht bei Moby Dick so? Im iBook Store, dass da das Wort...
Moby Dick war ausgestrichen, ne? Und Dick und Doof wär dann auch nicht mehr da.
Ach, das wird doch ein Spaß mit diesem Bookstore.
Das wird noch lustig. So, ich wollt jetzt nochmal auf so ein paar Sachen raus. Und zwar gibt's doch immer diese geilen...
Wir haben komplett übersprungen hier versehentlich.
Wirklich?
Was denn? Ja, einen wichtigen iAds.
Oh, ja. Oh ne, ne, ne. Wollte ich überhaupt nicht überspringen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Da muss ich jetzt mal wieder... Ich muss mal dieses Soundboard aktivieren. Jetzt wäre so... Nee, jetzt hätte ich so... Eingespielt. Orgel. Chöre.
Und zwar in welche Richtung?
Na, das war wieder so ein Steve Jobs Moment. Ich weiß auch warum er das irgendwie ganz ans Ende gepackt hat. Es war wieder so ein So Leute, und jetzt erzähl ich euch mal...
Wie wir Google ficken.
Wie wir...
Ich fand das Satz einem schon sehr passend.
Ja, aber es war ja nicht nur Google, Adobat hat ja auch gleich nur einen Tritt abgekriegt. Ja, es war mir so ein, wie wir uns nicht ficken lassen. So würde ich das auch sehen. Also ich meine, seine Kerntese war, ja, okay, alles klar, mit Werbung macht man heute Geld auf Search auf dem Desktop, aber auf unseren mobilen Geräten machen die Leute nicht Search auf dieselbe Art und Weise. Heißt nicht, dass nicht einer sucht, aber wenn er sucht, ist er nicht unbedingt auf dem Pfad, Werbung zu verfolgen. Das ist eine These. Das kann man so sehen. Das ist eine Steile These. Wir werden ja sehen, wie weit er damit kommt, aber darauf basieren sie sozusagen ihre Positionierung und bauen jetzt Werbung direkt ins OS rein, was natürlich auch schon ziemlich knaller ist. Und dann halt so diese Demo.
Aber sie bauen sie ja nicht ins... Was heißt ins OS? Du kannst sie als... Als App-Entwickler kannst du dir aussuchen, ob du da Werbung in deinem Programm drin hast, von Apple schon alles vorbereitet oder halt nicht. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass demnächst der Safari oder iCare irgendwie mit Werbung kommt.
Nö, das nicht, aber du kannst in deinem Programm wahrscheinlich einfach direkt so ein Ad-View da einfach rein-draggen in deinem Interface-Bilder und dann hast du da Werbung.
Ich hab ja schon so ein bisschen Angst, dass ich irgendwann in drei Jahren noch so ein iPhone kaufe und jede dritte Safari-Seite kommt dann deren Werbung hoch. Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Du hast dir das nicht angeguckt, oder?
Ja, also ich meine die Akzeptanz von Werbung.
Da gab's doch diesen Patentantrag, dass Apple hier auch OS mit Werbung machen will. Aber es ist schon noch...
Worauf sich das Patent liegt, vermag ich nicht zu sagen. Dazu muss man sich das wahrscheinlich alles mal genau durchlesen.
Die bauen eine Werbe-AP direkt ins OS ein und liefern dir den ganzen Background mit.
Nein, ich meine, worauf sich dieses Patent konkret bezog, das vermag ich nicht zu bewerten. Das ist im Grau der IELTS. Genau, IELTS ist klar, was es ist. Und die Idee, Code zu haben, der das dann eben in der Regel mit so einem Webview wahrscheinlich anzeigt und dann verlässt du halt die Applikation nicht, das ist natürlich...
Ja, offensichtlich mit einem Webview als HTML5.
Genau, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es das unbedingt sein muss, aber wahrscheinlich wird es das in allen Fällen dann sein. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass Google da nicht mitziehen könnte. Also AdMob wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ganz schnell mal umsehen und zusehen, dass sie die Werbung als HTML5 anbieten.
Oder haben sie auch gleich noch ein bisschen gepiekt, haben sie gesagt, die Location holen nur für Werbezweck ist nicht mehr erlaubt. Zack, noch ein oben drauf gleich.
Das ist Apple vorbehalten. Nein, also es ist, man darf Location für Werbezwecke holen, aber nicht nur für Werbezwecke. Also wenn Programm...
Die ziehen sich jetzt nicht alle einen Grund aus dem Arsch, warum sie doch die Location brauchen.
Nein, also wenn du einen anderen Grund hast, außer Werbung, dir die Location zu holen, dann darfst du sie auch für Werbung verwenden.
Was ich echt okay finde. Also wenn irgendein Notizettelprogramm, was ich über Werbung finanzieren will, das mich beim Start fragt, möchte gerne deine Location wissen, finde ich das relativ nervig. Wenn es mir ein Location-Feature bietet, ein Okay ist und dann die Information nutzt, um mir...
Es fällt aber wirklich fast jedem Programm dann auch was ein, wofür es diese Location...
Dann kann ich sie abschalten, jetzt.
Das stimmt.
Ja, das finde ich...
Bei den IADS kannst du das bestimmt nicht abschalten. Also das Programm, was das IADS anzeigt, kriegt wahrscheinlich die Location nicht, aber das IADS, die Werbung selbst, holt sich bestimmt immer die Location.
Was, die Werbung selbst? Meinst du, dieser HTML5-View darf auch bei Location machen?
Du hast da keinen Überblick mehr, sondern...
Die hat er auf jeden Fall, weil das haben sie auch in einer Demo vorgeführt, dass sie so zeigen, welche Stores in einer Ehe sind und sowas. Das war ja so eines der wichtigsten Features.
Ja, die drehen alle Schrauben gleichzeitig fest.
Tja, ich bin gespannt.
Also ich finde dieses iAds... Ich finde, das ist das erste Bereich, wo ich mal diese restriktive Politik von Apple... Wo ich sage, hey, die hat mal was Gutes. Weil ich glaube, also dieses...
Du freust dich schon auf die Werbung?
Das ist ein Apple-Fanboy. Erst ist Werbung scheiße und wenn Apple das macht, dann freut man sich sogar schon auf die Werbung.
Ich meinte gesagt, dass Werbung scheiße wäre. Nicht? Nö, ich finde Werbung per Show nicht. Ich finde Werbung ermöglicht mir Dinge kostenlos zu nutzen, die ich sonst nicht hätte.
So einer bist du.
So einer bin ich. Ich finde, dass das... Werbung ist einer der Grundpfeiler unserer Demokratie. Nein, aber... Ich finde Werbung per se nicht schlimm. Ich finde Werbung im Fernsehen sehr, sehr nervig. Ich finde Werbung auch im Kino sehr, sehr nervig. Ich finde Werbung in Zeitschriften absolut in Ordnung. Und ich finde Werbung im Internet total nervig, weil sie einfach scheiße gemacht ist. Und da hat er... Da finde ich, hat es...
Weil sie meistens in Flash gemacht ist.
Nein, nicht nur weil... Ja, weil man verarscht wird. Und das habe ich das Gefühl, dass Apple in dem Fall extrem darauf achten wird, dass man da nicht verarscht wird. Weil sie wollen sich nicht die Plattform kaputt machen. Sie wollen da wirklich... Die wollen hohe Preise damit kassieren. Die wollen hohe TKP-Raten damit kassieren. Das heißt, die werden sich nicht mit Werbung ohne Ende zuballern. Jedenfalls nicht am Anfang. Und sie werden dafür sorgen, dass da keine Verarschungssachen dran sind.
Aber die Menge der Werbung bestimmt doch bestimmt die App und nicht das iPhone.
Ich nehme an, dass da auch irgendwo noch Hinweise drinstehen, wie oft so ein Werbebanner eingeblendet werden darf.
Das wird da immer stehen so.
Das wird...
Das ist halt irgendwelche Videos und da ist das...
Oder dass du einfach... Das können sie auch per Software steuern. Hallo, der probiert jetzt innerhalb von 20 Sekunden den dritten Banner anzuzeigen. Dem liefern wir nichts mehr. Also das können sie ja alles steuern. Und die werden dafür sorgen, dass das relativ exklusiv bleibt und sie werden dafür sorgen, dass die Inhalte gut bleiben. Und dass das da eben nicht so... Dieses, irgendwelche... Hey, du bist der 20-Millionste-Besucher auf dieser Seite, du hast ein Auto gewonnen, dass dieses Zeug...
Du wirst mal eigentlich gleich weglagen. Das ist voll gelogen auch.
Das ist voll gelogen und das wird das... Ich geh mal...
Du hast die Möglichkeit, was zu gewinnen.
Ach. Ich hoffe drauf, dass das einfach nicht passieren wird. Also da wird Steve Jobs persönlich dastehen und wird jeden einzelnen Werbebanner abnicken.
Das heißt, die Werbeindustrie hat jetzt dieselben Probleme wie die Developer, dass sie einfach ihre Werbung gar nicht eingereicht bekommen.
Genau. Und das ist aber...
Und das ist so Werbung, die wird dann einfach zurückgeschickt von irgendeinem...
Genau. Das sieht......Ed Store-Checker. Ich glaub, das wird da passieren. Ich glaub, das wird da passieren. Das heißt, wir werden da echt okay Werbung sehen.
Okay Werbung. Jetzt neu. Auf Ihrem iPhone.
Das wird gut sein. Da freu ich mich drauf. Endlich mal gute Werbung.
Okay Werbung. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass ich mit Werbung durchaus klarkommen könnte, wenn sie nicht die ganze Zeit so braindead und so perfide und so...
Und tatsächlich, das könnte dann dieser Hoffnungsschimmer der... Das hat kurz irgendwie Krach gemacht. Dieses... Dass das vielleicht auch... Ich weiß nicht, ob es der so dringend gewollte Rettungsanker der Verlagsbranche ist oder der letzte Sargnagel. Oder vielleicht auch gar nichts mit ihnen zu tun hat, wahrscheinlich.
Von der welchen Branche?
Verlagsbranche.
Für die Werbung?
Naja, ich meine bisher...
Du meinst, dass die ganzen Zeitungs-Apps und so, dass die dann direkt die Werbung so einblenden können?
Also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Sie können sie direkt so einblenden und müssen sich um nichts mehr kümmern und die Chance ist da, dass relativ hohe Preise auch für erzielt werden für diese Form der Werbung. Also im Augenblick ist es ja so, im Internet...
Von den Apples sich dann 30% holt.
Das ist aber wirklich branchenüblich. Das sind 40% glaube ich, die es sogar haben wollen. Das ist jetzt nicht so absurd viel. Da kommen ja auch noch, da kommen Rabatte dazu. Das ist auch viel Arbeit und so. Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so unrealistisch. Aber dass die Preise dadurch relativ hoch sein könnten, wenn das wirklich gute Werbung ist, die auch funktioniert und im Internet kostet ja alles nichts. Da kannst du ja auch kein Geld mit machen. Da kriegst du pro 1000 Klicks, kriegst du da so 1 Euro oder pro 1000 Anzeigen, wenn du Glück hast. Dann bist du schon gut, dann hast du schon fast hochpreisiges Zeug. Und ich glaube Apple wird probieren, das ein bisschen umzudrehen, dass es besser geht und dann, dass man auch als Endanwender tatsächlich im Endeffekt oder beziehungsweise als Programmierer ein bisschen mehr davon hat. Das ist so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich für die Verlage große Gefahr. Die können sich ihre eigenen Medien, also die haben noch mehr Konkurrenz. Das ist jetzt nicht nur, dass jede dahergelaufene Webseite Werbung schalten kann. In Zukunft kann auch nur jedes dahergelaufene App Werbung schalten. Und die Aufmerksamkeit wird noch weiter verteilt. Und vielleicht sinken die Werbeeinnahmen im Endeffekt doch wieder an. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Spannend auf jeden Fall. Für mich eines der spannendsten Features überhaupt, den ganzen iPhone S4.
Ich bin gespannt. Gut, kommen wir zu den sonstigen Features, weil ich glaube, die großen dicken Teile haben wir jetzt schon irgendwie ausgerollt. Was ich ja mal sehr lustig finde, sind diese Screenshots, die er da bringt, wenn er diese Features vorstellt. Du weißt, was ich meine? Wo diese ganzen Features aufgezählt sind in so einer Art Tech-Cloud. Wo dann sozusagen die großen wichtigen immer gut zu sehen sind. Mich interessieren insbesondere immer die kleinen. Jetzt blicke ich hier gerade auf einen Screenshot. Leider kommt das irgendwie nicht in HD, also dass man das nicht alles immer so gut lesen kann. Aber es gibt da auch eine ganze Menge Kleinigkeiten, die durchaus interessant sind. Ich blicke jetzt hier gerade auf einen Screenshot, der in einem Blog steht. Ach so, Mist. Aber das müsste sich trotzdem herausfinden lassen. Mit den Features.
Ich sehe gerade irgendwelche iPad-Apps.
Zum Beispiel bei Minute 9,55 gibt es sowas.
Ah, hier kommen sie gerade alle.
Das sind so diese ganzen User-Features.
Genau. Kalender-Access.
Genau, das heißt, wir machen die Kalender-API auf. Das heißt, Programme können jetzt einfach auch auf den Kalender-Store zugreifen. Das könnte schon mal alternative Call-Apps ermöglichen. Das wäre schon mal sehr sinnvoll, dass man das nicht nur mit dem normalen iCal machen kann, sondern, wie auf Mac, da mit BusyCal auch eine Alternative hast. Wobei ich die Alternative nicht so toll finde.
Carrier-Information. Das wird wahrscheinlich nur für die Telekom sein, damit die endlich ihr Bundesliga-Fernsehprogramm, damit man dann nicht mehr das WLAN abschalten muss, wenn man Bundesliga-TV gucken will.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was Sie damit meinen, aber wahrscheinlich haben die Programme einfach die Möglichkeit, auch zu erfragen, wo sie denn gerade eingebucht sind.
Und wahrscheinlich auch Signalstärke und so eine Späße.
Welche Zelle wahrscheinlich?
Mal doch mal oben. Was ich sehr interessant finde hier, sind Date- und Adressdata-Detektors. Das ist etwas, was ich auf Mac auch sehr häufig benutze, wenn ich so E-Mails bekomme, wo irgendwelche Ankündigungen kommen, doch mal rum und so. Dann kannst du da halt schnell mit der Maus reingehen und er scannt dir das schon mal vor und macht dir dann schon mal so halbwegs fertige Einträge für dein Kalender draus. Und auch dein Adressbuch.
Das haben du bisher nur für Telefonnummern, oder?
Nö, auch mit Datum und so.
Nee, ich meine auf dem iPhone.
Ja, soweit ich weiß, gibt es das nur für Telefonnummern und jetzt haben sie halt dieselbe Logik da mit drin. Programme können SMS verschicken, Programme können auf die Foto-Library, zugreifen konnten sie das nicht schon vorher auch.
Ich glaube, nur über dieses Auswahl-Dialog fällt wahrscheinlich.
Genau, also sie haben das Auswahl-Dialog und du musstest dann klicken, welches, jetzt kannst du es wahrscheinlich von alleine.
Dass sie jetzt zum Beispiel eine Slideshow aus einem bestimmten Fotoalbum anzeigen könnten oder sowas.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ich habe hier dieses Photostitch zum Beispiel, das greift auch auf meine Foto-Library zu.
Also alles, was ich kenne, ist, es geht dieser Dialog auf, also du sagst, gib mir mal ein Foto, und zwar eines aus dem Album, und dann geht der Dialog auf, und das nächste, was du empfängst, ist...
Also ich habe hier bei dem Autostitch so eine Kombination, also vielleicht ist das nur so der View, wo halt hier so die Bilder sind, aber du kannst es zumindest als View einblenden. So, ne, also du kannst jetzt hier irgendwie verschiedene Fotos direkt auswählen, also das ist schon relativ interaktiv, ich weiß nicht, was sich da jetzt verbessert hat.
Vielleicht haben sie ja auch ein bisschen...
Vielleicht ist das View halt, solange du nicht auf das Bild klickst, kommt Photostitch dann nicht ran.
Na, ich...
Vielleicht arbeiten die auch vorbei, dass die irgendwelche illegalen Apis nehmen und naja, gab's doch schon ein paar Apps von denen, die dann auch dieses... gab's eine Zeit lang diese ganzen Barcode-Leseprogramme. Die direkt auf die Kamera zugegriffen haben und trotzdem im App Store waren.
Das stimmt, aber keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es manchmal. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was Sie meinen. Wo ich das erste Mal die Augenbrauen gehoben habe, war dieses Accelerate, das hat er ja auch erwähnt. Sie haben eine ganze Library mit mathematischen Beschleunigungsfunktionen.
2000 Stück allein?
Ja, also OpenCL, ich hör dir Trabsen. Also da... So wirklich knackige, komplizierte Berechnungen werden Sie einfach an der Stelle optimieren, um die Programme einfach schneller zu machen. Das ist einfach eine extrem sinnvolle Sache. Dann haben Sie einfach eine ganze Batterie von Performance-Profiling-Tools und so weiter für Developer, was auch ganz sinnvoll ist. Irgendwas fand ich hier noch ganz bemerkenswert. Oder war das dann diese Programmiergeschichte? Das, was du sagst hier mit dem Bar kurz und diesem ganzen Augmented Reality-Klimbim, das scheint dann wohl jetzt auch einfacher zu sein. Also du hast jetzt wirklich voll Zugriff auf Bildreihen raus. Ja, Entwicklung, wofür es auch immer gut sein mag. Farbprofile ist sicherlich auch kein Fehler. Regular Expression Matching. Was ist das hier? Das kann ich irgendwie kaum lesen. iPod Remote Control Accessories. Interessant.
Jetzt mal eine technische Frage. Dieses Echo, was wir hören, dieses Blechern, ist das dann auch auf der Aufnahme drauf?
Echo?
Oder höre ich das?
Was du hörst, ist das, was du nicht hörst. Du hörst gerade einen Expander, der im Betrieb ist. Also, während wir nichts sagen, ist es still, weil es so leise ist, dass mein Expander sagt, dann mache ich doch gleich ganz leise. Und wenn du anfängst zu reden, dann hörst du einfach hier die ganzen Computer, die hier stehen. Wir haben hier drei MacBooks, der hat ordentlich geatmet und gelüftet. Das ist einfach die Background-Note, die dann reingeht. Aber ist nur bei dir, oder?
Weil wenn ich was sage, kommt es auch?
Nicht halb so stark.
Wir sind alle über denselben Expander. Wenn wir noch weiter hier ablenken wollen, ihr braucht euch hier nur mal für euch irgendwie die rote und grüne Lampe hier anschauen. Wenn ihr was redet, dann geht hier jeweils eine grüne Lampe. Wenn bei uns überall eine rote Lampe ist, dann ist alles insgesamt leise. Wollen wir mal kurz schweigen? Ja genau, wenn du halt irgendwie redest. Die Leute, die jetzt am Stream hängen, die rennen dann immer gleich so, oh, mein Stream ist weg. Weil ich müsste rein theoretisch noch so eine Comfort-Noise einspielen, so wie Skype das macht, damit man wirklich immer das Gefühl hat, dass das noch da ist. MacBook-Rauschen, Hintergrundmusik.
Ach, genau.
Hintergrundrausch reicht vollkommen aus, das nimmst du halt einfach sofort wahr, diesen Unterschied zwischen nichts und so ein bisschen Rauschen, das kann der Mensch ganz gut unterscheiden. Also im Prinzip müsste ich für den Livestream noch so eine Comfort-Noise da reinbringen. Aber wir lenken schon wieder ab, das können wir immer gut. Und irgendwo gab es nämlich noch dieses andere Bildchen.
Das eine waren ja User-Features und das andere waren ja Developer-Features.
Hier gibt es noch mehr. Dann gibt es hier irgendwie Create-Playlist. Du kannst eigene Playlisten machen. Einzel-Playlist haben sie nicht mehr. Du kannst jetzt irgendwie Playlisten machen. Birthday-Kalender, Tap-to-Focus-Video haben sie. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie die Kamera nimmst, dann kannst du nicht nur bei Foto scharf stellen auf eine bestimmte Stelle, sondern eben auch bei Video.
Digital Zoom haben sie auch.
Die Foto-Applikation macht auch Places.
Places und Faces, das ist eine sehr schöne Sache.
Genau. Du kannst halt einen Wallpaper jetzt auch auf deine Abseiten legen, wobei das sieht so furchtbar aus.
Das sieht aus wie, jetzt sehen die Dinger plötzlich aus, wie alle mit Zylia gehackt.
Schicker finde ich hier dieses, dass du jetzt in Mail irgendwie nach Sachen suchen kannst und dann auch alle gleichzeitig löschen kannst. Also erstmal Spam besser weghauen.
Das finde ich nicht problematisch. Kann man machen.
Ich sehe mir so dunkel, schwarz, ist ein bisschen entspannter.
Ich finde, es wirkt, es ist eine Ursache dafür, dass ich es nicht mehr so übersichtlich finde. Also ich habe es mal aus meinem gelgebrokenen iPhones nie gemacht, weil ich es wirklich nie vermisst habe.
Wake on wireless gibt es auch? Was die Macs auch haben, dass du sozusagen über WLAN aufgewägt werden kannst. Wozu sie das auch immer brauchen? Vielleicht für VoIP?
Vielleicht, damit ich mein iPhone besser finden kann.
Nee, für VoIP.
Dafür macht es ja...
Dass dein Ding irgendwie schläft und in dem Moment, wo du halt einen Skype-Call rein kriegst, dass das Ding dann halt...
Vielleicht wäre das für den iPod Touch eine tolle Sache, damit der wirklich so mit Notifications einfach schlafen gehen kann. Und dass er dann irgendwie über WLAN ein Signal kriegt, alles klar. Hier, warte, hier ist eine neue Notification für dich. Und wirklich...
Das wäre dann so der Effekt. Das ist ja nur so, er wird halt aufgeweckt über Netzwerke-Access. Wo ich am Anfang noch ein bisschen gerätselt habe, aber mittlerweile habe ich so einen Screenshot gesehen, ist dieses iPod Out. Das ist so eine Art Apple-TV auf Bildschirm. Das heißt, das Teil kann halt tatsächlich ein Videosignal rausgeben und ich frage mich halt, wie das beim iPhone dann gelöst wird und ob das bedeutet, dass das iPhone dann auch VGA-Ausgang bekommt. Das hoffe ich natürlich schwer, weil das wäre mal echte Killer ab. Das iPad kann das ja. Das iPad macht übrigens nur Dual-Screen. Achso, du kannst kein Mirroring machen. Du kannst kein Mirroring machen. Aber immerhin, und wenn sie jetzt VGA auch in das iPhone einbauen, wo ich auch wenig einfällt, warum das nicht gehen sollte, dann wäre das natürlich total super. Und dann bitte auch noch Keynote auf das Teil drauf. Zumindest als Player, dass ich halt fertige Präsentationen auf meinem iPhone haben kann und damit mich eben an den Beamer anschließen kann und das zeigen kann. Das fände ich echt ganz super.
Und dann über Bluetooth-Tastatur mit Player, API, da weiß ich schon, Next Song, Last Song, die dann irgendwie die Slides switchen, das ist ja geil.
Bluetooth-Tastatur, am besten so ein Bluetooth, so ein Laser-Pointer-Teil mit Knöpfchen.
Die Frage, ob das iPhone OS 4 das dann könnte, lässt sich relativ leicht mit dem SDK beantworten, wenn man einfach mal guckt, ob man einen zweiten Monitor anschließen kann beim SDK. Ich glaube, das kann man als Jahrbezeiten antworten, oder?
Also es gibt... Überschreitest du jetzt gerade eigentlich die Grenzen deiner NDAs, oder? Achso, ok, gut, ja, nur wissen wir, worüber wir reden.
Wann aber auch ein Softwarewalk sein?
Könnte Softwarewalk... Bei 3.3.1 ist es nicht an.
So, ich will mich jetzt hier nicht ewig in diesen einzelnen Features, die sowieso keinen Schwanz interessieren, festhalten, aber es gab ja noch mal so eine ähnliche Feature-Wolke bei dem eigentlichen SDK-Kram, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also wo die ganzen APIs irgendwie aufgeführt waren, oder nicht? Ich finde nur gerade die Stelle nicht. Oder war das das?
Das stellt bestimmt der Scott Forstall vor.
Ja, ich glaube, das war das schon.
Was könnte ein Qual Event, eine Notification sein?
Das habe ich schon genommen. Ich habe das jetzt sozusagen vermischt, was sie als User-Features und was sie als Developer-Features aufgeführt haben. Genau. Also da haben wir im Prinzip alles erwähnt, was jetzt hier sich rausziehen lässt aus dieser Schlüsselnote.
Ja, wollen wir mal über den eigentlichen Punkt sprechen?
Was?
Na, was wir jetzt alle ausgebuddelt haben aus den Dritthersteller SDKs mit diesem ominösen Punkt.
Der böse Abstore.
Da müsstest du gleich zum Adobe Flash-Dings springen.
Genau. Was heißt gleich dazu springen? Ist ja eigentlich viel punkter.
Ja, vielleicht kannst du ja noch irgendein langweiliges Thema vorziehen. Dann kann ich nämlich nochmal hier kurz einen Podcast sagen.
Irgendein langweiliges Thema vorziehen? Ach, du willst dich in eine bessere Position, du willst dich noch dopen heimlich auf Klo. Ach, können wir, genau, langweiliges Thema, wo Tim nicht da ist, hast du mal Opera Mini ausprobiert?
Äh, nee, ist der gut. Also was sagt der denn anders? Der macht doch aus den Bilder, macht er doch kleinere Bilder oder was, damit die schneller übertragen werden. Alles geht über den Opera-Server.
Die haben Proxy, laden alles runter und machen aus dem HTML-Code so ein Binär-Code und beten da irgendwie JavaScript ein bisschen mit anders mit ein und optimieren das Ganze ein bisschen zurecht und rechnen Bilder klein. Und das Ergebnis ist, dass du, wenn du in einer Umgebung bist, in der du keinen, also 3G hast zum Beispiel, sind die Seiten wirklich viel, viel schneller. Also statt einem Minute laden in Safari, 15 Sekunden laden in Opera Mini zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, das ist der Browser, den man benutzen könnte, wenn man mal irgendwie so voll schlechtes Netz hat?
Definitiv, in Brandenburg ist das der Browser der Wahl.
Verstehe, weil wir da auch keinen 3G haben.
Weil es da keinen 3G gibt, wenn man mit O2 unterwegs ist. Oder eben in einer U-Bahn, wo ich nur Edge habe. Der ist for free.
Aber mit Werbung oder wie war das? Aber haben wir nicht auch eine bezahlte Version von OPERA MINI?
Auf den anderen Plattformen gibt es OPERA MINI. Ist immer kostenlos, überall. Und es gibt OPERA MOBILE, glaube ich heißt das. Das ist so für Symbian und das ist ein echter, also das ist ein stinknormaler Browser, ohne dieses ganze proxige Döns. Und der kostet dann Geld. Aber OPERA MINI ist auf allen Plattformen frei. Das ist jetzt definitiv kein Browser, den ich jeden Tag einsetzen würde. Aber wie du richtig sagst, in der Gelegenheit, wenn ich mal kein schnelles Internet habe, dann macht er definitiv mehr her als Safari. Wenn ich das kann.
Dann hat man aber wieder seine Bookmarks nicht und Zeug, oder?
Klar, man muss Kompromisse eingehen. Aber ich finde ihn ganz schön gemacht. Ich finde auch diese Startseite, da hat man so dieses Tab-Dial, oder wie das heißt, wo man dann so ein neuer Bildchen hat, wo man dann auswählen kann, welche, wo man ein Preview sieht der Seite und dann braucht man nur drauf tippen. Da haben sie es schon nicht schlecht gemacht. Da haben sie auch viele Fehler gemacht, aber es ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Brawler, finde ich nicht verkehrt. Kann man sich ruhig mal runterladen.
Ja, so wir haben die Löcke gestopft.
Erfolgreich.
Ja, der Upstore, also jetzt gibt es wieder Streit. Und ich muss sagen, das war echt Popcorn. Die Sache mit der geänderten oder man könnte ja auch sagen mit der etwas verdeutlichten Formulierung aus diesem Upstore-Vertrag.
Worüber reden wir überhaupt?
Der da besagt, eine der Bedingungen, die dein Programm erfüllen muss, ist, dass du halt gegen Coco links und dass dein Programm original auch in Objective-C oder JavaScript oder C usw., also alles, was offiziell unterstützt ist, geschrieben sein muss mit den von Apple provideden Developer-Tools usw. Und da hatten wir ja auch schon mal drüber geredet vor einiger Zeit, glaube ich, hier diese Ankündigung von Adobe, dass sie jetzt ja auch als Produkt rausbringen wollten mit CS5, nämlich die Möglichkeit, Flash über diesen Umweg LLVM direkt in iPhone-kompatiblen Codes zu erzeugen, sprich, aus dem Flash-Movie eine Art Flash Standalone-Player für iPhone OS zu bauen, was aber eben nicht im einlichen Sinne mit Xcode, mit den Frameworks entwickelt worden ist, sondern eben nur ein Subset von iPhone-OS-Funktionen aufruft und dann sich entsprechend von seinem Flashcode fernsteuern lässt.
Genau.
Und dann eben dieses Programm ausführt oder bzw. dieses Flash-Movie ausführt auf dem iPhone.
Also es bietet sozusagen Flash-Entwickler eine Möglichkeit, Nativa.
Es hätte unter Umständen Flash-Entwickler die Möglichkeit geboten, iPhone-Programme zu schreiben.
Es sind ja schon ein paar von diesen Flash-Programmen im App Store.
Ja, sind die eigentlich schon wieder draußen?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß auch nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt, wie die hießen. Ich hab nie eins mir auch nur näher angeguckt. Ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht hab ich ja auch irgendwann mal ein Spiel gespielt, was in Flash geschrieben war und ich wusste es gar nicht.
Kann natürlich sein.
Bleigießen, das wär auch ein guter Keil.
Zu viele waren es nicht, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Nee, es war nicht so viele, es ist ja auch noch nicht weit verbreitet. Es ist ja irgendwie eine Beta-Version von diesem Flash gewesen, weil so soll das auch alles kommen. Und die haben es jetzt explizit verboten und das finde ich ziemlich scheiße.
Wieso?
Wozu? Wozu Entwicklertools verbieten? Wem ist damit geholfen? Ja, ok, drauf geschissen. Interessiert mich nicht auf Apple. Nein, das ist doch albern. Wieso ist mir damit geholfen, wenn...
Hast du nicht den Artikel gelesen, der von John Guba verlinkt wurde? Da stand es doch ziemlich gut erklärt und das macht doch total Sinn.
Was macht daran Sinn? Ich habe ihn gelesen. Was macht daran Sinn?
Na, die verlieren die Kontrolle über iOS. Und dann bist du halt nicht von Apple abhängig, weil du sowieso schon alle Scheiße finden, sondern bist du von Adobe abhängig. Also noch von einem der dazwischen. Vor allem ist es immer nur ein Subset von allen Features. Das heißt, die wollen das ja nicht nur... Also es ist ja so, die wollen ja nicht nur, dass Flash aufs iPhone kommt, sondern sie wollen mit dem Flash, dass es ja dann auch auf dem Android läuft. Also die exportieren ja für alle möglichen OS. Das heißt, die können zum Beispiel vom iPhone nicht einen Feature anbieten in dem Flash, was es dann irgendwie auf dem Android nicht gibt. Also könnten sie schon machen, aber dann kann der Flash-Programmierer wieder nicht ein App bauen, was irgendwie auf beiden läuft. Aber das ist ja der Sinn der Sache. Das heißt, es wird immer nur ein Subset von allen möglichen OS-Plattformen sein. Und das haben die doch da erklärt, dass auch der App sich nicht mehr individualisieren kann, sondern es ist alles nur noch Standard.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht.
Sondern? Was nutzt denn Flash, bitteschön?
Flash nutzt nicht viel. In Flash kann ich ein absolutes Subset an Funktionen nutzen.
Das heißt, wenn du dich entscheidest, mit Flash deine iPhone-Applikationen zu machen, dann gibt es für dich nicht nur keine Motivation, sondern auch keine Möglichkeit, irgendwelche der advancederen Möglichkeiten von diesem iPhone OS auszunutzen. Genau. Es sei denn, du wartest darauf, dass Adobe das dann mal einbaut in Flash als solches. Und dass es dann eben auch die Möglichkeit gibt, das bei diesem Übersetzungsvorgang aufs iPhone zu machen. Das ist etwas, an dem Apple einfach kein Interesse hat. Sie wollen Bleeding Edge sein. Es geht jetzt um Apple. Sie wollen die beste Plattform sein. Und sie wollen vor allem, die Programmierer treiben können, möglichst viel von der Plattform, von den Funktionen, die sie offiziell bieten, auch zu nutzen. Damit sie einfach die bessere Plattform sind durch bessere Programme. Punkt. Das ist einfach das Interesse von Apple. Denn das ist das, wie sich das iPhone von allen anderen Plattformen unterscheidet. Und derzeit ist dieser Unterschied noch enorm. So, wenn Sie jetzt so jemanden wie Adobe im Rücken haben, die ja nun in den letzten 20 Jahren nicht, ich übertreibe, in den letzten Jahren, 10 Jahren nicht gerade damit brilliert haben, ihr Flash auf einer Plattform von Apple in besonders eleganter Art und Weise auszuliefern. Also wir reden immer noch von einem Flash-Plugin, was häufig crasht, langsam ist und so weiter. Einfach in Ressourcen ein hungriges Teil ist, was aber darüber hinaus eben auch nicht sehr viel bietet. Das ist einfach nicht in Apples Interesse und deswegen lassen Sie das nicht zu.
Okay, das ist nicht in Apples Interesse.
Genau, und ich finde es auch nicht im Interesse der User.
Wieso nicht?
Aus denselben Gründen eigentlich. Weil ich möchte gerne die Möglichkeit haben, dass jedes Programm, das ich benutze, eben dieses OS maximal ausnutzt.
Würde nicht passieren.
Wenn die Leute sich, wieso passiert das nicht?
Weil der App-Store voll ist mit Flashlight-Applikationen, die sind alle nicht in Flash geschrieben. Das ist ein App, was ein Bildschirm hell macht, das nutzt keine Delfast-Funktion.
Na gut, das tut es vielleicht nicht, aber es gibt halt genug Programme, die das sehr wohl tun. Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie eine Herrscher von Programmierern sich auf Flash committet, weil sie sagen, naja, da kann ich ja irgendwie alles mit targeten.
Herrscher von Programmierern sind auf Flash committet.
Ja, aber das ist für mich auf der iPhone OS-Plattform uninteressant. Wenn jemand auf der iPhone OS-Plattform mit Geld verdienen möchte, indem er seine Apps zum Verkauf anbietet, dann kann er nicht über Flash gehen. In dem Moment, wo sie aber das so zulassen, gehen die Leute einfach mal über Flash, weil sie einfach faul sind. Apple hat an faulen Programmierern kein Interesse, sondern sie wollen, dass wenn sich jemand für diese Plattform committet, dass er das dann auch vollständig tut und dass er sich darauf einlässt, was Apple macht. Das ist einfach das Hauptinteresse.
Also jetzt erklären wir nochmal.
Wenn ich mir die Geschichte anschauen von Intermediate Layers, ich kenne keinen einzigen Intermediate Layer der letzten 30 Jahre, der mir jemals irgendeine User Experience geboten hat, die ich haben wollte. Aber ich kenne tonnenweise Beispiele von Shitstorm und Scheiße und Ekel und furchtbar und schlimm. Es ist alles furchtbar. Google Earth, das User Interface, ich brech ins Essen. Moment mal. Das ist einfach mal die Hölle. Was liegt darunter? Moment.
Moment. Wir reden hier von zwei komplett verschiedenen Paar Schuhen.
Doch. Ich rede von Intermediate Layern, von Programmen, die einem dem Programmierer ein anderes API bieten und das Cross-Plattformen, compilen und sozusagen auf jedem OS das Minimum bringen. Da gehört gut T dazu, da gehört irgendwie GTK dazu, da gehören all diese ganzen Sachen, Flash dazu und Interface Toolkit.
Real Basic.
Das sind Programmierer-Schnittstellen. Das ist das, was sozusagen...
Ja, aber Flash ist keine Programmierer-Schnittstelle. Flash ist ein Authoring-Tool.
Das ist doch überhaupt gar kein... Da hast du eine Programmiersprache.
In Flash wird niemand programmiert. Also ich weiß, dass Adobe das gerne möchte, aber niemand programmiert in Flash ernstzunehmende Anwendung, sondern Flash wird genutzt für kleine Spiele, für so ein Zeug.
Das ist doch eine Ernst-Anwendung.
Das ist doch eine Ernst-Anwendung. Warum habe ich jetzt als Anwender einen Vorteil davon, wenn ein bestimmtes Programm auf dem iPhone nicht geht, weil Apple gerade irgendwie mit Adobe nicht kann?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich habe nicht einen Vorteil davon, wenn es nicht geht. Es gibt dieses Programm gar nicht. Ich möchte gerne, dass jedes Programm gut sein kann. Wenn Adobe das aber kontrolliert, wie gut ein Programm sein kann... Selbstverständlich. Wenn du über Flash aufs iPhone gehst, dann kann dein Programm maximal das, was dir diese Flash-Environment bietet und kein Funken mehr. Da ist Gleichmacherei drin und du hast da keine Native-Controls und Pipapo. Es ist alles nur das, was Flash kann. Du hast da nichts, was so aussieht wie auf dem iPhone.
Wie bei absolut jedem Spiel. Zeig mir ein Spiel, was Standard-iPhone-Controls benutzt.
Na, Settings und...
Zeig mir ein Spiel, was Standard-iPhone-Controls nutzt.
Ein Spiel, was Standard-iPhone-Controls nutzt. Naja, es geht ja nicht nur...
Wo nutzen das irgendwelche Standard-iPhone-Controls?
Da sind Buttons da, normale Buttons. Table-View, alles da.
Doodle-Jump?
Das ist doch ein Table-View, alles Standard. Na, weil es der Table-View ist.
Nee, ich meine, woran siehst du das?
Wieso er sonst mal?
Du meinst ja, ach ja klar, da ist es doch. Ja, merkt man. Hier, gucke mal. Doodle-Jump, High Score-Liste. Das Scrolling-Behaviour ist iPhone Scrolling-Behaviour. Das stimmt schon. Da hat der Dennis total recht.
So, da haben sie ein Table-View eingesetzt, der überhaupt nicht aussieht wie ein Table-View.
Doch, der verhält sich genauso. Da scrolle ich irgendwie mit der Hand genauso. Ich flicke da irgendwie hoch und runter. Das bounce schön und so weiter. Das verhält sich halt einfach wie ein iPhone-Programm.
Also, dass die Flash-Programmierer sich natürlich ärgern, weil ihnen jetzt einen Weg genommen wurde, einfach aufs iPhone zu kommen, ist ja klar.
Jetzt liefert aber Apple selber Programme aus, die das nicht tun, die nicht die Standard-Controls einsetzen. Weil die das zum Beispiel in Safari nicht unterstützen. Es gibt hier diese iPhone-Einführung.
Geht es jetzt um Standard-Controls oder um Flash?
Moment, also wir müssen zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Wenn ein Programmierer sich dazu entscheidet, irgendwas nicht zu benutzen, dann ist das was anderes, als ob ein Programmierer sich nicht dazu entscheiden kann, etwas zu benutzen. Da ist der entscheidende Unterschied, und da liegt auch der Hase begraben. Apple will sich nicht von einer dritten Gruppe, von einer Third-Party, einen Weg verbauen lassen. Und es ist halt einfach so, wenn Apple jetzt in iPhone OS 5.0 irgendein geiles Feature einbaut, für das Adobe seinen ganzen Flash-Generator komplett umschreiben müsste, damit dieses Feature überhaupt genutzt werden kann.
Oder es nicht geht, weil es auf Android nicht funktionieren sollte.
Und es gibt übrigens schon mit diesem Multitasking die ersten Hinweise, dass das schon mal einer dieser substanziellen Gründe sein kann. Also einfach dieses ganze Suspend und so weiter. Wir werden in sehr kurzer Zeit eine ganze Menge Applikationen finden, die dem konform sind. Wenn das aber erst mal ein Jahr dauert, bis Adobe sein CS6 rausgebracht hat oder eine anderthalb Jahre oder zwei Jahre, dann hat Apple einfach unter Umständen bei einer Herrscher von Programmen, an die sich Leute dann schon gewöhnt haben, einfach verloren und muss zwei Jahre warten. Und dann macht Adobe das irgendwie aber anders, als Apple das gerne möchte. Und dann müssen sie nochmal zwei Jahre warten. Und dann haben sie vier Jahre verloren. Und die ganzen Flash-Programmierer sind der Meinung, das wäre ja ein legaler Weg, dort iPhone-Apps zu machen, aber die Abqualität wird halt nicht besser. Und das ist das, was einfach Apple verhindern will. Da haben sie einfach gar kein Interesse dran. Und da ist ihnen das auch scheißegal, wie viele Flash-Programmierer sie darüber bekommen könnten.
Dass Apple daran kein Interesse hat, ist mir scheißegal. Warum soll das in meinem Interesse sein?
Weil deinem Interesse als wer? Als Benutzer? Als Benutzender. Ich will gute Programme haben. Ich will nicht noch mal so ein Google Earth haben. Ich finde Programme, die einfach mit Intermediate-Frameworks und die nicht native geschrieben sind, finde ich einfach mal scheiße. Sag mir mal ein nicht-native Programm auf dem Mac, was geil ist. Ja, okay. Den Konflikt haben wir schon ein paar Mal ausgetragen, aber das ist genau der Grund, ich will nicht so was wie Firefox haben. Ich finde Firefox auf dem Mac einfach eine Zumutung. Okay, das mag ja das sein, dass das irgendwie so innerhalb dieses Fensters... Ich glaube, dass man alles ganz nett rendert, aber dieses Programm verhält sich nicht wie ein Macintosh-Programm. Das mag sein, dass der HTML ganz gut umgerechnet bekommt.
Ich kann mehr als 10 Tabs gleichzeitig bekommen.
Das ist schonmal die gelbe Karte erstmal. Wir haben das ja besprochen, Jungs.
Okay, jetzt streiten wir uns wieder. Für die Hörer, wir haben jetzt Dennis macht jetzt hier mal den Titsrichter.
Also das Thema ist jetzt, wir wissen, also ich sehe das ein als User, wenn man erstmal so guckt. Klar, da sind Programme, die nicht kommen. Manche User interessieren sich vielleicht nicht für, ich fasse jetzt mal zusammen, interessieren sich vielleicht nicht so für Quality, sondern die wollen halt einfach so ihr liebtes Flash-Game haben. Und natürlich ist das ein bisschen blöde. Apple ist das aber schnurz, weil die müssen ja ein bisschen mehr Big Picture gucken. Die wollen natürlich ihre Marktmacht nicht verlieren. Und das wichtigste, glaube ich, warum die das nicht wollen, ist, dass wenn einer ein geiles Flash-Spiel schreibt, und die gibt es ja auch, also Desktop Tower Defense ist, einfach mal Flash, das war richtig cool. So, wenn einer so ein Spiel schreibt und das ist richtig geil, und der User sich dann denkt, scheiße, iPhone ist ja so teuer, die nächste Granat von 8.000 Euro, habe ich jetzt gar keinen Bock. Und Android, da läuft man ein geiles Flash-Spiel ja auch, weil es gibt ja auf allen Plattformen, oder noch die dritte, die irgendwann kommt, wo Adobe das natürlich auch rausbringen wird, dann geht er da hin und da hat Apple ja so gar keinen Bock drauf. Und das verstehe ich so. Also ehrlich gesagt, ich würde es auch so machen. Weil die können sich ja nicht mehr absetzen, weil dann sind sie ja nur noch Flash-Simulator und sonst nichts. Das ist genau das Gleiche, warum Microsoft Angst hatte, dass irgendwie die ganzen Programme irgendwie im Browser landen. Das haben sie sich mal irgendwann angeguckt, sofort verstanden und hatten einen riesen Schiss davor, dass iOS einfach nicht mehr wichtig ist, sondern dass alles nur noch im Browser ausgeführt wird. Das ist irgendwie bisher noch nicht passiert, aber das war eine Weile lang mal, wo alle gesagt haben, Programme werden sich in den Browser verlagern. Und da hatte Microsoft sowas von die Hosen voll. Das ist der Grund, warum Apple das nicht will.
Ich glaube auch, dass das der Grund ist, warum das Apple nicht will. Aber wie gesagt, in meinem Interesse ist es glaube ich nicht.
Das ist klar. Wenn ich auch ein Game haben will, geht es nicht.
Das ist übrigens auch in meinem Interesse nicht als Entwickler, weil es gibt halt, wenn man, um auf dem iPhone arbeiten zu können, gleich eine separate Programmiersprache lernen muss.
Aber guck mal jetzt nochmal auch, du bist immer noch der gleiche Developer. Und du machst jetzt, hast ein geiles Flash-Game und so, programmierst gegen dieses Adobe-Zeugs. Und dann kommt Apple mit so einem richtig geilen Kram raus und dann sagt er Adobe, ja, nee, können wir noch nicht unterstützen, weil gibt es bei Android noch nicht und dann kannst du es nicht nutzen. Ist das nicht blöd dann?
Dann kann ich es dann neu schreiben in Objective-C. Ja, dann hast du aber schon mal Jahre lang auf der falschen Pferde gewesen. Moment mal, in einem Fall ist es so, dass möglicherweise in irgendeiner fernen Zukunft mal ein Fall eintreten könnte, der das und das, der mich dann dazu zwingt, Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und zu investieren, um mein Spiel auf eine andere Plattform zu portieren. So habe ich gar keine andere Möglichkeit. Egal was, selbst wenn ich ein kleines, einfaches Programm haben will, ich möchte nur ein Tetris programmieren und das keinerlei Features nutzt, ich bin dazu gezwungen, wenn das auf dem iPhone laufen soll, muss ich das in Cocoa Touch machen. Ich habe keine Möglichkeit.
So ist das.
Es gibt keinen guten Grund dafür. Moment mal, aber das heißt nicht, dass du das gut filmen musst.
Da spiele ich mal Apple und sage einfach, dann geh. Ich bin jetzt mal Apple. Du bist ein Pro-Mio und du willst was. Dann kommst du dir das an, so eine kleine Leuchte. Du willst auf mein Telefon, du willst Teil meines Produktes sein. Du willst auf mein Premium-Environment mit heiligem Schein. Du kommst dann irgendwie da her und sagst, ich scheiße auf euch, irgendwie wie so ein Punk. Du kommst dann so da her, halbe Bierflasche in der Hand. Und dann sag ich einfach, geh. Mach, geh auf Android, geh woanders hin. Aber bei uns kommst du ja so nie rein.
Ich find das als Ant-Anwender exorbitant scheiße, dass Apple glaubt, dass sie aus eigenem Interesse mir als Anwender was verbieten.
Nee, die als Developer verbieten sie.
Nee, als Ant-Anwender.
Im Ant-Anwender garantieren sie einfach nur, dass sie bei jedem einzelnen Programmierer zur Not in der Lage sind, zu sagen, du verhältst dich hier nicht konform mit den Frameworks, du musst dein Programm jetzt mal hier auf Vordermann bringen, damit du eben wieder mal richtig kompatibel bist. Und das können sie halt nicht machen, wenn die Leute auf eine Third-Party-Umgebung setzen, auf die sie gar keinen Einsatz haben.
Natürlich können sie das machen. Entschuldigung mal bitte, sie können einfach sagen, in dem Moment, in dem sie feststellen, dass Adobe sich nicht mal deswegen an irgendwelche Regeln hält.
Ja, aber wenn das dann irgendwie auf einmal 60.000 Games sind, dann kommen alle zu Apple und sagen, ihr seid schuld. Ihr habt mein Programm weggenommen.
Die würden nicht zu Adobe gehen und...
Rote Karte?
Nein, die gehen zu Apple. Apple ist nämlich dann schuld. Das ist nämlich der Punkt.
Wenn Adobe nicht in einer Lage ist, in der Entwicklungsumgebung, z.B.
Ja, das sehen die nicht. Das sehen die nicht.
Der normale User weiß doch gar nichts.
Der normale User peilt auch diese Zusammenhänge nicht.
Moment mal, wir reden jetzt gerade nicht vom normalen User, sondern von einem Flash-Entwickler.
Ich würde sagen, wir switchen erstmal das Thema.
Flash-Entwickler. Flash-Entwickler, weißt du, das ist schon ein höherer Flash-Entwickler.
Jungs.
Wenn ihr der richtige Entwickler seid, dann geht man nicht auf Flash. Das ist unanständig. Ich finde das unanständig. Ja, richtige Environments, richtig nackt mit dem Betriebssystem, irgendwie muss man sich verabreden und sagen, ja, AP, komm her.
Ja, es gibt aber auch Leute, die irgendwann mal fertig werden wollen.
Fertig werden?
Ja, die irgendwann mal was ausliefern wollen. Entschuldigung, bitte, du willst ja jetzt nicht ernsthaft sagen, dass ein Grafiker gefälligst, der ein Flash-Banner basteln will oder der ein kleines Flash-Spiel schreiben will, dass der gefälligst jetzt Objective-C zu lernen hat?
Nein, wenn du ein Flash-Banner machen willst, dann musst du das natürlich in Flash machen.
Ja, oder auch wenn du ein kleines...
Das Problem ist überhaupt erst mal in Flash machen zu wollen.
Was ist daran denn so ein absurde...
Ich finde das verärflich.
Du findest das verärflich?
Aber jetzt sage ich dir mal, was ich scheiße finde an dieser Regelung. Anderer Aspekt. Also diese Regelung konkret mit dem, was sie dort versuchen zu verhindern in der Formulierung, wie sie es tun, hat noch einen anderen interessanten Kollateralschaden und es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, wie das ausgehen wird. Also ich finde, du siehst es anders, akzeptiere ich. Ich sage, ich kann die Motivation von Apple nachvollziehen und ich finde das eine gute Sache.
Ich kann die nachvollziehen, aber ich finde es nicht gut.
Sowohl für Entwickler als auch für Endanwender. Ich finde das gut. Und klar kann das sein, okay, dann sperren sie aber aus, dass jetzt die Flash-Entwickler mit ihrem Flash kommen und das dann darauf machen. Da sage ich nur, so what? Ich habe noch nicht so viel Großartiges gesehen in dieser Flash-Welt, dass ich da irgendwas groß vermissen würde. Nichts, was in Flash gemacht ist, wie sie sich nicht auch anders machen. Das ist keine Plattform...
Hallo, natürlich lässt sich das alles anders machen.
Das ist keine Plattform, die jetzt irgendwelche besonderen Fertigkeiten mit sich bringt.
Doch, sie ist extrem weit verbreitet.
Ja, das wird aber nicht mehr lange so sein. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass sie jetzt da hergekommen sind. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ist diese Formulierung noch mal genau, dass du quasi nur Code laufen lassen kannst, der... ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Es gab ja jetzt gestern noch mal eine andere Zurückweisung eines Programms aus dem App Store. Wie hieß das Ding? Scratch? Und das ist so eine...
Da haben sie aber gesagt, der soll es nochmal reinstellen.
Nein, das war was anderes. Das war dieser Kartonist. Da ging es mal wieder so um, weißt du so, Cartoons und Politik und Beleidigung. Der, der den Pulitzer hat. Genau, der Typ, der den Pulitzer hat. Darüber will ich aber gar nicht reden, sondern ich will reden über dieses andere Game. Das ist natürlich ein Spiel, das ist ein Problem, was auch viele Games haben, weil es nämlich mittlerweile auch ein Wesen von Games an sich ist, und dass Games natürlich ihre eigene Engine haben. Apple aber sagt, Engines bei uns nur, wenn es JavaScript ist, kurz gesagt. Wenn du irgendwie mit Lua gescriptet bist oder mit irgendwas anderem oder deine eigene Game-Engine mitbringst. Und das war halt bei diesen Scratch-Gamen, ist das halt einfach so. Und da ist es eben aber auch Teil des Prinzipes, dass du ja quasi in deinem Programm, innerhalb dieser Laufzeit-Umgebung deine eigene Programmiersprache entfaltest. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch eine ganz sinnvolle Geschichte. Weil was ist, wenn du halt ein Programm in den Upstore bringen willst, was dir Programmieren als solches ermöglichen soll? Hier, denk mal an Logo, Schildkröte steuern und so weiter. Wo es ja sozusagen Teil des Konzeptes ist. Oder du irgendeine visuelle Programmierungs-Umgebung geschaffen hast, mit der du eben Dinge steuern kannst. Robotik, das kann man ja beliebig weit denken. Diese Idee des Skriptings. Und eigentlich, wenn man jetzt Apple genau auslegt, beschränkt sich das quasi auf JavaScript. Ich würde das sehr elegant finden, wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, ok, ich skripte hier mein Game mit JavaScript. Kann man nämlich auch machen. Kenne ich auch ein paar Beispiele. Aber andererseits finde ich das auch ein bisschen daneben, wenn man jetzt einen Game-Developer zwingt, JavaScript zu nehmen, obwohl er eine andere Programmiersprache wie Lua für angemessener hält. Und an der Stelle wird es nämlich sehr schwierig, weil das, was die Programme an der Stelle machen, die Games, die ja In-Game-Scripting haben, ja gar nicht das im Sinne tun mit wir schaffen hier eine Plattform, in der Anwendung gemacht werden kann und das ist dann in so einer Engine embedded und dann kommen da ganz viele Spiele damit. Obwohl das wahrscheinlich bei Electronic Arts und so weiter, weil diesen ganzen großen Game-Hersteller eben auch nicht sehr viel anders läuft letzten Endes. Und diese Games wollen sie ja auch gar nicht verzichten.
Na werden sie auch nicht, die werden ja einfach drin lassen und die ganz locker ignorieren.
Ja aber jetzt haben sie halt schon mal einen rausgeworfen, der das macht.
Das war wahrscheinlich so ein kleiner, den sie geopfert haben, um Adobe zu zeigen, wir machen es auch.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn sie Adobe irgendwas zeigen wollen, dann brauchen sie nur Flash-basierte Sachen rausschmeißen und dann weiß auch jeder, dass es nur about Flash ist. Sie behaupten ja, das sei ja nicht so. Auch wenn ich schon glaube, dass Flash mit Abstand das größte Problem ist in dem Zusammenhang. Ich bin gespannt, wie das ausgeht. Vor allem dieses aktuelle Gerücht, dass Unity, die ja meines Wissens ein Environment für C-Lattenzaun anbieten, durchaus noch eine Chance haben, drin zu bleiben. Das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Hast du dir das mal angeguckt?
Dieses 3D-Game, die benutzt man als Tool?
Ich glaube, ich verwechsel jetzt gerade was. unity3d.com Ich meine, wie heißt denn dieses Tool, was einfach einem erlaubt, iPhone Apps in C-Sharp zu machen?
Ach so, Mono? Monotouch.
Dann habe ich das verwechselt. Wie komme ich denn jetzt auf Unity? Unity3D ist eine Game?
Die haben auch.
Und warum sind die gefährdet?
Weil man damit Spiele entwickeln kann und die nicht in Objective-C schreibt, aus dem gleichen Grund.
Ach so, weil sie C-Lattenzaun und JavaScript benutzen. Und das Problem ist C-Lattenzaun an der Stelle. Tja, also das ist halt gut. Da sind wir mitten drin in diesem Problem. Game-Frameworks sind irgendwie auch Tools, die dir Cross-Platform-Development erlauben.
Macroobie. Macroobie wäre ja theoretisch auch noch mal ein Kandidat gewesen.
Aber das ist ja nur hypothetisch, weil die gibt's ja noch nicht. Niemand weiß, ob der überhaupt auf dem iPhone gekommen wäre.
Oder vielleicht nur noch kommt.
So wird's nie passieren. Wieso? Weil eben Apple da drin steht, darf nicht.
Also ich meine, der Chef macht seine Regeln selbst.
Ja, Moment mal. Aber so unabhängig, wie es kommt von Apple, es ist ja ein Open-Source-Projekt, und es wird ja weiterentwickelt.
Macroobie wird bei Apple entwickelt.
Ja, es mag ja bei Apple entwickelt werden, aber wenn jetzt irgendjemand dafür eine Garbage-Collection macht, sagt, hey, Moment mal, dann kommt wieder jetzt neu und es läuft auf dem iPhone, wäre das erstmal keine Apple-Entwicklung.
Nee, erstmal nicht, auch wenn Apple irgendwann sagt, wir machen das jetzt so offiziell.
Ja, wenn die dann irgendwann mal aus dem Kram kommen oder aus dem Arsch kommen und sagen, alles klar, wir haben jetzt auch irgendwann mal gekriegt, dass es sich halt was anderes gibt. Aber wenn jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt, Moment mal, ich hab hier eine Lösung gefunden, dann geht's erstmal nicht. Dann geht's nicht.
Aber bei Macroobie sehe ich noch am ehesten die Chance, dass das noch mal den Weg aufs iPhone findet. Allerdings glaube ich da erst dran, wenn es auch wirklich den Weg auf den Mac richtig gefunden hat. Also wenn die da... Wenn sie auf Mac, irgendwann mal Macroobie als... Ach, übrigens, und jetzt könnt ihr auch Programme in Ruby schreiben, und das ist genauso wie Objective-C, was ich nach wie vor für möglich halte, aber auch nicht als gesetzt, dass das stattfinden wird.
Da hatten sie vor 10 Jahren mit Java, haben sie vor 2 Jahren oder einem rausgeschmissen, ist auch nie irgendwas passiert.
Ist aber eine andere Geschichte. Ja, es ist eine komplett andere Geschichte.
Eigentlich nicht.
Doch, weil es nicht auf derselben Ebene verheiratet ist. MacRuby ist wirklich mitten in den Foundation Classes drin. Das ist komplett verschmolzen. Auf der niedrigsten Ebene treffen sich MacRuby und Objective-C Libraries treffen sich einfach an derselben Stelle. Während du bei Java immer noch irgendwie eine Brücke hast und du hast es mit einer nicht-dynamischen Programmiersprache zu tun, Java war gar nicht in der Lage, da alles abzubilden, was Objective-C abzubilden in der Lage war. Und das ist bei McRuby halt ganz anders. Man kann bei McRuby alles abbilden, was Objective-C macht. Und deswegen passt das eben auch gut zusammen. Deswegen glaube ich auch, dass sie da deshalb diese Energie da reinstecken. Also das ist hypothetisch. Es ist nur ganz klar, Apple hat immer noch das Problem, dass sie mit ihren ganzen Regeln, die sie dort rausgeben, einfach unscharf sind. Niemand weiß genau, was sie eigentlich jetzt scheiße finden und was nicht. Und ab und zu sehen sie sich mal genötigt, das genauer zu formulieren, wie sie es jetzt getan haben. Aber es gibt nach wie vor auch Ablehnungen in diesem Upstore, die eben einfach keinerlei Basis haben. Also wo irgendwie keiner weiß, warum ist das jetzt abgelehnt worden? Ich habe doch gegen gar nichts verstoßen, was in dieser Liste drin steht.
Um es mal kurz zu sagen, bei jeder Plattform kann man sich aussuchen, in welcher Programmiersprache man spielt. Programmiert beim iPhone kann man das nicht, finde ich scheiße.
Naja, ist der gleiche Grund wie mit den Apps selbst. Kannst du auch nicht jedes App reinschalten, sondern nur, wenn es denen gefällt. Sonst ist es halt nur mal eine Restricted-Plattform. Da muss man sich mit abfinden.
Und wird tendenziell eher restrikteter als alles andere? Das ist das, was ich gerade problematisch finde.
Nö, es ist nicht restrikteter als alles andere. Es gibt durchaus Plattformen, die sind noch sehr viel strikter.
Nee, es wird immer restrikteter.
Xbox, Nintendo, Sony, diese ganzen Game-Konsolen, das sind alles noch viel schärfere Environments, wo du viel mehr Geld investieren musst und wo noch viel genauer geprüft wird, was du da raushauen darfst. Ja, da musst du sogar irgendwie von den Herstellern, die produzieren auch noch die Scheiben für dich, und du musst deren Development-Tools benutzen und so weiter. Also das ist da noch viel knalliger. Und das iPhone ist im Prinzip etwas, was halt zwischen diesen vollständig geschlossenen Game-Konsolen ist und den Computern. Und das iPhone liegt irgendwo dazwischen. Sie versuchen da also eine Melange von so offen, wie es geht, aber so geschlossen, wie sie es brauchen. Das ist der Spagat, den sie da versuchen. Und es ist noch nicht klar, wie weit die Reise führt, und es ist auch noch nicht klar, wie weit sie da an Android oder andere Systeme noch Anteile verlieren. Es gibt definitiv eine diverse Gattung von Programmen, wo die Leute gar nicht erst zum iPhone gehen. Weil sie einfach sagen, das ist so offensichtlich, dass wir da gegen eine Wand laufen, da sind wir dann eher bei Android zu Hause. Weil das dann eben an der Stelle auch freier ist. Ob das dann eben für sie sich auszahlen wird, ist die Frage. Macht schon irgendjemand richtig Geld bei Android?
Ich würde ja da mal Zahlen interessieren, so insgesamt, wie viel Android für uns gibt es denn?
Das sind schon nicht wenige, das sind schon viele.
Na wie viele?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Zahlen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass das alles nach wie vor extrem zerklüftet ist.
Also was ich mitgekriegt habe, ist, dass es auf der Republika, zum Beispiel, die Entwickler haben einen unglaublichen Aufwand, damit das für alle Plattformen zum Laufen zu kriegen. Das stimmt schon alles. Einfach so ein Stimmungsbarometer ist, dass auf der Republika, wo letztes Jahr noch alle nach einem iPhone gelegt sahen, war dieses Jahr das Nexus One, das Begehrlichkeitsobjekt des Tages.
Das iPhone ist ja auch schon kein Ding, aber hat ja jeder eins.
Die Trauben haben sich doch eher ums iPad gebildet.
Das stimmt, das Nexus One ist noch ein bisschen verbreiteter. Aber so mit Leuten, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, was die sich kaufen wollen, das war... Also hier Andreas, der bei mir jetzt gepennt hat, der meinte so, ey, ich bekomme endlich ein paar... Na, wo bekomme ich endlich mein Nexus One? Und so was, das sind jetzt... Der holt sich vielleicht noch ein iPad, aber... Das ist schon... Das... Da finde ich schon so ein bisschen so ein Umdeckenstand. Und ich glaube genau wegen dieser Abgeschlossenheit.
Ja, ich nehme das zur Kenntnis, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, das ist einfach... Wie sagt man so schön? Ein... Strom im Wasserglas.
Im Chat beschwert sich gerade jemand drüber, dass das Nexus One ein schlechtes Telefon wäre, weil es keine Testatur hätte.
Jetzt haben wir schon 5x M gesagt. Ich nicht. Wollen wir das Thema iPhone OS abschließen? Ja.
Gut.
Dann kommen wir zur Hardware.
Ja, voll toll.
Es gibt neue MacBooks. Nein, es gibt neue MacBook Pros. Genau.
Und zwar gibt's ja jetzt die Unibodies, wie lange? Schon zwei Jahre jetzt schon wieder, oder wie lange?
Ende 2008 war das, ne?
Ja. Auch mit den Unibodies ist ja nichts passiert. Die Auflösung ist ja seit Jahrzehnten die gleiche. 1440 x 900.
Du redest vom 15-Zoller.
Ja, genau. Das ist so das Standardding eigentlich. Ich hab mir mal schon gesagt, weil meine Kiste hier ist von Ende 2006, ich hol mir erst wieder eins, wenn die Auflösung größer geworden ist. Ja, jetzt hat es ja gehalten und endlich dürfte ich jetzt. Und das ist schon mal ein Feature, warum es sich auflösungsmäßig lohnt. Also muss man halt drauf sein, bei Apple ist es halt so. Aber dass man jetzt die Auflösung mal ein bisschen mehr bekommt. Dann speedmäßig hat sich auch was getan. Das war jetzt auch seit Ende 2006. Ich glaube, Mainz war das erste Core Duo. Anfang 2006 oder Mitte kam erst mal ein normales Core Duo raus. Egal. Jedenfalls war es die ganze Zeit die Core Duo-Reihe. Inzwischen haben sie jetzt gewechselt zu i5 und i7. Aber nur beim 15-Zoller und dann sitzen wir hier. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie den schon wieder aufgeben.
Im 15-Zoller ist noch ein Core Duo drin.
Ja, die haben sie noch nicht gewechselt.
Und im 17-Zoller auch? Wirklich?
Ich glaube schon.
Guck das mal parallel raus. Jedenfalls Core 2 Duo war schon ganz schick. War eine schicke CPU-Wechsel nach Pentium 4, glaube ich, oder was auch immer die da vorher hatten. Und jetzt gibt es halt den i5 und i7 oder i5, i7. Und die haben halt nicht nur zwei CPUs, so wie der Core 2 Duo, sondern die haben zusätzlich auch noch Hyper Threading. Dann haben sie den Turbo Boost, das heißt jetzt zum Beispiel das Standard 15-Zoll hat, glaube ich, irgendwie so 2,5 Gigahertz. Sieht erstmal weniger aus als bei den Unibodies davor. Aber sie haben halt mit dem Turbo Boost, können sie übertakten, je nachdem, wie heiß die gerade sind. Das heißt, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Prozess hat, der nur eine CPU braucht, und nur eine CPU deswegen heiß wird und die andere abgeschaltet werden kann, dann können sie bis zu, beim i7 bis zu 3,3 Gigahertz übertakten, solange die Kiste nicht zu heiß wird. Also wenn man ordentlich seine Kiste kühlt, kann man auch öfter diese Übertaktung ausnutzen. Das soll wohl auch ziemlich gut laufen.
Ist das automatisch oder wie passiert das?
Also der merkt einfach, dass nur ein Core belegt ist, der andere so vor sich hineidelt und dann gibt er dem Core halt mehr Wumms.
Also kann es sein, dass eine schlecht optimierte Software, die nicht auf mehreren Prozessoren läuft, unter Umständen den 1-Thread dann deutlich schneller ausführt?
Also wo jetzt die alten Unibodies, wo die dann nur 2,8 Gigahertz hatten, also was heißt nur, die hatten 2,8, was ja viel mehr ist als jetzt die Kiste mit 2,5, hört sich das ja erstmal schneller an. Aber wenn es halt nur 1-Thread belegt ist, dann können die halt auf 3,3 Hochtakten. Obwohl sie eigentlich viel weniger haben. Also der E7 kann das, der normale kann nur bis 3 glaube ich, was auch schon ein Stück mehr ist.
Das 17 Zoll hat ein i5, nicht ein Corsodo, sondern ein i5.
Ok, also auch den neuen.
Ja, aber nur den kleinen. Es gibt keinen i7 17 Zoll.
Ok, der Unterschied zwischen dem E5 und dem E7 ist, wobei der E7 ist auch ein 5. Zoll mit extra, kann man hoch ist. Der ist nicht gelistet, aber man kann den Build-to-order hoch.
Ach, der steht einfach nur nicht auf der Webseite oder was?
Genau.
Na Standard-Konfiguration, 2,53, optional 2,66.
Ja, aber die 5. Zoll sind beide, da kannst du direkt auswählen, glaube ich, den E7 und der 7. Zoll, da kannst du erst beim Kaufen noch hier die Option wechseln. Ist ja auch egal, es gibt irgendwie...
Ok, dann gibt es das doch.
Also auf den Tech-Spec-Seite steht das drauf. Es gibt 15 und 17 Zoll in E5 und E7.
Ich hab sie gerade offen. Da steht 2,53 GHz Intel Core E5. Technische Daten.
Bist du aber jetzt nur für einen Rechner?
Ja, für den 17 Zoll. Technical Specifications.
Dann geh doch mal auf kaufen und guck, ob du die 2.
Ok, da geht das vielleicht.
Darf ich dir das zeigen? Da steht's.
Wo, wo, wo?
Du bist auf der deutschen Seite.
Stimmt, also es gibt einen mit 2,53.
Es ist Deutschland hier. In der Tabelle steht kein Wort vom E7. Darum.
Ja, meine lieben Zuschauer, meine beiden Jungs, sie streiten sich schon wieder und zeigen sich gegenseitig ihre Laptop-Frächen.
Der Flash-Programmierer guckt nicht auf die billigen, nicht auf die bunten Bildchen.
Auf irgendwelche Flash-Banner wie ihr.
So, jetzt aber zurück zu den Fakten. Also der Unterschied zwischen Core i5 und i7 ist erstmal natürlich die Gigahertz-Zahl. Der i7 hat natürlich ein bisschen mehr. Zweitens hat er einen größeren Cache, also die i5 haben nur 3 MB Cache. Und der i7 hat 4 MB Cache. Scheiße, jetzt hab ich glaube ich den dritten Grund vergessen. Achja, das dritte war dieser Turbo-Boost. Da können die i5s halt nur bis 3 Gigahertz hoch boosten oder 3,06 oder sowas. Und die i7 können bis 3,3 hoch boosten. Und ich hab halt diesen langen Anand Tek irgendwie Artikel gelesen und der meint, das würde sich schon ganz schön dolle lohnen. Also der holt richtig was raus mit diesem Turbo-Boost und auch durch den besseren Cache und sowas.
Meinst du der i7 gegenüber dem i5 oder beide gegenüber dem Core 2?
Nee, nee, also die beiden. Insgesamt sind sie sowieso reichlich schneller als der Core 2 Duo, also als genau das Gerät davor. Und da meine Kiste ja noch von Dezember 2006. Also die müssten, wenn ich upgrade, das müsste alles nur noch so fliegen.
Naja, also CWO-Power, muss ich ja auch sagen, scheint ja irgendwie nicht so wirklich das Ding zu sein. Da finde ich ja das mit dem SSD-Update schon viel interessanter. Da bieten das Teil ja auch mit einer 512 GB SSD Option an. Das kann ja keiner bezahlen. 1170 Euro.
Das ist scheiße viel Geld.
Naja, dann hast du aber auch echt... Turbo... .SSD.
Ja, aber...
Und sogar noch mehr Platz. Wenn auch nur geringfügig.
Als die 500er diese anbieten?
Ja, die 10 GB da.
Aber bieten sie den einen großen nicht mit einer 640er an?
Du könntest noch mehr reinhauen, wenn du unbedingt...
Ich hab hier gerade einen 640er drin, weil die Alte ist irgendwie kaputt gegangen.
Also ich finde das jetzt auch nicht so attraktiv, zumal ich sie ja auch nicht sagen, was sie da reinbauen. Und wahrscheinlich sind das so Samsung-SSDs.
Ja, Intel sind es nicht.
Und wenn man es halt haben will, dann wird man glaube ich Intel haben. Was ich ja persönlich... Also es gibt zwei Sachen, die mich extrem enttäuschen. Drei genau. Also was sie nach wie vor nicht drin haben, was ja meiner Meinung nach da rein gehört, ist irgendwie GPS. Okay, da kann ich noch am ehesten darauf verzichten, aber ich hätte es halt gut gefunden. Wo ich schon weniger begeistert bin, ist, dass diese 15 Zoll nach wie vor diese blöde SD-Karte hat und kein Express-Card-Slot. Weil es halt eine Killer-Anwendung gibt für diesen Express-Card-Slot. Nämlich, dass du dir da eine schöne SSD reinbaust und sozusagen...
Das hatte ich das letzte Mal erzählt. Da gibt es irgendwie so SSDs, die jetzt nicht mehr über OSB funktionieren, sondern über PCI und bis 150 MB oder 130. Die gibt es nur mit 64 GB. Kosten aber auch ein bisschen was leider.
Naja, aber die steckst du da halt rein. Also wenn du jetzt so einen 17-Zoller holst und bootest einfach davon. Die schließen vor allem auch komplett ab.
Und wenn du sie rausnimmst, haben sie noch einen USB-2-Anschluss, dass du sie auch noch an andere Geräte ranstecken kannst, die keinen Express-Card-Slot haben.
Ich hatte das Ding, den Gäste mal drin stecken, die gibt es mit 64, die gibt es aber auch mit 32 und mit 16.
Ach du hast noch ein altes Modell.
Ich hab ja noch das alte Modell, wo es ging. Von welchen Herstellern waren die gleich? FileMate oder so was? Nee, das war ein totaler Standard. Das war Sandisk, glaube ich, oder so was.
Ich hab eine Weile bei Amazon geguckt und hab nichts Vernünftiges gefunden. Dann hab ich auch was gelesen von, der Sleep-Modus geht nicht mehr und lauter so ein Schnickschnack. Also es war noch nicht so richtig das Wahre. Und das fällt ja sowieso weg, weil bevor ich jetzt hier meine SSD für meine uralte Kistole hole, hole ich mir lieber den neuen. Und SSD, glaube ich, warte ich eh noch ein bisschen. Es ist auf jeden Fall total cool, aber vom Preis her immer noch irgendwie zu teuer.
Mir wäre eine Option lieber, wo ich das optische Laufwerk rausschmeißen kann und dann steppt das in eine schöne SSD rein. Zusätzlich zur Festplatte.
Na, so eine Boot-SSD.
Boot-SSD, so 64 Gig, irgendwie so was mit.
Meine dicken 8 GB Movies müssen nicht auf dem SSD liegen, sondern nur hier so das OS und irgendwie, weiß nicht, hier mein Xcode-Zeugs vielleicht, damit alles irgendwie so arbeitenmäßig schnell geht und sonst OS-Zeugs schnell.
Im Idealfall irgendwas so recht optimiertes im Betriebssystem, was das noch automatisch auf die jeweilige Platte packt, auf der es gerade am meisten Sinn macht. Und das ich davon gar nicht mehr merke.
Jetzt kann ich wieder ZFS einwerfen, aber haben wir ja leider nicht, weil der kann sowas.
Ich habe uns einen interessanten Blog-Eintrag gefunden zu dem Thema, der heißt Mac OS X SSD Tweaks. Ganz interessant, wo er so ein paar Tipps gibt, wenn man eine SSD einsetzt, was man denn noch so alles machen kann, um da mehr rauszuholen, was ich mir auch sonst vorstellen könnte. Unter anderem schaltet er Access-Time ab. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt eine Lesezugriff hast auf eine Datei, dann schreibt ja das OS immer noch in die Einnot rein, wann der erfolgt ist. Das heißt, auch ein Lesen einer Datei erzeugt ein Schreiben des Verzeichnisseintrages dieser Datei. Und ist ja natürlich klar, viele Freize halten irgendwie auf und dann braucht man die schon, diese Access-Time.
Und SSDs leiden ja auch darunter, dass zu viele Schrauben werden.
Genau, wobei die das natürlich irgendwie wegoptimieren, indem sie dann wieder auf einen anderen Blog gehen und so weiter. Und da sie keine Sieg-Time haben, macht es jetzt auch nicht so einen Unterschied. Aber klar, jeder Freit, den du dir sparst, ist gut. Aber das ist natürlich auch bei einer Festplatte nicht anders, weil die muss es ja auch erstmal wegschreiben. Das heißt, er hat hier das auch relativ elegant in dem Blogpost mit drin. Also das ist hier blogs.nullvision.com, Eintrag 275. Mach mal oben links rein. Dann remountet er das Root-Volume einfach mit NoRTime und dann macht das OS einfach nicht. Also es ist kein Hack, sondern es ist etwas, was das OS eben auch kann, wenn du es ihm sagst und er erzeugt hier einfach so einen Launch-DP-List, mit dem das dann eben beim Buten auch gleich durchgeführt wird. Dann schaltet er noch den Hibernate-Modus aus. Das ist ja auch klar, das kann man auch machen. Also wenn dir der Akku fast alleine sleep-Modus ist, schreibt er sich ja weg und belegt ja dann nochmal 3 GB.
Ich glaube, standardmäßig macht er das, er schreibt es immer weg. So in der default-Einstellung, wenn du Smart Sleep hast, dann schaltet das ab.
Richtig, bei Smart Sleep ist es, wenn du Smart Sleep machst, dann ist es flexibel, wie auch immer. Du kannst das halt auch komplett ausschalten. Das ist das, was er hier halt auch macht. Dazu legt er sich dann irgendwie noch eine RAM-Disk an für die temporäre Dateien.
Wie man eine RAM-Disk ansehen kann, das finde ich mal ganz spektakulär.
Ja, da gibt es mit HD-ID kannst du das machen.
Aber es ist dann eine echte RAM-Disk hier auch wirklich total.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht ausprobiert, ich habe das nur deshalb aufgerafft, weil es eben nicht nur für SSDs Sinn macht, sondern wenn du jetzt viel RAM hast, keine Ahnung, was kann man eigentlich in den neuen MacBooks reinschrauben?
Acht.
Gehen da acht Gigabyte rein?
Das hier gehen eigentlich auch schon acht Gigabyte rein.
360 Euro Aufpreis bei Apfel.
360 Euro Aufpreis.
Das geht ja mittlerweile regelrecht.
Waren vorher 520 oder so.
Ja gut, aber du kannst ja auch sagen, ok, alles klar, ich stecke mir da acht Gigabyte rein und dann sind meine temporären Dateien, für temporäre Dateien mache ich einfach eine RAM-Disk auf. Und opfer mal zwei Gigabyte dafür, reicht ja. Schwuppdiwupp, schon wieder hast du weniger Plattenabhängigkeit. Weil ich merke einfach, das ist eine schnelle CPU, das ist geil, wenn du viel encoden musst, wenn du Audio encodest, wenn du vor allem Video encodest, rumrechnest oder sonst welche mathematischen Rechnungen.
Ansonsten hält einem halt das File-IO auf.
Aber ansonsten ist es einfach die Platte. Die Platte macht einfach das Ding langsam und du kannst einfach nicht genug RAM und nicht genug SSD in deine Büchsen reinstecken, um alles zu beschleunigen. Aber ein Tweek fehlt hier in der Liste.
Ein Tweek fehlt hier in der Liste, würde ich sagen. Und zwar die automatische Defragmentierung abschalten. Mac OS defragmentiert ja automatisch kleinere Dateien. Und das ist ja eigentlich total überflüssig. Weil das ist ja nicht diese am Stück lese Zeit, also diese...
Das stimmt. Das ist auch ein interessanter Hinweis. Also ich denke, da geht noch so einiges. Ich weiß ja nicht, was Apple selber noch an Optimierungen drin hat, wenn sie wissen, dass da eine SSD ist. Kann ich dir sagen, dass sie schon von allein abschalten? Dass sie schon irgendwas optimieren werden, das weiß ich nicht.
Es gab immer einen Punkt, da musste Apple mal langsam mitkommen. Und zwar, soweit ich weiß, machen sie das bis heute nicht. Haben wir darüber mal gesprochen, über diesen Truncate-Befehl? Also wenn die Datei kleiner wird, dann sagt das Betriebssystem, sagen alte Betriebssysteme, der Platte nicht bescheidt, du, ich hab deine Datei kleiner gemacht als Speicher, der nicht mehr benutzt wird.
Trim meinste?
Genau. Trim heißt genau, nicht Truncate, sondern Trim. Und die SSD schiebt das Zeug ja hin und her, und die muss ja auch bei jedem Schreibvorgang der gesamte Block geschrieben werden. Das heißt, Schreibvorgang dauert länger, wenn die Platte voller ist. Das heißt, es macht Sinn, wenn man Dateien wegschmeißt, dass man auch explizit sagt, du, die ist jetzt weg, SSD, brauchst dich nicht mehr darum zu kümmern. Soweit ich weiß, und da gibt es einen SATA-Befehl für, und Windows 7 hat den drin, nutzen die. Mac OS ist nach meinem Wissen aber nach wie vor nicht. Also mit 10.6 war es auf jeden Fall noch nicht dabei.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei Macbook Pro. Haben wir das mit den Grafikkarten schon erwähnt? Übrigens, in der Hörer-Wave steht zu dem Hi-Res-Screen auch noch, der habe eine Anti-Reflektionsbeschichtung. Achso, ne, optional.
Aber den kleinen halt nicht mehr. Sondern nur noch den großen teuren. Der kostet auch 135 Euro anstatt 90. Obwohl es waren eventuell die Dollar preisweise jetzt nicht.
Und halt Dual-Core i5, i7.
Und die Grafik ist aber jetzt hier, früher war es ja bei den Unibuddies hier dem Vorgänger, war es ja ein NVIDIA-Chipsatz und ein NVIDIA Extra GPU. Jetzt ist es ja durch den neuen Prozessor, dafür darf NVIDIA keinen Chipsatz bauen, weil sie die Lizenz nicht mehr haben. Das heißt, NVIDIA ist raus aus dem Boot. Deswegen ist es jetzt halt ein Core i5 plus irgendwie Intel Chipsatz.
Also eingebaute Grafik.
Eingebaute Grafik von Intel jetzt.
Aber noch mal eine NVIDIA.
Aber zusätzlich noch mal diese NVIDIA, wie heißt die, M330 oder was? Irgendwas mit 330 war da. Und da schaltet dann Apple im Betrieb, wenn man es sich auswählt, hin und her zwischen der externen Grafik oder der Intel Chipsatz Grafik, ohne dass man halt was merkt. Wenn man ein externes Bildschirm dran hat, dann wird immer die externe Grafik, also der NVIDIA Chip benutzt. Und wenn so Sachen laufen wie Aperture, weiß nicht, Final Cut oder irgendwelche OpenGL Frameworks benutzt werden, dann wird automatisch immer die dicke Grafik, der dicke Grafik Chip benutzt. Und auf Windows gibt es das auch mit diesem automatischen Umschalten von NVIDIA, nennt sich irgendwie Optimus. Aber dort ist es halt wahrscheinlich noch der NVIDIA Chipsatz und die NVIDIA Grafikkarte. Also die schalten zwischen sich selbst um und dann macht das halt der Treiber und nicht Windows. Aber Apple hat da halt was eigenes und die schalten ja sogar zwischen zwei verschiedenen Herstellern um. Und zwei, die sich anscheinend nicht mehr leiden können, weil NVIDIA kriegt keine Lizenz, um für die neuen Core i7 und i5 irgendwie einen Chipsatz bauen zu dürfen. Die streiten sich da gerade so ein bisschen rum.
Ja, sieht nach einer echt kreativen Lösung aus. Zumal das ja dann auch wirklich auch dazu beitragen kann, dass das Ding oder wahrscheinlich dazu beigetragen hat, dass das Ding so eine gute Urlauffleistung erzielt. Weil wer sollte besser entscheiden können, ob man das jetzt gerade braucht, je externer Grafiksteinchen oder nicht, als das OS.
Da bin ich ja mal sehr gespannt, was man davon mitbekommt. Also ich meine, bei mir ist es so, ich muss mich komplett ausloggen und wieder einloggen, um die Grafikkarte zu wechseln. Und dass das jetzt wirklich so seamless funktionieren soll, das wäre natürlich echt geil, aber es ist...
Ja, das Ausloggen und Einloggen, das fand ich schon immer irgendwie gaga. Das war auch für mich ein bisschen zu warten.
Ich dachte mal, das kommt noch dafür.
Habt ihr das jetzt mit der WLAN-Antenne mitbekommen?
Dass die jetzt am optischen Laufwerk irgendwie dran hängt?
Jaja, die haben sozusagen dieses Loch, also um das Loch da, wo man die CD reinschiebt, da haben sie halt die Antenne drum herum gemacht.
Weil das so die einzige offene Stelle noch ist?
Naja, eben, da ist sozusagen eh...
Sollen sie auch hier in deine App packen?
Sollen sie das doch unter den Tastatoren machen?
Ja, sie hatten es ja vorher im Display, aber das Problem ist, dass es natürlich auch die Verkabelungskomplexität zum Display hin vergrößert hat. Und das haben sie jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt haben sie nur ein kleines Steckerchen, um den Bildschirm anzuschließen. Machen da halt wahrscheinlich einfach Display-Port und fertig. Und der ganze Antennenschmuck liegt jetzt wieder unten.
Wenn sie meinen, ist cool.
Mein Wunsch wäre lieber optischer Port, optisches Zeug raus und dafür mal lieber ein bisschen mehr Plastik.
Ich habe schon alles aufgezählt, was mir eigentlich nicht gefällt.
3G, kein GPS und...
Kein 3G.
Und kein Express Card-Slot.
Und kein Express Card-Slot, beziehungsweise so eine flexible Dual-SSD-Festplatten-Kombination.
Und eSata haben sie auch nicht.
Ja, aber eSata ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal. Also, brauch ich nicht, bis jetzt nicht.
Ich brauch kein UR NTS.
Tja, aber da musst du erstmal ordentlich getessert bekommen. Das ist halt immer wieder ein totales Problem.
Ich kann tessern. Die Telekom-Jungs, die scheiße. Die können sich ihren Tessering-Vertrag kaufen. Das ist nicht mein Problem.
Das hatten wir doch letztes Mal. Das letzte Mal hab ich doch gesagt, dass ich nicht mehr tessern kann. Hast du das gelöst bekommen? Ja, ich hab's gelöst bekommen. Ich kann's jetzt auch erklären. Nein, ich hatte ja mein iPhone von 3, was auch immer, 3.0 irgendwas, was war da aktuell?
Stimmt, das 3.1 übersprungen.
Die letzte 3.0er-Version. Dann erst als 3.1.3 rauskam, aktualisiert, weil ich gehört habe, dass dann das Tessering auf Analog Phones wieder geht.
Ja, kann ich bestätigen, ist so.
Genau, und dann hab ich das irgendwie auch gemacht und alles war gut. Ich hab mich gefreut, die Sonne schien, die Vögleinspitze hatten, tralala. Und dann hab ich aber irgendwann mal, dann hatte ich aber wieder so dieses mit Call-Forboarding, dieses Teil, wenn man irgendwie anruft, dass man diese Rufweiterleitung anzeigt. Und auch wenn man das nicht umbringt, war es halt irgendwie so, hm, und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, dann spiel ich doch noch mal so ein IPCC-File, also so ein Carrier-Profile ein, wo er eben drin steht, bitte für diesen Carrier O2 das nicht machen. Dann hab ich das gemacht. Und das Ergebnis war, dass mein Tethering nicht mehr funktionierte. Und er auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht auf dieses Profil ansprach. Also er hat dieses Profil nicht genommen, aber ab dem Moment, wo ich ihm das über iTunes einverleibt hatte, war dann irgendwie auch Schicht im Schacht. Und ich hatte meinen ganzen, alles das, was ich sozusagen nicht loswerden wollte durch 3.1.
Das ist doch das, was ich auch hatte, dass ich auf 3.1. abgedatet hab und bei mir ging das Tesla nicht. Und die einzige Lösung war ein kompletteres Set mit Backup wieder einspielen, dann ging's.
Genau, weil du dann nämlich wieder den alten Scheiß gemacht hast und er nämlich dieses Profil genommen hat, was er automatisch geupgraded hat. Der Punkt ist, es ging nämlich bei mir nur deshalb und bei dir, weil du ein Upgrade gemacht hast und er bei diesem Upgrade auch das gespeicherte IPCC-File aktualisiert hat. Was hat sich nämlich jetzt geändert? Es hat sich das Format von diesem IPCC-File geändert. Und all diese ganzen Seiten, die dir irgendwelche IPCC-Generator und so weiter anbieten, haben das meines Wissens bisher noch nicht aktualisiert. Es gibt nämlich ein neues Feld in dieser P-List und das heißt mandatory verify. Und mandatory verify ist eine Liste von GSM Country Code und Mobile Provider Number. So eine 5-stellige Nummer.
Also 27384O2 oder irgendwie sowas?
23205 und sowas, genau. Und jetzt wirst du auch teilweise mehrere davon? 2, 6, 2, irgendwas ist Deutschland. Und da stehen alle Provider drin, mit denen Apple einen Vertrag hat. Das heißt, bei mandatory verify heißt es sozusagen, wenn du in einem von diesen Netzen bist, dann musst du die Signatur überprüfen. Und wenn das Ding dann nicht signiert ist, dann gilt das halt nicht. Und diese Liste ist aber selber auch nochmal signiert. Das heißt, in dieser P-List steht oben nochmal ein Signature drin. Das heißt, du kannst da nicht auch einfach einen rausnehmen, weil dann gilt das eben auch nicht mehr, und dann wird das ganze Profil signiert. Was sie sozusagen weggelassen haben, ist, dass alles signiert sein muss. Und sie haben dafür reingeschrieben, nur wenn du in einem Vertragspartner-Netz bist, dann musst du halt noch signiert sein. Und ansonsten kannst du machen, was du willst. Wir helfen dir jetzt nicht besonders, aber es geht zumindest. Das ist ja eigentlich so das Minimum, was ich erwartet habe. Und genau dieses Minimum haben sie halt auch gemacht. So, was musste ich also jetzt tun? Ich musste mir also mein IPCC-File nehmen und diese mandatory verify-Geschichte dort einbauen. Da die ja signiert ist, muss man die irgendwo herholen. Das kriegt man nur aus so einem Unknown. Also es gibt einen Unknown Punkt Bundle. Das ist quasi ein IPCC-File für das Default-Teil, was eben gilt, wenn ihr eben den Provider nicht kennt. Weil kann ja mal passieren, dass ein neuer daherkommt. Und der liegt halt irgendwo auf dem iPhone und durch jailbroken Phones sind die halt irgendwie ins Internet gekommen. Und so kriegt man das dann halt. Dann fügt man sich das ein und alles ist gut. So, dann war ich wieder ganz happy. Jetzt habe ich sozusagen so ein Profil, was eben so funktioniert, wie ich möchte. Ich habe ein O2-Logo und so weiter. Nicht, dass es jetzt so wichtig wäre, aber naja, daran sieht man zumindest, dass das Profil auch aktiv ist. Und ich habe Tethering. Und dann bin ich jetzt irgendwie letzte Woche in Wien gewesen und da habe ich dann immer so meine, beim österreichischen Aldi, dem Hopa.
Ich weiß, was jetzt kommt. Darf ich raten? Da warst du natürlich bei einem Carrier, der in dieser Liste drin steht und dann hast du kein Tethering mehr.
Genau, also genau genommen war ich das nämlich nicht. Sondern ich war bei Yes, das ist halt so ein Billig-Provider, der nutzt das Orange-Netz. Was auch kein Problem wäre, weil der hat nämlich eigentlich eine eigene Provider-Kennung, weil er ist ja auch ein eigener Provider und der steht auch nicht in dieser Liste drin. Nur hatte ich noch eine Karte von vor zwei Jahren, wo aus irgendwelchen Gründen er sehr wohl noch die Netznummer von Orange benutze. Das heißt, ich habe eine SIM-Karte von Yes, wo tatsächlich aber eine Orange-Karte draufsteht. Das ging bisher immer, aber so konnte ich mir halt kein IPCC-File machen und hatte dementsprechend jetzt die paar Tage in Wien dann doch kein Tethering. Also es ist ein bisschen Schmerz im Arsch. Mir wurde gesagt, wenn ich jetzt wieder zum Hofer gelaufen wäre, mir eine neue Karte gekauft hätte, dann hätte ich halt eine SIM-Karte mit einer aktualisierten Netznummer und dann wäre das irgendwie auch alles okay.
Okay, mit anderen Worten, man sollte besser da noch einen Stick dabei haben.
Genau, beziehungsweise man, ja Stick, ja doch.
Bist du dieses Call-Forwarding oder dieses Anruf weiterleiten jetzt eigentlich losgeworden?
Also du hast jetzt da ein selbstgemachtes O2-Profile drin.
Genau.
O2-Call-Forwarding off, Tethering an und was noch geändert?
Logo.
Na ich hab da jetzt nichts weiter, also ich hab nichts geändert, als ich da bisher auch schon mal... Also das ist im Prinzip so ein Profile, ich weiß gar nicht, wer das gemacht hat, ich hab das nicht gemacht, ich hab das irgendwo...
Willst du mir das mal geben und vielleicht noch mit in die Seite packen?
Ja, ich hab das auch mal getweetet.
O2 und das Call-Forwarding nervt schon so ein bisschen.
Ja, total.
So, das hab ich doch jetzt ganz gut erklärt, oder? Ich bin ganz stolz.
Waren wir jetzt mit dem MacBook Pro eigentlich schon durch?
Ja, waren wir schon durch.
Die Grafik haben wir erklärt mit dem Umschalten. Was haben sie noch bei dem Touch? Haben sie da auch noch irgendwas geändert? Da geht jetzt irgendwas mehr. Ach so, dass man dieses Scrolling, was so nachläuft, okay, das ist ja ein Software-Feature eigentlich, hat ja mit den MacBook Pros nichts zu tun. Die verkaufen es immer gerne so, aber es ist eigentlich ein Software-Feature.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie da wirklich an dem Touchpad irgendwas geändert haben.
Nee, was soll das ändern? Das lässt ja los und das scrollt weiter. Also die Hardware sorgt nicht dafür, dass es da weiter rollt.
Also sie können halt jetzt flicken und sie nennen das inertial track height scrolling.
Apropos, was die Magic Mouse ja auch schon hat.
Gerüchteküche. Ganz frisch reingekommen. Dass Apple mit AMD in Gespräch wäre. Ich hasse ja eigentlich immer diese Gerüchteküche, aber das fand ich jetzt mal echt interessant. Wieso was? Wieso ich das interessant fand? ich so den Eindruck habe, dass Apple diese Nummer, was du da gerade erzählt hast, mit Nvidia-Aussperren nicht geil fand. Das hat sie irgendwie echt vor Probleme gestellt.
Aber das Problem haben sie bei AMD auch, weil die auf Nvidia ja auch keinen Bock haben, weil die haben ja ATI gekauft. Da ist Nvidia eh so ein bisschen raus.
Das ist die Frage, mit welcher Verhandlungsposition die da sind. Also ich denke, wenn Herr Drops bei AMD da auf dem Campus einläuft, dann wird der rote Teppich aber sehr weit ausgerollt. Weil was geileres, als das Apple-Rechner mit AMD-Chips baut, könnten wir sich glaube ich kaum vorstellen. Aber das Gerücht gibt es schon seit 2006, dass die das Gerücht verbaut haben.
Doch, da gab es auch schon AMD-Gerüchte. Und bald werden sie auch AMD nehmen und so. Also da gebe ich erstmal nichts drauf.
Nö, ich gebe da jetzt auch erstmal auf dieses Gerücht, gebe ich auch gar nichts. Ich finde bloß den Gedanken ganz interessant. Weil AMD schon seit längerer Zeit, und das basiert vor allem auf dieser Geschichte, dass sie halt mit ATI zusammengegangen sind. Intel in dem Sinne, die Grafikkartensparte ist immer noch ein Scheiß.
Von Intel? Also die sind die Marktführer sozusagen, was die meistverkauften Karten betrifft.
Nicht die Highend-Karten, aber diese ganzen Chipsats-Dinger. Sie sind nicht der Performance-Führer. Und Apple will halt Performance. Und AMD und ATI, ich meine, Apple setzt auch ATI-Karten immer wieder ein. Es gibt immer wieder die Optionen, Deine iMac und so weiter.
Die beiden werden hin und her geswitcht, je nachdem, wer den besseren Preis gebracht hat.
Und meistens sind die ATI-Karten dann aber auch immer so das rechts unten Modell. Also wenn du wirklich die schnellste iMac-Variante haben willst, ich hab's jetzt im Einzelnen nicht mehr so, wie das Leiner wir letztes Jahr hatten, es wechselt, aber ATI ist dabei. Das ist das, was ich sagen wollte. Nvidia und ATI sind immer auf gleicher Augenhöhe. Nur ATI und AMD sind natürlich auch dabei, in zunehmendem Maße Prozessoren zu bauen, die eben GPU und CPU in sich vereinigen. Das ist das, was jetzt kommt. Das ist natürlich das, was Apple auch in ihrem iPad drin hat und auch in ihrem iPhone drin hat, dass sie ein System-on-a-Chip haben.
Ja, gibt's von Intel aber auch. Noch nicht in groß, der Atom hat halt sowas jetzt.
Ja, aber so wie Intel sich das vorstellt.
Klar, AMD hat es so wie AMD sich vorstellt.
Ja, es sei denn, Steve Jobs kommt da hingelaufen und sagt, irgendwie baut uns das doch mal so, wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Das geht doch bei Intel auch. Haben sie doch auch schon gemacht. Die haben doch auch schon irgendeine Intel-Spezialfläche.
Fürs MacBook Air.
Diesen kleineren Chip.
Ja, aber Intel hat keine Grafikkarten-Performance. Verstehst du? Das ist das, was ich meine.
Ja, aber wenn die ATI den Chip mit reinbauen, nehmen die doch auch nur so eine billige Version.
Warum?
Na, weil das Ding sonst wegglüht.
Na, das halte ich mit wie das Quatsch. Ich meine, du kannst das ja auch ordentlich bauen.
Naja, aber zwei so einen totalen Hitze-Produzierer auf einen Chip zu machen?
Das muss nicht unbedingt so sein. Ich meine, guck dir das iPad an. Das Ding erzeugt irgendwie keinerlei Nennstättewärmung.
Da ist ja auch kein fetter Grafik-Chip drin.
Na, das macht auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz ordentlich Wumms. Und die Frage ist ja...
Für das kleine Ding.
Ja, für das kleine Ding. Aber die Frage ist... Ja, jetzt nehmen wir mal ein Gerät wie das MacBook Air. So, MacBook Air braucht sicherlich nicht jetzt unbedingt die High-End rechts unten 3D-Performance, aber trotzdem ist natürlich Grafik-Performance für dieses Teil auch sehr gut. Angenommen, AMD wäre in der Lage, einen Stein zu bauen, der sowohl sparsam ist im Strom, da waren sie ja nicht so gut, aber sie müssen sich ja auch bemühen, was weiß ich, was bei denen so kocht. Und mit dem Vorteil, dass sie eben einen hochintegrativen Chip bauen können, der eben auch einfach keinen Platz wegnimmt, aber trotzdem performancemäßig einen Intel grafikmäßig auch weghaut, dann ist das für Apple doppelt interessant. Nicht nur wegen der schnellen Grafik, sondern eben auch im Hinblick auf OpenCL, etc., PP und der ganzen Acceleration ihres GUIs grundsätzlich. Deswegen finde ich dieses Gerücht gerade interessant, weil ich sehe im Prozessorenmarkt einfach diesen Trend, CPU und GPU gehen zusammen. Ich sehe niemanden, der da besser aufgebaut ist, best of both worlds zu spielen wie AMD, besser auf jeden Fall als Intel. Und insofern finde ich dieses Gerücht überlegens.
Aber CPU-mäßig sind die doch gerade wieder ein bisschen hinterher, oder? Die waren ja eine ganze Weile voll vorne, weil doch Intel halt, die hatten immer noch diese, wie war das, die Southbridge, die sich um den Memory-Controller, der war extern, und AMD hat den einfach mal mit auf die CPU verfrachtet, deswegen konnten die da schneller auf den Speicher zugreifen, und zwar so richtig viel schneller. Da war Intel hinterher mit dem Core 2 Duo, jetzt haben sie aber mit dem Core i7, die machen genau auch das, die haben jetzt auch den schnellen Speicher, und jetzt haben die AMD gerade wiederholt. Aber das ist üblich, immer eine Firma macht was, sind schneller als die anderen, die machen es dann auch, aber ein Stück besser, überholen die wieder. Das Gleiche hast du mit ATI und Nvidia auch, aber ich glaube, AMD ist gerade hinterher.
Na gut, nochmal was anderes bei dieser ganzen AMD-Geschichte, als Apple auf Intel gewechselt ist, also als auf Intel Architektur gewechselt ist, und damit auch zu Intel gewechselt ist, haben sie natürlich ein großes Interesse gehabt, vor allem erst mal mit einer Bude zu arbeiten, um überhaupt erst mal ihre Plattform gesichert zu bekommen. Da sind wir aber jetzt. Apple hat den Intel-Schritt komplett gemacht, also den Intel-Architektur-Schritt komplett gemacht, und jetzt gibt es nichts mehr, was sie zwingen würde, bei Intel zu bleiben, sondern in dem Moment, wo sie mit AMD auch nur reden...
Ich glaube, die haben vorhin auch mit denen geredet...
.erhöhen sie ihren Leverage. Na ja, sie werden sicherlich... Aber ich glaube nicht, dass AMD damals etwas für sie gehabt hätte, weil diese Core-Duo, also die Core-Serie, Core-Solo, Core-Duo...
Das war ein super Mobilprozessor.
Das war einfach ein super Mobilprozessor, und das war für Apple wichtig.
Aber nicht im Laptop-Bereich.
Das kann sein, ja.
AMD hat nur im Server-Bereich gepunktet, mit ihren 64-Bit-Maschinen im Server-Bereich. Das ist eigentlich auch ihre Kernkompetenz. Im Laptop-Bereich ist Intel vorne.
Haben sie denn da jetzt was im Laptop-Bereich?
So richtig toll.
Weiß man's. Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen. Wenn sie halt einen Stein bauen, der irgendwie nicht nur sparsam ist, sondern der auch noch exorbitante Grafik-Performance bringt.
Aber die stellen die ja schon eine Weile vorher vor, die Chips, dann lüften wir jetzt was davon.
Ja, also wir können sagen...
Vielleicht tun sie das halt jetzt nicht mehr.
Die sind ja nicht so wie Apple.
Aber das ist jetzt wirklich...
Vielleicht werden die jetzt so wie Apple.
Es gibt mal wieder Spekulation.
Das Reality-Distortion-Field zieht einen.
Es gibt mal wieder Spekulation darüber, dass Apple vielleicht mit AMD zusammen... Das bleibt doch nicht das letzte Mal. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wenn es dann eintritt. Was mir jetzt vielleicht noch mal ein kleines Detail, was ein bisschen, ohne dass ich jetzt so weit ausfallen will, zu unserer Flash-Disco, die von vorhin passt, aber was ich ganz lustig finde, ich bin neulich gestolpert über ein Programm, das heißt iPhone Benutzerhandbuch. Das ist kein Programm, sondern es ist eine Webseite von Apple. Die ist von den Standardbookmarks drin. Ich bin darüber, die ist mir aufgefallen, als ich den Simulator mal wieder resettet habe. Und da hat man hier so eine Anleitung von dem iPad drin. Und die sieht halt aus, wenn man sie auf dem Desktop abspeichert wie ein echtes App. Nun ist mir da sofort was aufgefallen, wenn man nämlich Web-Apps entwickelt für das iPhone, dass hier etwas getan wird, was eigentlich gar nicht möglich ist auf dem iPhone. Nämlich, ich scrolle und oben diese Namensleiste, also ich habe hier so ein Scroll-View und der hat oben so eine Taskbar, diese Menüleiste oben, diese Navigation Bar drinne und die bleibt stehen. Das geht auf dem iPhone normalerweise gar nicht.
Das ist jetzt eine Web-App?
Und die bleibt hier einfach oben, ich kann unten scrollen und oben die Navigationsbeileiste, der Titel bleibt stehen.
Wieso geht das nicht?
Weil es dafür in Safari keine Möglichkeit gibt. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, Elemente fest auf dem Bildschirm zu positionieren.
CSS, das geht seit CSS 1. Position, Doppelpunkt, Fixed.
Ja, und das geht auf dem iPhone nicht.
Was?
Das geht einfach nicht.
Wieso haben sie da den S-Test bestehen, wenn sie sowas nicht können?
Weil das wahrscheinlich nicht für einen S-Test relevant ist und ich weiß nicht, ob das iPhone den S-Test bestehen.
Position, Fixed?
Auf jeden Fall geht 100%ig, Tim, vertraue mir, es gibt keinen Position.
Hast du den HTML-Code angeschaut?
Ich hab mir den HTML-Code von dem Zeug angeschaut und offensichtlich ist Apple zu dem gleichen Schluss gekommen, weil zumindest wären sie sonst verdammt doof. Sie haben komplett den Teil neu implementiert. Welchen? Das Dragging, das sich dann der Layer bewegt.
Warte mal, wer ist jetzt sie?
Apple.
Womit haben sie das neu implementiert?
In JavaScript.
Mit welcher Version jetzt?
Wie mit welcher Version?
Ich hab den verantworten.
Ich auch.
Wie mit welcher Version?
Ich weiß nicht, wovon du redest. Redest du jetzt von diesem Benutzerhandbuch oder redest du von dem iPhone OS?
Ich rede von diesem Benutzerhandbuch.
Was haben sie da neu implementiert?
Die Möglichkeit, dass man ein View scrollen kann. Hier dieser Scroll-Balken, den du rechts siehst.
Das muss die Seite selber implementieren?
Den Scroll-Balken, den du rechts siehst, der wird durch JavaScript gemalt. Der wird komplett in JavaScript gemalt. Apple hat eine JavaScript-Bibliothek geschrieben, so viel zum Thema Emulation und native Views nehmen, mit dem sie tatsächlich einen Roll-Balken...
Die selbe Optik machen wie bei apps.
Die selbe Optik machen.
Du bist jetzt im Safari, oder?
Welches Framework ist das? Da gibt es auch so drei verschiedene, die sie da irgendwie sind im Einsatz.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie das heißt. Es gibt jetzt...
Und wie komme ich zur Leiste oben zurück? Woher weiß ich denn, dass das ein Safari ist? Wie komme ich denn zu irgendwas?
Ich habe es jetzt einfach auf dem Desktop abgespeichert, aber du kannst es hier... Warte mal, ich habe es hier noch in Safari offen. Da siehst du, das ist jetzt genau das Gleiche.
Aber da müsste doch oben auch die Adressleiste kommen.
Na, ja, musst du halt oben drauf tippen. Die haben sie halt nur so weit runtergescrollt, dass sie wegfährt.
Die Adressleiste, die blende sich ganz schön aus, wenn du einen Bookmark machst.
Die kannst du einfach mit dem, da gibt es mit einem JavaScript-Befehl.
Das ist automatisch, wenn du eine Webseite auf dein Homescreen draufmachst.
Nee, das ist nicht automatisch. Du musst ein, nein. Nein, Tim! Ich kenne mich damit aus. Das ist ein HTML-Metatec, den du eingeben musst noch. Also du musst ein paar HTML-Tags angeben.
Achso, du musst das dann in deiner Seite auch noch sagen, dass du sie nicht willst. Und wenn du sie dir dann gerne auch wegmachst.
Weil viele Seiten sind ja darauf angewiesen, dass du Vorwärts- und Backbuttons hast und so was. Das kannst du ja nicht einfach so alles weglassen.
Verstehe.
Das kann man angeben. Da kann man auch angeben, ob man gerne eine transparente Menüleiste oben haben möchte oder eine weiße oder eine schwarze.
Das haben sie alles damals für die Web-Apps schon vorbereitet, oder?
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Jaja, genau, das ist alles das Web-Apps-Zeug. Aber eben, dass man einzelne Views scrollen kann, das geht nicht. Und das haben sie jetzt mehrfach sogar implementiert. Und zwar einmal mit dieser Bibliothek, deren Name ich nicht weiß, die es auf dem iPhone gibt. Auf dem iPad gibt es genauso eine Anleitung, die läuft dann mit der verräterischer Namen AdLib, was natürlich im Rahmen von diesem iAds relativ spannend ist. Apple implementiert eigene Scrollbars, neue weiß es nicht haben. Naja.
Naja, sonst müsste das ja Standard im Safari sein und da fest eingebaut sein.
Nein, sie könnten ja einfach Position Fixed unterstützen. Könnten ja Safari mal sagen.
Achso, ich dachte mal, das ist wegen des Scrollbars jetzt.
Jaja, dann hätte es den Scrollbar.
Den hast du doch im Safari auch so, wenn du irgendwas scrollst.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht dafür sorgen, dass einzelne Bereiche der Seite stehen bleiben.
Und der Rest scrollt?
Und der Rest scrollt. Das geht in Standard, CSS und HTML, wie Tim schon richtig sagt, mit Position Fixed, aber auf dem iPhone hat das leider nie hingehauen.
Und es gibt auch... Die Experten staunen, leiden, wundern sich.
Und es gibt auch eine Möglichkeit, man kann auch einfach sagen, in Safari zum Beispiel, oder in allen Browsern kann man sagen, auch so definierende Box macht die ein bisschen kleiner, und dann hat sie einen Rollbalken. Das geht auf dem iPhone, aber da muss man dämlicherweise mit zwei Fingern scrollen. Also so eine schöne Lösung haben die dafür leider auch nicht.
So, was haben wir noch?
Ich guck grad mal. Na ja, also Mac OS X 10.6.3 hat ja nach einem problemlosen Update aus. Ich hab dann eigentlich den Fehler gemacht.
Für mich war es eins.
Ja, weil du die Mac Ports nicht benutzt. Aber die Mac Ports und 10.6.3, da ging irgendwie ganz schwer was durcheinander. Wie war es, das alles nochmal neu installieren? Das war irgendwie nicht so toll. Sind wir denn jetzt schon bei allen anderen? Ich glaube ja, ne? Müssen wir noch was zu Palm sagen? Wer kauft Palm? Palm will sich kaufen lassen.
Motorola.
Meinst du, dass sie es tun, oder dass sie es tun sollten?
Tun müssen.
Müssen?
Klar, sonst gehen sie unter. Wieso? Weil, doch, was hab ich gelesen? Weil, das Droid Verison gehört, und die haben es ja von Motorola bauen lassen, lassen sie es jetzt aber von HTC bauen.
Also, Droid ist eine Marke von Verreisen. Das heißt, nur sie dürfen ein Telefon so nennen.
Und haben es von Motorola bauen lassen.
Sie haben ein Telefon von Motorola genommen, und haben es Droid genannt. Die Tatsache, dass sie es genannt haben, die gehört zu Verreisen.
Das selbe Telefon heißt ja hier.
Uns alle haben immer von Motorola-Droid gesprochen.
Ja, aber hier heißt es Milestone.
Gibt es hier ja auch das Telefon, und da heißt es einfach Motorola-Milestone.
Na gut, das ist jetzt nicht der Grund, warum sie Palm kaufen, nur weil Verreisen ihr Telefon Droid nennt. Ich meine, das mag jetzt eine gute Markteinführung gewesen haben. Jetzt lassen sie sich halt etwas, was Droid heißt, weil sie halt als Provider auftreten. Das ist ja auch in den USA immer noch ein starkes Ding, dass man so Warn im Telefon kommt von Provider.
Das ist wie mit dem Google Nexus One. Das gibt es ja auch noch mal unter dem Namen HTC. HTC Desire?
Das ist aber der einzige Beispiel, wo es nicht mit einem Provider zusammenhängt. Das Google Nexus One ist das einzige Telefon, das nicht als von einem Provider wahrgenommen wird.
Ja, aber es ist auch ein gebrandtes Telefon. Also nicht vom Hersteller.
Ja, aber nicht von einem Provider gebrandet.
Das meinte ich damit.
So, jetzt kann man sich streiten, ob das iPhone auch ein nicht von einem Provider gebrandet ist. Wahrscheinlich gilt das so. Aber beim Droid ist es halt so. Na gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja nicht das Hauptproblem von Motorola.
Weil vorher das Motorola mit dem Droid immer verbunden war. Und es eigentlich auch ganz cool rüber kam. Und jetzt plötzlich haben sie es nicht mehr. Das heißt, sie brauchen jetzt irgendwas Neues, was cool ist.
Ja, aber dann brauchen sie einen Markennamen und nicht ein anderes OS. Weil letzten Endes ist ja für sie die Frage, ob sie auch... Also du meinst, sie kaufen Palm und bringen dann ein Android-Telefon raus, was sie Palm nennen? Das wäre natürlich...
Das wäre vielleicht...
Ja, die schmeißen einfach WebOS weg. Weil sie nicht dran glauben. Kann ja sein, dass sie nicht dran glauben. Weil ich glaube, derzeit glauben alle irgendwie an Android.
Ja, das glauben alle an Android.
Das ist wirklich meine Wahrnehmung. Android und iPhone sind einfach jetzt so die hirnbeherrschenden Namen für Telefonbetriebssysteme. Und das eine ist halt die Apple-Wolke, das andere ist die Google-Wolke. Und den anderen Wolken geht es halt irgendwie schlecht. Hab ich hier übrigens schon mal so vorausgesehen. Und Palm, naja, geht es halt schlecht.
Und zwar so richtig schlecht.
Und sie mögen da ganz nett was hingemacht haben mit dem WebOS, aber entweder haben sie es nicht gut verkauft oder es war einfach nicht gut genug.
Wie auch immer.
Jetzt stehen sie scheiße da.
Sie haben einen Ausblick von ihrem Aktienkurs von 0 Dollar. Und das war so der Zeitpunkt, wo ihnen alle den Stinkefinger gezeigt haben. Und jetzt sagen sie, hallo bitte, kauft uns. Und naja, Gerüchteküche geht hin und her.
Wie viel haben sie verkauft von ihren Palms?
Nicht viel. Ich weiß die Zahl nicht mehr, aber es war below expectations und unter ihren eigenen Ankündigungen.
HTC wäre ein schöner Kandidat, wie ich finde, um Palms zu kaufen.
Na ja gut, warum sollten sie das tun?
Die haben aber auch die Hardware selber gebaut, oder?
Palms hat die Hardware selber gekauft, ja.
Und auch die Hardware gemacht. Also eigentlich von der Apple-Weg.
Also sie haben sie designen, ja. Aber alle sagen, das soll doch bauen lassen.
Die einhellige Meinung über den Palm Pre ist, die Hardware ist scheiße, aber das OS ist geil. Und HTC baut geile Hardware. Ist aber bei den OSen zumindest abhängig von anderen. Also ist auf der einen Seite von Microsoft abhängig, für das Windows und das auf der anderen Seite von Google.
Na, das haben sie selber schon aufgehört, oder?
Nee, nee, die machen, also die haben sich schon, ich glaube doch, die entwickeln. Also die haben doch Windows-Mobile-Phones.
Naja, ich dachte, die haben jetzt aufgehört für Windows.
Also dieses HTC HD2 oder irgendwie, wie das heißt.
Sie haben aufgehört, Windows-Mobile.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt, dass sie das aufgehört haben. Ach so, ich dachte, die bauen und...
Das sind die Letzten, die noch...
Und die haben schon gesagt, dass es Windows-Phones sind. Das sind die Letzten, die machen wollen.
In nennenswerter Größe welche bauen. Aber sie haben damit noch nicht aufgehört.
Wer baut noch welche? Oder waren es die Letzten, die noch welche bauen und sonst niemand?
Sonst baut keiner wirklich nennenswert Windows-Mobile-Phones in irgendwelchen Stückzeilen. Also ich glaube, die sind sowieso 95% aller Windows-Mobile-Phones, kommt von HTC. Und ich glaube nicht daran, dass die Leute glauben, dass WebOS toll ist. Weil vielleicht mögen das ein paar User denken und vielleicht haben sie damit auch recht, weil es für sie gut ist, wie das User-Interface funktioniert. Aber ich denke, die Wahrnehmung in dem Telekomarkt ist eine andere. Und da zählt einfach nur, wie kriege ich meine Telefone verkauft? Und was ist derzeit der Hype? Und der Hype ist halt iPhone und Android. Und der Hype ist vor allem Apps. Und Android ist das einzige OS, was überhaupt derzeit nennenswert Programmierer um sich scharen kann, um wirklich Applikationen zu machen, vor allem im Hinblick auf massenkompatible Anwendungen, wie zum Beispiel Spiele. Und da ist einfach Palm überhaupt nicht präsent. Die haben einfach nur eher JavaScript-basiertes Ding. Und das mag die Zukunft sein, Web-Anwendungen, da glaube ich auch dran, aber es ist nicht die Gegenwart.
Naja, aber man könnte durchaus, wenn man nicht so arrogant wäre, wie Palm es ist, könnte man, vielleicht wäre sogar Google ein geeigneter Übernahmekandidat für Palm, um Androiden von dem Free User Interface zu geben. Weil das User Interface...
Ja, die kaufen sich vielleicht die Leute irgendwie.
Naja, und die Patente. Ich nehme an, dass Palm auch ein paar Patente drauf haben wird auf das User Interface. Und was... Android ist ein...
Interessanter Gedanke.
Ist eine gute Plattform, aber das User Interface ist halt scheiße und... Palm hat ein geiles User Interface.
Und einen Brand-Namen, der noch halbwegs was wert ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie auf den so unglaubliche Werte Wert legen würden, aber...
Kann nicht schaden. Google Palm Nexus Edition.
Also wenn sich Android ein paar Scheiben von WebOS abschneiden würde, dann...
Dafür braucht man die nicht aufkaufen.
Die liegen da. Ich meine, Google kommt vorbei, sagt oh guck mal, hier liegt Palm rum, nehme ich mit. Warum sollen die sich da großartig auf irgendwelche Patentstreit einlassen oder irgendwie sowas?
Die machen die nicht.
Ich finde den Gedanken ganz interessant. Ich glaube trotzdem nicht, dass sie es tun. Ich kann aber nicht sagen warum. Einfach nur so aus diesem, ich denke, dass sie da schon irgendwie ihre Leute zusammengesucht haben und jetzt gerade nicht unbedingt die Notwendigkeit verspüren, nochmal irgendwelche Leute aus einer OS-Entwicklung, die jetzt ganz stolz sind auf ihren Teil und sich nicht ihre Lieblingsfeatures wegkürzen lassen wollen von anderen Teammitgliedern, dass sie die nicht so einfach integriert bekommen und dass sie mit Android ja eigentlich einen guten Lauf haben.
Ich denke auch eher aus der Perspektive, wo würde am meisten von WebOS überleben? Also ich finde, das ist ein gutes Betriebssystem, wie ich schon mehrfach erwähnt habe und hätte gerne das davon eine Menge überlebt. Und das sehe ich eben tendenziell, wenn HTC das kaufen würde, würde das Betriebssystem komplett überleben, würde ich toll finden. Bei Google hätte das User Interface noch starkes. Wenn Nokia Palm aufkauft, dann würde WebOS ein Eintrag in einer Akte werden.
Ich denke, dass Motorola der bessere Kandidat wäre als HTC, weil sie Amerikaner sind. Die sind einfach kulturell, mit den Palm-Leuten, die könnten gleich vom ersten Tag anfangen, irgendwas Sinnvolles zu tun, aber sich, glaube ich, mit den Asiaten da auf einen Weg zu einigen. Asien kann gut Masse produzieren, aber innovativ ist es einfach noch ein anderes Ding.
Also gerade bei HTC sieht das ein bisschen anders aus. Für Android haben die ja diese eigene Oberfläche, dieses HTC Sense. Die haben auch eine eigene Oberfläche für ihre Windows-Mobile-Fones. Das ist jetzt alles nur oberflächlich, gar keine Frage. Aber da haben sie schon bewiesen, wir wissen, wie man gute Software macht. Weil jeder, der HTC Sense benutzt, sagt, hey, das ist gut. Für viele Leute ist das ein Grund, ein HTC-Handy zu kaufen, und nicht von einem anderen Hersteller, weil da diese Oberfläche drauf ist. Und die sind ja nicht nur ein billiger Massenproduzent, sondern die haben wirklich schöne Telefone, die auch ein bisschen durchaus technische Features bieten. Also nicht nur rein chipsatsmäßig, sondern vom Design her. Zum Beispiel ist ja dieses HTC, wie heißt das Ding jetzt? Der Nachverhörer vom Hero? Legend heißt das. Das ist auch so wie ein MacBook komplett aus einem Aluminiumblock gefräst und hat darum keine beweglichen Teile mehr und ist darum super stabil und so was. Die nehmen auch Geld in die Hand, um wirklich tolle Dinge zu entwickeln. Und insofern könnte das vielleicht ganz gut klappen. Wohingegen bei Motorola, das Milestone oder Droid oder wie auch immer man es nennt, das ist jetzt bestimmt ein okes Telefon und kein schlechtes. Und die Leute, die das haben, sind auch alle sehr glücklich damit. Was Motorola sonst noch so raushaut, also sie haben ja noch ein paar Android-Telefone, das sind alles eher so kleine billige Crapware. Und Motorola, ich glaube, die sind selber noch nicht so ganz wieder auf der grünen Wiese. Denen geht es doch selber noch nicht so richtig blendend. Und wenn dann der eine Hersteller, dem es nicht gut geht, dem anderen Playersteller, der Pleite aufkauft...
Aber Palm ist halt etwas, ich weiß nicht genau, wie Motorola so drauf ist. Aber guck mal, wobei hat Apple Erfolg? Apple hat damit Erfolg, dass sie es anders machen. Die haben irgendwie eine eigene Idee, sie haben ihre eigene Vision, sie haben ihr eigenes OS, sie bauen ihre eigene Telefone, sie tun es einfach und positionieren sich eben auch, indem sie anders sind. Android ist mittlerweile halt das Ding, was irgendwie alle haben werden. Das wird so das Default-OS, wenn dir sonst nichts einfällt, nimmst du halt Android. Und wenn dir auch kein eigenes User-Interface dafür einfällt, dann nimmst du halt das, was von Google so rausfällt.
Das ist ja auch nicht ganz verkehrt.
Genau, packst du drauf, super und so weiter, funktioniert definitiv noch besser als das, was bisher alles so da war. Aber die Differenzierung ist schwierig, das merkst du ja auch schon. In diesem ganzen Android-Wald, da weiß, ich meine, gut, wenn man da jetzt wirklich die ganze Zeit mitliest, dann weiß man, welches Telefon jetzt auf welches folgt, aber ich komm da einfach permanent durcheinander. Legend, Hero, Droids, Schnickes und so weiter. Du hast keine Ahnung, wie die zusammenhängen. Du weißt überhaupt nicht, wem, was jetzt eigentlich gehört. Gehört es dem Provider, gehört es dem Hersteller, gehört es Google? Ja, also es ist vollkommen unklar, wer überhaupt dafür sorgt, dass diese Marke vorankommt und welches Telefon mit was zu tun hat und was überhaupt übertragbar ist. Laufen da die gleichen Applikationen drauf oder nicht? Diese Betriebssystemversion, diese Betriebsversion, das ist ein Wildwuchs derzeit. Man kann es auch Markt nennen, aber okay.
Ja egal, erzähl weiter.
Ich nenne es Wildwuchs. Keine Ahnung, wie Motorola drauf ist, aber sie hatten ja auch mal eine Zeit lang durchaus so einen Lauf mit ihrem Razer und so weiter. Würden sie jetzt Palm nehmen und Palm, was die Leute von Palm bestimmt ganz toll finden, so ernst nehmen und sagen, okay, ihr habt die Power-User-Interfaces, euch auszudenken, ihr habt auch irgendwie eine Vision, wie man Application-Interfaces baut, um Programmierer anzuziehen. Ihr wart da jetzt noch nicht sonderlich erfolgreich, aber wir glauben an euch. Und wir wissen aber, wie man Telefone baut. Lasst uns zusammenschmeißen. Und dann ist Motorola auch so eine Plattform und so eine Brand und wir gehen halt den Weg der Web-Kompatibilität. Und so versuchen wir halt auch in diesem Application-Markt zu überleben, was schwierig sein wird. Aber ich könnte mir das vorstellen, dass sie so denken.
Also ich halte Motorola für relativ hemmsärmlich und ich glaube, die passen von der Firmenkultur nicht so zu Palme. Palme spielt jetzt mit Ruhmstein so sehr auf Apple und Glossy und alles schick und Motorola ist ja immer eher so... Also dieses Milestone, das sieht...
Ja, aber der Razer war irgendwie über Jahre die Ikone. Das war das erfolgreichste Telefon auf dem amerikanischen Markt.
Ja, aber auch das war eigentlich kein wirklich schönes... Also es war jetzt kein designtes Telefon. Also das Gehäuse vielleicht, aber das User-Interface sah immer aus wie eine Katastrophe.
Ja, das ist gut, aber ich rede ja vom Telefon, also von der Hardware. Und ihre Schwäche ist die Software. Deswegen wäre das ja ein gut Match.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass Motorola, dass die wirklich... Das ist jetzt wirklich meine Fast-Ratch-Theorie über die...
Das war in Matrix dieses Telefon.
In Matrix? Nee, im Moment, weil die hatten noch dieses... Also zumindest im ersten Teil hatten die noch dieses Nokia-Aufklapp-Ding, wo dann unten so was rausgefahren ist. Das war ein Nokia? Im ersten Matrix, das war ein Nokia.
Stimmt das.
Ja, schweißt da so eine Mülleimer, so diese Zeitlupenzähne, wie er es dann so in Mülleimer wirft und dann so langsam dieses Nokia 700... Das ist auch 10 Jahre her, man.
Ich hatte jetzt nur so aufklapp... War das nicht ein Aufklapp?
Ne, unten ist da so ein Ding rausgefahren, so ein Kind quasi.
Ich dachte, das war so ein Aufklappteil. Nicht bei Matix, aber die ganze Zeit so Aufklapptelefon in der Hand? Ich muss mal wieder Matix sehen.
Hier hat sogar jemand den StackEvil schreibt gerade 7.110. Das ist also...
Kiek an! Na so cool ist Nokia! Gewesen.
Ob man 63.10 immer noch, das ist einfach best Telefon ever, aber es hält auch ein Telefon kein Smartphone. Aber wenn der Krieg ausbricht und du brauchst mal ein zufälliges Telefon, das ist genau das.
Wenn der Krieg ausbricht und du brauchst ein zufälliges Telefon. Was liegt denn dann noch so an, wenn mal ein Krieg ausbricht, Kiste?
Na, eine dicke Mac-Lite mit ordentlich viel Saft.
Ein paar dreieinhalb Zollesketten.
Zum Beispiel, genau.
Leute, wir reden schon wieder viel zu lange.
Drei Stunden sind schon wieder voll locker.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt hier mal langsam hin. Haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges?
Ja, ich möchte noch eine App empfehlen, das geht auch ratzfatz. Und zwar, wenn man Google-Reader auf dem iPhone nutzen will, ist das wirklich Reader mit Doppel-E vorne. R-E-E-D-E-R. Nichts. Der ist wirklich, zum einen, der synchronisiert deinen Account, lädt alle Bilder runter, das heißt, wenn du z.B. an Bord eines Flugzeugs steigst, startest du vorher das ab, der lädt alles runter und du kannst den ganzen Flug überlesen, was sehr, sehr geil ist.
Was, Moment, halt, stopp. Der lädt alle Webseiten runter?
Nein, der lädt den Artikel mit Bildern runter.
Also das, was im RSS, also den Full Feed plus Bilder ist?
Genau.
Ah ja, ok, das ist ja schon mal ganz cool.
Was schon mal ganz schön schnell ist. Und zum zweiten ist es so, wenn man, der hat eine geile, man kann die Artikel sehr gut lesen, weil du brauchst nicht, also bei anderen ist das ja so, du klickst auf einen Artikel, tippst auf einen Artikel durch, dann gehst du wieder zurück, fallt zurück, nimmst den nächsten Artikel raus, immer weiter, immer weiter. Bei dem Ding ist das einfach, du scrollst durch und wenn du am Ende eines Artikels bist, ist das so ein bisschen wie bei Tweety. Also am Anfang und am Ende, dass er dann den nächsten so, dann ziehst du kurz rüber, dann zeigt er an, wenn du jetzt loslässt, dann lade ich den nächsten, dann macht er den nächsten. Das liest sich sagenhaft schnell. Du kannst alles offline machen, also wenn man sagt, star mir das, twittere das, was weiß ich was, kannst du auch, wenn du gerade kein Netz hast, machen, wenn du im Flugzeug sitzt, mach da alles, sobald das nächste Mal online ist, ist wirklich im Augenblick für mich der... Den gab's schon vorher, Version 1 war schon gut.
Ich bin sehr unglücklich mit meinen RSS-Riddern auf dem iPhone, ich werd den mal ausprobieren.
Der ist wirklich für mich...
Ich hab den jetzt gekauft.
Der ist super.
Ka-Ching.
Gute Entscheidung.
Wenn der aufs iPad kommt, bin ich so richtig glücklich.
Gibt's aber noch nicht für iPad.
Gibt's noch nicht für iPad. Hab ja auch noch kein iPad, insofern interessiert's ja noch auch noch. Ja, das wollte ich unbedingt noch loswerden.
Aber alle Kinder wollen einen haben. So, wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig. Wir haben nicht geredet über das We-Pad.
Ich weiß, dass das eine Arbeit ist. Ich schwör mich auch schon drauf.
Und das war's, oder? Leute.
Hat es auch lang genug?
Ja, drei Stunden.
Über drei Stunden.
Über drei Stunden. Das wird wieder ewig dauern, bis ich das fertig geschnitten hab. Letztes Wort, Dennis?
I'm done.
I'm done. Du bist durch, Max?